ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO THE
JOINT INFORMATIONAL HEARING BY
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WERE VERY HAPPY TO BE LOOKING
AT THIS ISSUE OF ASSESSING THE
IMPACT ON JUSTICE OF THE COVERT
PANDEMIC IN HOW WE CAN IDENTIFY
BEST PRACTICES. AND IN
ULTIMATELY MOVE FORWARD- TO
COMMITTEES HAVE LONG TRIED TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO JUSTICE SAID
IN A COVERT. INFLUENCE WORLD
THAT HAS BECOME MORE AND MORE
DIFFICULT AND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES I THINK THAT WE'VE
SEEN REPORTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
GETTING. CENTER AROUND
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF IMPACT FOR
A FROM THE DIFFERENT COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE WE'RE SEEING
THAT IN THE PRACTICAL FRANCISCO
GOOD RESPONSE BUT ALSO IN THE
JUSTICE RESPONSE IN THE ABILITY
OF COURTS TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE.
WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO AND ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE STILL CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO THE JUSTICE THAT THAT
THEY DESERVE. SO WE ARE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ALL
THE INFORMATION WE CAN. ENSURE
THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE JUDICIARY
BRANCH IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
APPROACH THAT WE CAN BRING. TO
ENSURE JUSTICE IN ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES AND MAKE SURE
THAT ALL THE SYSTEMS ARE
WORKING AS WE WOULD EXPECT. SO
LIKE TO WELCOME CENTER ON BURKE
IN THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE I KNOW THAT MEMBERS
WILL BE COMING IN AND OUT OF
OUR HEARING. AS WE PARTICULARLY
AS AS WE GO ON WITH THE
AFTERNOON I THINK. THERE A LOT
OF CAUCUS HEARINGS AND OTHERS
GOING ON THIS AFTERNOON SO I
KNOW WILL HAVE. MEMBERS
WATCHING REMOTELY BUT ALSO
TRYING TO- SHOW UP TO OUR
CHAMBERS AS. OR THE HEARING
ROOM AS AS POSSIBLE. THIS IS
BEEN A REALLY I THINK A GOOD
EXERCISE BETWEEN THE TWO
COMMITTEES AND I WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF BOTH THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY FOR AN EXCELLENT
BACKGROUND PAPER I KNOW THIS
TOOK A LOT OF COORDINATION AND
COOPERATION AND INTERESTINGLY
COORDINATION AND COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE HOUSES TO GET THE
TECHNOLOGY STRAIGHT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN ALL
PARTICIPATE. YOU THINK IT WOULD
BE EASY AT THIS POINT BUT-
WE'RE GETTING THERE. FROM A
TECHNICAL AND PRACTICAL
STANDPOINT I JUST NEED TO GO
THROUGH SOME OF THE LOGISTICS
HERE. SO DO TO CONTINUE TO STAY
HOME ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL. WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE. IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON WE ALSO
REQUIRE THAT MASKS BE WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ANY AND ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
TESTIFYING THIS HEARING ROOM
AND IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK
WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU.
BECAUSE OUR SPACE LIMITATIONS
WE HAVE. SOME COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SITTING IN THE DIENSTE AND
OTHERS SITTING IN. THE FIRST
HEROES POTENTIALLY. OF THE
AUDIENCE AND FOR THOSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK DURING THE
HEARING. PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE BEHIND THE
PLEXIGLAS. AND ALSO REMEMBER
TO. ACTIS PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UNFORTUNATELY IF WE DO HAVE
MEMBERS IN THOSE SEATS IN THE
AUDIENCE WE DON'T HAVE
MICROPHONES AT THOSE SEATS. AND
FROM THE DYESS. WE WILL OPERATE
AS NORMALLY FOR MEMBERS WHO ARE
ONLINE AND OBSERVING IF YOU'D
LIKE TO ASK QUESTIONS TO BE
RECOGNIZED IT'S LIKE SURE THAT
YOU ARE WAITING SURE YOU'RE
CALLING ON SO THAT I CAN SEE.
YOU CAN ALSO TRY TEXTING ME BUT
I MAY NOT BE ABLE TO PICK UP.
THOSE TEXT AND NOT ALL OF THE
OFFICES HAVE THE ABILITY TO USE
A REYES HAND TYPE FUNCTION. ON
THE EQUIPMENT SO. TRYING TO GET
MY ATTENTION THROUGH YOUR
CAMERA MIGHT BE THE BEST. FOR
THE PUBLIC HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
TWO WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE.
MINIMAL A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF
STAFF ANY LIMIT NUMBER OF. THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA HERE AS LONG
AS WE MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF.
SPACING THEY'RE ALSO PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. AS WELL AS IN THIS
HEARING ROOM IF ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND. WHEN WE COME TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND UNLESS YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE OF THE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. PLEASE
DO NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
AND ALLOW SPACE FOR OTHERS TO
BE ABLE TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE AS WELL. FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO
COMMENT BY A TELEPHONE. AND
AGAIN DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD AT THE END OF THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. THERE IS
A TOLL FREE NUMBER WHICH IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THAT
NUMBER SHOULD BE APPEARING ON
YOUR SCREEN AGAIN. 877-692-8957
AND THERE'S THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE OF FOUR TWO. OH TWO. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE AGAIN THAT IS
FOUR TWO- TWO ONE THREE ONE
FIVE. AND FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN COMMENTS WHICH
WE HIGHLY ENCOURAGE EITHER NOW
OR IN THE FUTURE BASED ON WHAT
YOU HEAR AT THIS HEARING OR
OTHER PERSPECTIVES ON THIS
SUBJECT. YOU CAN PROVIDE THOSE
TO THE COMMITTEE THERE'S
INFORMATION ON HOW TO CONTACT
THE COMMITTEES EITHER SENATE
JUDICIARY OR ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY. ON ARE RELEVANT.
COMMITTEE WEBSITES AND ALSO
PLEASE NOTE THAT WHILE WE'RE
DOING OUR BEST WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CONNECTED IF THEY ARE AT HOME
DEPENDING ON THEIR SYSTEM THERE
MAY OR MAY NOT BE. TECHNICAL
ISSUES OF EVERYONE WOULD JUST
PLEASE. SHARE WITH US SO WITH
THAT I'M GONNA TURN OVER TO
SENATOR- BURKE FOR OPENING
REMARKS WELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN STONE AND THANK YOU
FOR INITIATING THIS JOINT
COOPERATION I GET BODES WELL
FOR THE YEAR THE TWO HOUSES AS
WELL AS THE TWO COMMITTEES
MEETING TOGETHER FOR THE FIRST
TIME. TO DISCUSS THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT SUBJECT
THANKS TO THE STAFF-
PARTICULARLY TO ON OUR SIDE
MARGE'S STARTED ALSO MERRILEES
FOR ALL THE GOOD WORK THEY DID
IN ANTICIPATION IN PREPARATION
FOR THIS HEARING- AS WE KNOW
THERE'S BEEN OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND US. THE SCOLDED
PANDEMIC HAS IMPACTED EVERY
THING WE DO IN LIFE SOME THINGS
AFFECT THE QUALITY OF OUR LIFE
BEING ABLE TO GO TO RESTAURANTS
GYMS IN THE LIKE. IN SUMMER
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL SERVICES
MCCOURT'S FALL INTO THAT
CATEGORY THE IMPACT ON. COVERT
NON COURTS IS UNDENIABLE- WE'VE
HAD MANY. BOTH INDIVIDUALS AS
WELL AS INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
GONE A LONG WAY TO. TRYING TO.
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGE WITH
RESPECT TO ACCESS TO JUSTICE
DURING THE PANDEMIC THEY'VE
DONE SOME INNOVATIVE THINGS AND
WE CONGRATULATE THEM- WE MADE
STRIDES IN TERMS OF REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS- WE'VE ENACTED
LEGISLATION TO. ENABLE
DISCOVERY- DURING THE PANDEMIC
BUT WE STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO WE STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO
GO. BOTH FOR WHAT'S GOING ON
NOW IN ANTICIPATION OF THE
NEXT. DISASTER THE NEXT
PANDEMIC THAT MAY AFFLICT
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE FORTUNATE
STAY HERE FROM A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT EXPERTS TALK ABOUT
BEST PRACTICES. OF BOTH
ATTORNEYS AND FROM THE COURTS
WE HAVE A MUTUAL INTEREST WITH
THE COURTS AND MUTUAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT. CALIFORNIANS CAN SEE CAN
HAVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE- BY THE
WAY IS CHAIRMAN STONE IT
INDICATED. ALL WHILE WE'RE HERE
TODAY SOME OF US ARE HERE IN
PERSON BUT WE UP TERMS OF
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WELCOME ANY.
GOOD IDEAS WE WELCOME WRITTEN
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMUNITY AND
SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR I'LL
TURN IT BACK OVER TO YOU. BOB
THANK YOU I THINK OUR- NEXT
STEP IS TO GET SOME
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS FROM THE
ARTS ARE CHIEF JUSTICE WE'VE
BEEN INTRODUCED HI I WILL THE
CHIEF OF ENERGY IS HERE AND
STANDING BY. SHE IS HERE
INSTEAD WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOUR HONORED AND
PRIVILEGED TO HAVE WITH US
TODAY CHIEF JUSTICE TANI CANTIL
SUKHU A- THE CHIEF JUSTICE IS
SPRING COURT HAS SERVED. OUR
COMMUNITY IN OUR STATE FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS AT EVERY LEVEL OF
COURT TRIAL COURT APPELLATE
COURT- SHE HAS BEEN AN
INNOVATOR. AND IN FACT SHE WAS
THE PERSON WHO YES TO THE FIRST
QUARTER IN SACRAMENTO. THAT WAS
DEDICATED TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ISSUES. SHE HAS ADDRESSED THE
HERCULEAN TASK OF MAKING SURE
THE COURTS AS WE MENTIONED A
MOMENT AGO. REMAIN OPEN AND
ACCESSIBLE DURING THE COURSE OF
THE PANDEMIC IN SO MANY AREAS-
SHE HAS BEEN AN INNOVATIVE
LEADER. OF THIS YEAR WITH
DIRECTIONS EVICTIONS BEING. A
AN ACUTE ISSUE FOR THE COURTS
AND FOR CALIFORNIANS- SHE HAS
LED THE WAY IN MAKING SURE
THAT. THERE IS SOME RELIEF-
BOTH IN TERMS OF THE ACCESS TO
COURTS IT IS WELL AS WITH
RESPECT TO BEING ABLE TO STAY
IN ONE'S ABODE- AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE. IS THE DAM IS THE
PANDEMIC ENTERS ITS SECOND YEAR
THE CHIEF JUSTICE CONTINUES TO
LEAD THE JUDICIARY WITH VISION
AND DETERMINATION AND WE'RE
MOST GRATEFUL. FOR HER TAKING
THE TIME. OUT OF HER VERY BUSY
IMPORTANT SCHEDULED TO VISIT
WITH US HERE FOR A FEW MOMENTS.
WITH THAT- MAN CHIEF JUSTICE OF
IF YOU'RE HERE WE WELCOME YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON IT IS
A PLEASURE AND A PRIVILEGE TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU HOWEVER
REMOTELY BUT I AM SAYING FIRST
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR MANY YEARS OF WISE
COUNSEL AND LEADERSHIP AS
TOGETHER WE HAVE WORKED ON SOME
VERY DIFFICULT ISSUES AND
TOGETHER WE HAVE BEEN FRANK BUT
ALWAYS WITH GOOD INTENTIONS
WILL BE AT THE STATE WILL WORK
I LOOK FORWARD TO MANY MORE
YEARS OF THAT KIND OF
PARTNERSHIP. AND THANK YOU
SENATOR- BURKE ALSO. YOU ARE
OUR NEWEST MEMBER OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WHICH I CHAIR
AND I THOROUGHLY ENJOYED OUR
FIRST MEETING TOGETHER LAST
MONTH. AS WELL AS OUR
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD IN
BETWEEN I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND RELY ON
BOTH YOU AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONES. PRACTICAL WISDOM AND
EXPERIENCE AS WE LEAD JUSTICE
FOR IN CALIFORNIA. I'M ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
WITH MY COLLEAGUES SOME OF THE
PANELISTS AND PARTNERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS OTHER ANALYSTS
TODAY. TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT IT'S BEEN LIKE SINCE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY. AND I WANT
TO START OFF BY SAYING BECAUSE
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT IT WAS
EXACTLY WE NOW KNOW IT IS
AFFECTED AS YOU SAID SENATOR-
BURKE EVERY ASPECT OF LIFE NO
PERSON NO ENTITY. HAS BEEN
UNTOUCHED BY THIS PANDEMIC BUT
IN THE BEGINNING IN MARCH NOT
KNOWING WHAT IT WAS I TOOK THE
STEP OF PUBLISHING
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT ADVISORIES.
TO THE JUDICIARY REMINDING THEM
IN CAJOLING THEM AND BRINGING
TO THEM BEST PRACTICES WELL WE
TRIED TO FIGURE OUT SEVERAL
THINGS WHAT THIS ONCE WHAT IT
MEANT TO US AS AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICE. AND HOW WE WOULD GO
FORWARD TO PROTECT THE SAFETY
NOT ONLY OF THE PUBLIC BUT ALSO
AS IMPORTANT OUR COURT STAFF
AND OUR JURISTS. AND AS YOU
KNOW THOSE EIGHT ADVISORIES
TURNED INTO THIRTEEN EMERGENCY
TEMPORARY STATEWIDE ORDERS BY
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH THE
PANDEMIC AT THIS TIME IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAD THOUGHT
HAD REACHED ITS APEX LITTLE DID
WE KNOW OF THE SURGES TO COME
AND THE DIFFERENT RULES. BUT IT
WAS THIS VERY SAME PANDEMIC
THAT FORCED THE LEGISLATURE.
OUT OF SESSION FOR
APPROXIMATELY TWO MONTHS AND
PART OF THE SUMMER. AND WE
DECIDED WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO STEP IN TO
TEMPORARILY FILL THE VOID THAT
WE KNEW YOU WOULD CONSIDER ONCE
YOU CAME BACK FROM BEING OUT OF
SESSION. AND THAT'S WHEN WE
PASSED AS YOU HAVE REFER TO THE
ORDER THAT STOPPED UNLAWFUL
DETAINER EVICTIONS THE ORDERS
THAT SET NO BAIL BECAUSE WE
WERE CONCERNED AS A JUDICIARY.
ABOUT INFECTIONS IN THE JAIL
AND PRISONS AND THE
TRANSFERENCE OF THAT INTO THE
COURT HOUSES. YOU KNOW WITH A
STATEWIDE RULES I WANT TO SAY
ONE THING OR TWO THINGS
ACTUALLY STATEWIDE RULES AS YOU
KNOW ARE RIFE WITH CHALLENGE
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS SO
DIVERSE. I STATEWIDE RULES ARE
RIFE WITH CHALLENGE BECAUSE SO
MANY TIMES WE ARE OFTEN ACCUSED
AT LEAST I HAVE BEEN IN MYRIAD
LAWSUITS IN FEDERAL AND STATE
COURT. OF UNDERMINING LOCAL
DIVERSE LEADERSHIP. OF
PRESUMING SUPERIORITY WITH
ABSTRACT WISDOM OVER BOOTS ON
THE GROUND EXPERIENCE AND
TRUST. AND STATEWIDE ORDERS
ALSO CAN BE DIFFICULT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE CULTURE OF THE COMMUNITY. I
KNOW YOU YOURSELVES ARE
GRAPPLING WITH UNIFORM
STATEWIDE ORDERS HAVING TO DO
WITH SCHOOLS AND SPORTS AND-
VACCINE ROLLOUTS AS WELL AS- A
NUMBER OF ISSUES WHERE IT SEEMS
SO SIMPLE TO SAVE A STATEWIDE
RULE WOULD WORK. BUT WE KNOW
THAT THAT IS NOT ALWAYS THE
BANDAID THAT REALLY SUFFICES TO
FIX THE PROBLEM. IN ADDITION TO
THE THIRTEEN PASSED STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY ORDERS. I HAVE
REVIEWED IN MY CAPACITY CHAIR
AND CHIEF. OVER FOR AND SEVENTY
EMERGENCY ORDERS. REQUESTED BY
THE PRESIDING JUDGES OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COURTS NOW IT MAKES
AN EMERGENCY ORDER UNDER SIXTY
EIGHT ONE ONE FIVE IS NOT IN
YOUR PAGE. IT IS PAGES AND
PAGES OF REASON AND MATERIAL
THAT BACKS UP THIS REQUEST BY
THE PRESIDING JUDGE ELECTED BY
HIS OR HER PEERS. TO PROPER FOR
ME TO PROVIDE AUTHORITY THAT
THEY CAN USE AS NEEDED TO
ALLEVIATE THE CONSTITUTIONAL OR
AND OR STATUTORY PROVISIONS
REGARDING. BOTH CRIMINAL AND
SOME CIVIL MATTERS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY AND
COUNTING EXECUTIVE OUR
EMERGENCY ORDERS AND YOU ASK
WHY SO MANY ORDERS FRANKLY I
ASKED THE SAME QUESTION. WHEN I
READ THROUGH THE MATERIAL
SUBMITTED BY THE PRESIDING
JUDGES OF EACH COUNTY ASKING
FOR AN EMERGENCY ORDER THE SITE
TO THE MYRIAD CHANGING LOCAL
HELP ORDERS. THE MYRIAD
CHANGING STATEWIDE ORDERS THE
DIFFERENT. THAT THE DIFFERENT
EXPERTS. THE DIFFERENCE IN
SIZES OF COURTROOMS AND HERE IS
THE KEY. OUT RIGHT FEAR OF
JURORS TO COME TO COURT. JUDGES
ARE PUT IN A VERY DIFFICULT
SPOT WE ARE ASKING PEOPLE SO
MANY PEOPLE TO COME TO COURT SO
THAT. AN ACCUSED MAY HAVE THEIR
DAY IN COURT. ARIF TO COME IT'S
NOT THE THEY DON'T WANT TO FEEL
OUT THE RISK OF OTHER DUTY
THERE ARE FREIGHT EVEN THOUGH
THE COURTS HAVE PLEXIGLAS AND
THERMOMETERS I EVERY MATTER OF
PROTECTIVE GEAR. WHO CAN BLAME
TEACHERS FOR BEING AFRAID NO I
USED TO BE A TRIAL ATTORNEY I
MYSELF DON'T WANNA JUROR WHO'S
AFRAID TO BE IN COURT WITH ME.
AND SO IT MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT BUT IMPORTANTLY TO
REMEMBER THAT EVEN WITH THE
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY I
MERGING SEE ORDERS ARE COURTS
HAVE NEVER CLOSED I AM AWARE OF
ONLY TWO COURTS THAT CLOSED.
DURING THE INITIAL PERID OF
THE PANDEMIC THAT WAS PRIMARILY
TO CLEAN TO START UP AND START
OVER. BUT TO MY KNOWLEDGE BASED
ON MY READING OF FOUR HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY AND COUNTY
EMERGENCY ORDERS. ALL COURTS
HAVE REMAINED OPEN THEY OFFER
REMOTE HEARINGS MANY ARE
OFFERING JURY TRIALS BUT THE
JURY TRIALS ARE BEING
INTERRUPTED BECAUSE A JUROR IS
EXPOSED A STAFFER IS EXPOSED AN
INMATE IS EXPOSED AND THEY END
UP BEING MISS TRIED AND WE
START OVER AGAIN. ADDITIONALLY
TO BECAUSE OF THE STRUCTURE OF
COURTHOUSES SORT OF LIKE
SCHOOLS WE CAN'T ACCOMMODATE
NUMBERS AND CRITICAL MASS
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO SOCIALLY
DISTANCE. SO OUR BRICK AND
MORTAR IS SOMEWHAT A BARRIER TO
THE ABILITY TO CALL MASS GROUPS
OF PEOPLE TO SIT FOR JURORS.
SOME COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY INNOVATIVE AND A
CONTRACTED OUT WITH GYMS AND
SPORTS ARENAS IN ORDER THAT
THEY CAN BRING IN JURORS AND
SOCIALLY DISTANCE THEM TO
SELECTORS. SO THIS IS A LONG
WAY OF SAYING. THAT WHILE WE'VE
BEEN OPEN AND IF WE'RE NOT
WORKING ON THE CASE THE TRIAL
JUDGE'S ARC ARE VALUABLE COURT
STAFF OR COURT EMPLOYEES WERE
NOT WORKING ON A CASE WE'RE
MEETING WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS
WITHOUT LEGAL AID WITH
PLAINTIFFS LAWYERS WITH.
DEFENSE LAWYERS WE'RE TRYING TO
FOR FIND BETTER FOR WHERE HE IN
THE- ABOUT WHAT WORKING WHAT
ISN'T WORKING. I ALWAYS ASK FOR
WHICH COUNTY ARE YOU HAVING
PROBLEMS IN BECAUSE WE CAN GET
MESSAGES AND HELP AND BEST
PRACTICES TO THOSE COUNTIES
WHERE THEY MAY BE A PROBLEM.
BUT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE OUR
EYES AND EARS OPEN AND YOU MAY
WANT TO KNOW THIS WHO IS IN OUR
COURT NOW. WELL THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE COURT NOW ARE THE PEOPLE
WHOARE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
STATUTORY LAW THAT LEGISLATORS
BEFORE YOU HAVE SAID DESERVE
PRIORITY. AND THOSE ARE PEOPLE
ACCUSED OF CRIME PEOPLE WHOSE
LIBERTY IS AT STAKE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN CUSTODY. OF FAMILIES
THAT ARE FALLING APART BECAUSE
PARENTS SPOUSES PARTNERS HAVE
LOST JOBS BECAUSE THEIR HOMES
ARE AT RISK ALSO YOU KNOW WHO'S
IN OUR COURTS. CHILDREN
CHILDREN WHO IT'S UNSAFE
IMAGINE THAT IT'S UNSAFE FOR
THEM TO BE AT HOME NOW AND
COURTS MUST. ADDRESS THE ENTIRE
FAMILY TOGETHER. THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE IN OUR COURTS NOW AND WE
TRY TO HELP THEM IN THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND REMOTE POSSIBLE
WAY IN ORDER TO CREATE MORE
ROOM FOR OTHER CASES LIKE
SEVERAL OR OTHER CASES OR
TRIALS. WHAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH A CRISIS IN OUR POPULATION
AND IF THERE IS CRISIS IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS. YOU CAN ONLY
IMAGINE. THE CRISIS AT HOME.
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
HEARING TODAY LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR COLLABORATION I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOU UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE JUDICIARY HAS BEEN
DOING IN THE LAST YEAR WITH A
10% CUT. TO OUR STAFFING. OUT
WHERE WE WERE NOT FULLY FUNDED
TO BEGIN WITH. BUT TO THE TRIAL
JUDGES TO OUR COURT EMPLOYEES
OUT THERE I HAVE NOTHING BUT
THANKS GRATITUDE AND AWE FOR
WHAT YOU ARE DOING. AND I GIVE
YOU STRENGTH BECAUSE YOU GIVE
ME STRENGTH. THANK YOU. FOR
THESE MOMENTS TO MAKE THESE
REMARKS. THANK YOU MADAM CHIEF
JUSTICE. THANK YOU MADAME CHIEF
JUSTICE I THINK WE VERY VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THEY- ARE
ALSO LEGISLATURE YOUR ROLE AS A
AS THE JUDICIARY AND THEY WERE
ALL LEARNING ABOUT THE
INTERPLAY AND HOW WE BEST AS AS
TWO. BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT CAN
WORK TOGETHER AND THE- YOUR
LAST POINT THAT I THINK IS VERY
WELL TAKEN THIS HEARING IS FOR
US TO UNDERSTAND. THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE UP
AGAINST AND WAYS THAT WE CAN BE
HELPFUL AND TO PARTNER AND
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE CENTER. I'M GLAD THAT
YOU MENTIONED THE COURTS
FUNDING ISSUE IS WE'VE
STRUGGLED WITH THAT OVER THE
YEARS IN THE IMPACTS. THAT HAS
LED TO A LACK OF ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IS YOU AND YOUR COURTS
VERY WELL NOW NOW WERE
COMPOUNDED WITH THE COVE IT.
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US AND
YOUR BEING HERE WITH US TODAY.
SO WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVE TO OUR
PANELS WE HAVE FOUR PANELS WE
HAVE A PRETTY LONG HEARING
TODAY SO THE WAY I'D LIKE TO
RUN THIS HEARINGS ALL
INTERVIEWS THE PANELS WILL
HAVE. THE FIRST PANEL SPEAK.
AND THEN OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS FROM
SENATORS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
TO THOSE PANEL MEMBERS IT'S OUR
FIRST PANEL IS AN OVERVIEW OF
THE UNPRECEDENTED IMPACT OF
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC ON THE
COURTS. AND COURT USERS SO
WE'RE STARTING KIND OF TOP
LEVEL AND WE HAVE THE HONORABLE
MARLA- ANDERSON. THE SPIRIT
WORD OF MONTEREY COUNTY FROM MY
BACKYARD SO WHEN I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH FOR QUITE SOME
TIME AND SHE IS. THE CHAIR OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
LEGISLATION COMMITTEE. WE ALSO
HAVE ROBERT- YOUNG THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE TO BE CHIANG C. A.
O. C. THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA PRESIDENT. FOR A
STATE WIDE PERSPECTIVE AND I
UNDERSTAND. WAS CHIANG HAS A
VIDEO PRESENTATION. SO LET'S
START WITH JUDGE ANDERSON.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M TOUCH MARLEY ANDERSON AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT IS
INDICATED CHAIRED THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL LEGISLATION COMMITTEE
AND JUDGE YOUR MONTEREY COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT. AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AND
SENATOR I'M BURKE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS JOINT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE COMMITTEES ON JUDICIARY.
ON THE UNPRECEDENTED IMPACTS
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
HAS HAD ON CALIFORNIA'S COURTS
AND ITS USERS INCLUDING THE
COURTS RESPONSES TO THE
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES
BROUGHT ON BY THE PANDEMIC. AND
THE COURTS CONTINUED EFFORT TO
GATHER DATA TO INFORM TAX
FORWARD FOR THE BENEFIT OF ALL
COURT USERS AND COURT PERSONNEL.
HERE GO WHO WOULD HAVE BELIEVED
THAT TERMS SUCH AS MASK
MANDATES LOCKDOWN SHELTER IN
PLACE SOCIAL DISTANCING
NONESSENTIAL SERVICES REMOTE
WORKER BUILDING CAPACITY. A
VACCINATION PARTY WOULD BE
COMMON TERMS USED TODAY TO
DESCRIBE HOW WE AS A SOCIETY
INTERACT MAKE DECISIONS AND GO
ABOUT OUR DAY. THE PANDEMIC
SLOW DOWN HAS DEEPLY IMPACTED
THE COURTS NOT UNLIKE THAT
EXPERIENCED BY THE BUSINESS
SECTOR GOVERNMENT SERVICES
HEALTH CARE AND EDUCATION. IN
LESS THAN A YEAR COURTS HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY REINVENT
THEMSELVES AND HAVE TRANSFORMED
IN MANY OF THE SERVICES
PROVIDED IN THE METHODS BY
WHICH THE PUBLIC IS SERVERS. IN
SOME RESPECTS FOR THE COURTS
IT'S BEEN MUCH LIKE DESIGNING
AND BUILDING AN AIRCRAFT WHILE
IN FLIGHT. AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
LOCKDOWN IN MARCH DIFFICULT
OPERATION DECISIONS WERE MADE
BY THE COURTS TO BALANCE HEALTH
AND SAFETY. THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AND STATUTORY RIGHTS OF
INDIVIDUALS ACCESSIBILITY. AT
THE OUTSET TO ENABLE RESUMPTION
OF SERVICES IN TO AUTHORIZE
COURTS TO OPERATE UNDER
PANDEMIC CONDITIONS
NOTWITHSTANDING OTHER STATUTORY
PROVISIONS. COURTS REQUESTED
EMERGENCY ORDERS FROM THE CHIEF
JUSTICE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ADOPTED STATEWIDE EMERGENCY
RULES OF COURT AND INDIVIDUAL
COURTS ADOPTED LOCAL EMERGENCY
RULES. THE SUMMERS AND THE
GRAVITY OF PROVIDING EQUAL
ACCESS UNDER PANDEMIC
CONDITIONS. WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF COURT USERS COURT
PERSONNEL AND JUDICIAL OFFICERS
WEIGHED HEAVY ON THE COURTS.
TRIAGING BECAME NECESSARY.
SERVICES SUCH AS TELEPHONE WAIT
TIMES TIMES FOR CITY HEARINGS
AND TRIALS AND DISPOSITION OF
CASES WERE MODERATELY TO
SEVERELY IMPACTED. HOWEVER AS
TIME MOVED ON AND THIS TIME
MOVE FORWARD AND DATA WAS
COLLECTED AND ANALYZED COURTS
BECAME BETTER POSITION TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ADAPTING AND
EVOLVING SERVICES AND METHODS
BY WHICH COURT USERS ARE SERVED.
BUILDING ON FOUNDATIONS FROM
PREVIOUS TECHNOLOGY INVESTMENTS
CORPS IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF
MEASURES TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SAFE ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN
PARTICULAR. MOST COURTS
RECONFIGURED PHYSICAL SPACE TO
ENABLE PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
THEY ALSO IMPLEMENTED REMOTE
HEARINGS AND EXPANDED ON SITE
LOCATIONS FOR JURY SELECTION.
MANY COURT STREAMED HEARINGS
AND PROCEEDINGS TO THE INTERNET
AND OFFERED OTHER ONLINE
SERVICES LIKE LIVE CHAT. AND
REMOTE SELF HELP FOR EXAMPLE
YOUR MODERATE COURT WHERE I
SERVED WE IMPLEMENTED AN
EMERGENCY LOCAL THAT PERMITTED
PARTIES AND COUNSEL TO
STIPULATE TO SUBMIT SYMBOL ON
MOTIONS ON THE PLEADINGS
WITHOUT APPEARANCES OR ARGUMENT.
WE ALSO MOVE CIVIL SETTLEMENT
CONFERENCES TO VIDEO CANCERS
AND WE ALSO PROVIDED STAGGERED
HEARING TIMES AND THE OPTION TO
PROMOTE APPEARANCE BY VIDEO OR
TELEPHONE OR IN PERSON
APPEARANCES FOR FAMILY LAW
PROBATE AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HEARINGS. WE PURCHASED
PLEXIGLAS TO PROVIDE SAFETY FOR
THE JURY BOX COUNSEL TABLE
WITNESS STAND IN JUDGE'S BENCH.
AT THE OUTSET SELF HELP STEP
CONTINUE PROVIDING SERVICES
TELEPHONICALLY AND IT WOULD
HAVE TO PLACE OF REQUESTED
DOCUMENTS OUTSIDE THE DOOR OF
THE COURTHOUSE ON A CART AT A
AND THEN WE PROVIDED A DROP BOX
FOR THE DOCUMENTS TO BE PLACED
IN THE DROP BOX FOR FILING.
THESE ARE SOME OF THE WAYS WE
ANOTHER COURTS ADAPTED TO
PROVIDE ACCESS. HOWEVER NO
MATTER THE SAFETY MEASURES
IMPLEMENTED WE STILL HAD COURTS
STAFF AND A JUDICIAL OFFICER
TEST POSITIVE FOR THE COPA
NINETEEN VIRUS I SEEN ANOTHER
COURTS. RECORDS DURING MARCH TO
DECEMBER IT WAS ADDITIONAL
GROWTH IN THE USE OF TECHNOLOGY
MOST NOTABLY IN THE AREAS OF
DIGITAL SIGNATURES AND WEB
BASED YOUR PROCESSING. AFTER
THE SIGNIFICANT DROP IN COURT
FILINGS IN THE EARLY MONTHS OF
THE PANDEMIC COURT FILINGS FOR
MANY CASE TYPES HAVE RETURNED
TO PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS. AS A
COURTS WORK TO ADDRESS ISSUES
OF KEEPING PACE WITH CASE
LOADS. DATA WILL CONTINUE TO
PROMPT US TO ASK QUESTIONS TO
LOOK FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
PROVIDE MORE ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
AND EFFECTIVELY MANAGE OUR
OPERATIONS. WE'VE MADE IT PAST
THE TREE HOUSING STATE AND
COURT LEADERSHIP HAVE
COLLABORATED TO IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES CIRCULATING THE
PANDEMIC CONTINUITY OF
OPERATIONS RESOURCE GUIDE. WE
CONTINUE TO GRAPPLE WITH
BALANCING HEALTH AND SAFETY DUE
PROCESS AND ACCESSIBILITY
CALIFORNIA'S COURT USERS.
COURTS CONTINUE TO UPDATE THEIR
OPERATION STATUS ON THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA'S
SERVICE STATUS QUO BUT NINETEEN
WEBPAGE. AND THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH WILL CONTINUE TO EXPLORE
THE VARYING WAYS THE DOORS OF
THE COURTS CAN REMAIN OPEN TO
THE PUBLIC WE SERVE. CONTINUING
THE CHIEFS JUSTICE AXIS THREE
D. PLAN FOR THE COURTS WHICH IS
PHYSICAL REMOTE AND EQUAL
ACCESS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AND I'M ROBERT A YOUNG OUR
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WILL PROVIDE A
BRIEF WALK THROUGH THE DATA
COLLECTED FROM THE COURTS. WELL
THANK YOU- JUDGE ANDERSON- MY
NAME IS ROBERT O'DONNELL AND I
AM THE CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
FOR THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL- IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY. THE
COURT EXECUTIVES ADVISORY
COMMITTEE SPONSORED A SURVEY
THAT WENT OUT TO ALL TRIAL
COURTS- IN AN EFFORT TO GATHER
DATA TO MEASURE THE IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC. ON TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS ARE FIFTY FOUR OUT
OF FIFTY EIGHT COURTS WERE ABLE
TO RESPOND AND I'D LIKE TO
SUMMARIZE THE RESULTS FOR YOU-
AS JUDGE ANDERSON MENTIONED
TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER
OPERATIONAL ENHANCEMENTS. HELP
MAINTAIN ITSELF ACCESS TO
JUSTICE ARE WITH MOST COURTS
IMPLEMENTING NEW TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS TO PROVIDE REMOTE AND
ONLINE SERVICES. BALLCOURT USER
SHELTER IN PLACE. OR WORK FROM
HOME. SELF HELP CENTERS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO REMAIN OPEN AND
NOW PROVIDE THE MAJORITY OF
ASSISTANCE REMOTELY. PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC APPROXIMATELY 90%
OF THE SELF HELP INTERACTIONS
OR FACE THE POINTS- THAT
CHANGED ABOUT APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY AND THEN BY AUGUST. 75%
OF SELF HELP VISITORS CHOSE TO
INTERACT WITH SELF HELP CENTERS
REMOTELY. WHILE 25% OF THE
VISITORS DECIDED TO VISIT
THAT'S ALL HEALTH CENTERS IN
PERSON. I PROVIDING THE WITH
THE CHOICE OF HOW TO INTERACT
WITH THE COURTS SOME PEOPLE
WERE ABLE TO SAVE TIME-
TRAVELING OR STAY SAFELY AT
HOME WHILE CONDUCTING THEIR
CORE BUSINESS. WELL THERE'S
COULD COME INTO A COURTHOUSE IF
THAT WAS THEIR PREFERENCE. CORE
PROCESSING SLOWDOWNS WERE DUE
PRIMARILY TO PHYSICAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS.
IMPACTS OF WORKFORCE ABILITY
AND AS THE CHIEF JUST MENTIONED
DELAYS DUE TO EXPOSURE IN
QUARANTINE RELATED TO COPE IN
NINETEEN. WORK FOR CHEFS AND
READ DIRECTIONS OCCURRED FOR
ABOUT 5210% OF EMPLOYEES OR
PANDEMIC SPECIFIC TASKS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES SUCH AS
TEMPERATURE MONITORING AT COURT
ENTRANCES ADDITIONAL CALL
CENTER WORK AND ADDITIONAL
CLEANING. SOME COURTS EVEN
BEGAN TO OFFER TECHNICAL
SUPPORT TO THE PUBLIC TO HELP
THEM CONNECT TO COURT SERVICES.
AND THEN FINALLY DUE TO
PANDEMIC RELATED ABSENCES AND
IT'S A PERCENT BUDGET CUT IN
THE CURRENT YEAR ADDITIONAL
WORKFORCE THE LADIES- WERE
REDUCE- THE COMBINATION OF
PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS AND WORKFORCE
REDUCTIONS. RESULTED IN AN
AVERAGE 49% REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF DISPOSITIONS IN%
TWENTY TWENTY COMPARED TO
TWENTY NINETEEN. THIS REDUCTION
WAS MOSTLY CONSISTENT BETWEEN
CIVIL AND CRIMINAL CASE TYPES
WITH CIVIL HAVING 49% YOUR
DISPOSITIONS AND CRIMINAL
HAVING 51% YOUR DISPOSITION.
JUDICIAL OFFICER AVAILABILITY
WAS NOT SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED
BY PANDEMIC RELATED LEADS- AND
JUDICIAL OFFICER ASSIGNMENTS
FOR SPECIFIC CASE TYPES REMAINS
CONSISTENT WITH PRE PANDEMIC
LEVELS. WE HAVE HEARD SOME
CONCERNS THAT PEOPLE THOUGHT OF
THE COURTS WERE REASSIGNING
JUDICIAL OFFICERS FROM CIVIL
ASSIGNMENTS TO CRIMINAL
ASSIGNMENTS OR OTHER AREAS BUT
OUR DATA SHOWS THAT ASSIGNMENTS
RECEIPT OUT REMAIN CONSISTENT.
CONTINUANCES FOR CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL CASES INCREASED AN
AVERAGE 11% WITH CIVIL CASES
BEING AFFECTED LESS THAN
CRIMINAL CASES. ARE THE AVERAGE
NUMBER OF DAYS A LAPSE FROM
FILING TO THIS POSITION
PERCIVAL UNLIMITED CASES WHICH
INCLUDES COMPLEX CIVIL CASES
INCREASED BY 18% AND THEN
FINALLY THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF
HEARINGS PER CASE FOR CIVIL
CRIMINAL AND TRAFFIC VERY-
BASED ON LOCAL CONSTRAINTS AND
PROCESS CHANGES SOME INCREASE
SOME SAY THE SAME AND IN SOME
CASES THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF
HEARINGS DECREASE. ARE THE
SURVEY RESULTS ARE STILL
PRELIMINARY AND SOME FOLLOW UP
IS NEEDED WITH THE COURTS BUT
THE OVERALL THEME AND
CONCLUSIONS ARE CLEAR-
PROCESSING SLOWDOWNS ARE DUE
PRIMARILY TO PHYSICAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS. IMPACT
THE WORKFORCE ABILITY AND
DELAYS DUE TO EXPOSURE IN
QUARANTINE RELATED TO COVERT
NINETEEN. AS YOU HEARD FROM
JUDGE ANDERSON OF THE CHIEF AND
AS YOU WILL HEAR AN UPCOMING
PANELS THE COURTS RECOGNIZE
THAT EVERYONE HAS BEEN AFFECTED
BY THE PANDEMIC AND HAVE TAKEN
GREAT MEASURES TO ENSURE EQUITY
ACROSS THE STATE IN PROVIDING
CONTINUED ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR
ALL THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. GIVE US YOUR GOING
ON AND FOR THE MEMBERS THE
BACKGROUND PAPER INCLUDED. SOME
DATA ON DISPOSITIONS OF CIVIL
CASES WE JUST RECEIVED
YESTERDAY CRIMINAL SO YOU'RE
THERE THAT DATA HAS BEEN
PROVIDED OUT TO YOU. AS WELL SO
WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT HAVE
BOTH. RIGHT WILL MOVE TO OUR
THIRD PANELIST ON PANEL NUMBER
ONE DOUBLE CHECK FROM CHAU
SINCE. THANK YOU SO MUCH- AS
SOON AS I BECAME THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE PRESIDENT
OF C. O. C. WE IMMEDIATELY
ABOUT WITH OUR CHIEF JUSTICE
AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
DISCUSS WHAT WE COULD ALL DO
WORKING TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG OF CASES AND IN THIS
PHASE OF THE PANDEMIC LAWYERS
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
AGREED TO ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES
AND WORK TOGETHER. AND SO
TOGETHER THE CEO SEE AND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENSE COUNSEL AND MEMBERS OF
CALEDONIA SENT OUT A SURVEY TO
ITS MEMBERS AND OVER NINE
HUNDRED ATTORNEYS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE RESPONDED TO
QUESTIONS RELATING TO PROBLEMS
ENCOUNTERED DURING THE PANDEMIC
HOT SPOT AREAS OF CONCERN AND
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO USE
ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
MECHANISMS AS WELL AS REMOTE
VIRTUAL TRIALS AND PRIVATE JURY.
IT HAS BEEN ASSEMBLED IN A
REPORT THAT IS BEING
DISTRIBUTED TODAY. BY FAR THE
NUMBER ONE CONCERN OF ALL
ATTORNEYS IS THE INABILITY TO
GET THEIR CASES TO TRIAL THE
SETTING OF A TRIAL DATE IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT EVENTS IN THE
LIFE OF THE CIVIL CASE IT IS
THE ONLY THING THAT MOVES THE
CASE TOWARDS RESOLUTION WHEN
THERE'S NO TRIAL DATE
EVERYTHING SLOWS DOWN WITH NO
END IN SIGHT AND NO INCENTIVE
FOR SELLING EXCEPT FOR CERTAIN
LOWBALL NUMBERS. WITH WHAT'S
BEEN NOW TERMED AS THE KOBE
DISCOUNT AND AS A RESULT OUR
CLIENTS ARE SUFFERING. FOR
THOSE OF US THAT THE CDC WHO
REPRESENT PLAINTIFFS WHO HAVE
BEEN INJURED THIS MEANS THAT
OUR CLIENTS CAN I GET MUH
NEEDED MEDICAL CARE OR
COMPENSATION FOR LOST WAGES AND
SO AS A RESULT THE LIVING
CONTINUAL PAIN FEAR AND
DISCOMFORT. AND FOR SOME SUCH
DELAYS IN TREATMENT CAN RESULT
IN SEVERE BACKSLIDING IN THEIR
CONDITIONS AND EVEN DEATH
BEFORE THEIR DAY IN COURT. AND
THE ELDERLY AND THE VERY YOUNG
ARE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
DURING THIS TIME PERIOD WE
THOUGHT THAT THEY COULD TELL
YOU ABOUT THEIR PREDICAMENT SO
MUCH BETTER THAN I COULD SO WE
ARE SHOWING YOU NOW A VIDEO OF
TWO OF THEIR STORIES IN THE
SERIES THAT WE'RE CALLING FACES
OF THE PANDEMIC. AND NOW WE CAN
ROLL THE VIDEO- JURIES TO CA
CORE BUSINESS. OPEN. NINETY
MARK. SIXTY SAN. ZERO VIDEO
PLAYING ARMCHAIR WITH US WE'RE
HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF
TECHNICAL. ISSUES IF SOMEONE
ALLOWS ME TO SHARE I COULD
SHARE IT ON MY SCREEN- HANG ON.
WE CAN GET. WHAT. THE PREVIOUS
OKAY IT'S GREAT. YEAH. I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE IS THERE A WAY TO
ALLOW HER TO SHARE HER SCREEN
IF SOMEONE ELSE TO BE CHAIRS I
CAN SHOW IT ON MINE THEN WE'LL
SEE IT IN THE SHOULD ALSO. OVER
THE- LAKE. OKAY. YES SOMEONE
LISTENING IN YEAH WORK HOLD ON
WE'RE ON. WE. THE. GOOD IT IS
NOT ENABLING IT. ONE OF THE
PROBLEM. I'LL GIVE US A MINUTE.
OKAY. YEAH WE'RE SHALL BE ON.
OKAY WELL WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
TECHNOLOGY TO KIND OF CATCH UP
WITH US UNFORTUNATELY DUE
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS OF OUR
FIRST PANEL. WITH THE CHILD
CARE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MAYBE
I'LL DO A COUPLE OF FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS ARE IF I MAY- MY
QUESTIONS DEAL WITH THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY- TEKELI WITH RESPECT
TO COURT HEARINGS. I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE COURTS HAVE QUITE A
BIT OF DISCUSSION WHEN IT COMES
TO USE OF TECHNOLOGY AS TO WHAT
TECHNOLOGY THEY WANT TO USE.
OUR AND ALSO GRANTED THAT-
YOU'RE DIFFERENT CASES ARE
QUITE DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES
YOU KNOW SOME TECHNOLOGY MAY
NOT WORK IN CERTAIN CASES. AND
MY QUESTION IS SOLVED. USER IS-
UNIFORMITY IN THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY- WHEN IT COMES TO
LET'S SAY A COURT HEARINGS IN
THE LIKE A PARTICULARLY REMOTE.
ACCESS TO THE COURT SYSTEM. AND
IF UP AND WHY AND WHY NOT. SO
THIS IS ROBERT A YOUNG I CAN
ANSWER THAT- REGARDING THE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES FOR.
COURT PROCEEDINGS ARE THAT VERY
IS DUE TO THE FACT THAT EACH OF
THE INDIVIDUAL COURTS HAVE
DIFFERING INFRASTRUCTURE SO I
HAVE DIFFERENT CAPABILITIES AND
REQUIRE DIFFERENT TOOLS- SO HE
DON'T PRESCRIBE ANY PARTICULAR
TOOL FOR THE COURTS. HOWEVER WE
DO HAVE THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS
RESOURCE GUIDE THAT JUDGE
ANDERSON MENTIONED A SET OF
BEST PRACTICES AND GUIDELINES
THAT ALL COURTS- CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT TO ENSURE THAT. THE
PUBLIC- RECEIVED THE BEST-
POSSIBLE- EXPERIENCE WHEN
INTERACTING WITH THE COURT AND
SO THESE ARE THINGS LIKE MAKING
SURE THAT THE VIDEO IS CLEAR
MAKING SURE THAT THE AUDIO CAN
BE HEARD THROUGHOUT THE
COURTROOM. SO ALTHOUGH WE DO
NOT HAVE A SINGLE PRESCRIBED
PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY WE DO HAVE
A SET OF- BEST PRACTICES THAT
THE COURTS CAN LEVERAGE TO
ENSURE- A GOOD EXPERIENCE FOR
THE PUBLIC. SO DOES THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL MAKES A
RECOMMENDATION REGARDING THE
USE OF- DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES
OR IS IT ENTIRELY UP TO THE
JUDGES HOW TO MAKE THE DECISION-
SO IT'S TYPICALLY UP TO THE
COURTS TO MAKE THAT DECISION-
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WILL
PROVIDE SOME GENERAL GUIDELINES
IN TERMS OF. CAPABILITIES AND
IN PARTICULAR- SECURITY- BUT
AGAIN WE WON'T PRESCRIBE A
PARTICULAR PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY
FOR THE QUOTE. THANK YOU.
HERTZBERG THANK YOU I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN YES IT IS BT I
WANT TO RAISE FOR THE RECORD
THESE TWO POINTS ONE AND I KNOW
THERE'S GREAT COMPETITION TO
VACCINATE FOLKS BUT YOU KNOW.
ESPECIALLY IN THE COURTS WERE-
PEOPLE ARE COMING INTO THE
COURT ROOM WITH SOME REFERENCES
TO IT. IN OUR THIRTY PAGE
PAPER. GERMAN GERMANS. PLAY
READ THAT'S A COMPLIMENT THAT
IS AN ABSOLUTE COMPLIMENT. I
APPRECIATE IT- IT JUST TOOK ME
LONGER THAN EXPECTED BUT- BUT
WHERE WHERE THERE'S JUST
EXTRAORDINARY CASES OF
OUTBREAKS OF COALBED WHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF PRO PERS
COMING IN. YOU KNOW IN DEALING
WITH CASES THEY'VE GOT TO DEAL
WITH IN THE COURTROOMS. A JUST
TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE'S BEEN
THE EFFORTS TO VACCINATE- SOME
OF THE JUDGES AND WORKERS AGAIN
WE'VE GOT LIMITED RESOURCES I
JUST RAISE IT IN THE- IN THE-
ARRAY OF ISSUES THAT WE REYES.
TALK ABOUT AND SECONDLY. IT'S
ALLUDED TO AND- DIVERGING TALKS
ABOUT. IT TALKS ABOUT IT IS.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO REALLY
EXPEDITE THOSE CASES WHERE.
SOMEONE'S DYING OR THERE IS IT
WE SEE THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES I KNOW THERE'S SOME THE
GENERAL DISCUSSION ABOUT IT BUT
THERE ARE CERTAIN CASES WHERE
TIMELINESS OF PRECEDING. IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
PRESERVING EVIDENCE ORDER
PRESERVING A CASE OF LITIGANTS
OR WHATEVER TO FIGURE OUT A WAY
THAT TO SOMEHOW- EXPEDITE THOSE
PROCESS THESE- TO. TO DEAL WITH
THOSE VERY SENSITIVE CASES
PEOPLE ARE BEFORE. OF THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH. I CAN ADDRESS
THAT IF YOU'D LIKE AND THIS IS
JAKE ANDERSONI THINK IT
DEPENDS IN SOME RESPECTS ON THE
COURTS AND THEIR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT. WE
DO HERE IN MARIN COUNTY
PRIORITIZE THOSE CASES- WE
STILL HAVE OUR FULL A JUDICIAL.
RESOURCES FOR THE CIVIL MATTER
IN FACT I AM ASSIGNED TO THE
CIVIL CALENDARS AND HAVE BEEN
HANDLING THOSE CASES LIKE I
MENTIONED IN MY COMMENTS
PREVIOUSLY SOME OF THE CASES WE
ALLOW TO BE SUBMITTED ON THE
PAPERS WITHOUT HAVING TO COME
INTO COURT SOME OF THE PAPERS.
SOME OF THE CASES WE HAVE
PERMITTED TO GO BY WAY OF
REMOTE PROCEEDINGS EITHER
THROUGH VIDEO. A SOME THROUGH
COURT CALL IF IT'S NOT A TRIAL
ITSELF SO WE DO EACH COURT
WORKING THERE PASSED WITH UNDER
THE CONDITIONS THAT THEY HAVE.
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE PRIORITY
CASES YES IT HERE TOO- WE ALSO
HAVE PRIORITY OF JUVENILE
MATTERS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
MATTERS WE HAVE JUVENILE
DEPENDENCY WE HAVE A JUVENILE
JUSTICE YOU HAVE. PRIORITY OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE YOUR PRIORITY
FAMILY LAW MATTERS CUSTODY
VISITATION SUPPORT AND SO WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
PRIORITY TYPE CASES. AND THAT
THE AVAILABILITY OF PHYSICAL
SPACE AND REMOTE SPACE AND THEN
YOU HAVE TO DO AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WORKED AT TRIAGE BUT
ALSO KEEP THINGS IN THE
PIPELINE ALL ALWAYS KEEP MOVING
THINGS FORWARD. AND AS DATA
BEGINS TO PRESENT ITSELF ON
BETTER WAYS TO PROVIDE SERVICES
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO. BUT
WE ARE WORKING HARD AT IT AND.
I ASKED ONE CAN QUESTION. YEAH
LINCOLN COURSE ALL THE FOLLOW
PUSH WHICH IS MANY J. DO YOU AN
MODERATE CONCERT MIKE. IN LOS
ANGELES WE HAVE FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO. HOW MANY DO YOU
HAVE- WE HAVE IN TERMS OF JUST
OFFICER TO POINT TO I KNOW THE
POINT TWO THAT'S A
COMMISSIONER. BUT OUT OF THE-
CASE. TWENTY TWO JUDICIAL
OFFICERS AND IT ALSO DEPENDS AS
WELL AS- IN YOUR ABILITY. IN
MONTEREY COUNTY WERE FORTUNATE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A CRIMINAL
BUILDING THAT'S IN SALINAS
SEVERAL WAS IN MONTEREY. AND
THEN WE HAVE JUVENILE AT A
DIFFERENT PORT HOUSE. SO IT
ALSO DEPENDS ON YOUR PHYSICAL
SPACE IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU'RE-
WHAT YOU'RE ABLE TO DO AND
PROVIDE. SO EACH COUNTY HAS ITS
CHALLENGES I JUST LIKE WITH THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND PROVIDING
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES.
DEPENDING ON THE RESOURCES IN
YOUR COUNTY IS DEPENDING ON HOW
FAST. YOU CAN PROVIDE SERVICES
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU'RE
NOT AND IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
YOU'RE NOT WORKING AS BEST YOU
CAN. TO PROVIDE WHAT YOU CAN.
WHERE YOU CAN AND CONTINUE TO
DO BETTER. I THINK HEARING SUCH
AS THIS HELPS. US TO UNDERSTAND.
AND KNOW WHERE WE CAN BE BETTER.
I DO THINK YOU'RE READY TO PAY
THAT. DOWN IF ANYONE TO SEE IT.
WE DO WE DO BUT HANG ON A
SECOND SENATOR OTHER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- MY QUESTIONS ARE
ABOUT. THE FUNDING- BUT YOU'VE
GOTTEN AND- MAYBE FUNDING THAT
YOU NEED. AND THE BACKLOG SO
HOW DO YOU PLAN TO USE WILL BE
WILL YOU BE USING THE MONEY FOR
THE BACKLOG YOU RECEIVED LAST
YEAR FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE- PANDEMIC BACKLOG AND THEN-
TO RESTORE YOUR ONGOING FUNDING
TWO HUNDRED MILLION. BUT I
REALLY WANT TO KNOW IS HOW YOU
GET IT HOW DO YOU PLAN TO USE
THAT FUNDING AND ESPECIALLY
WITH REGARDS TO- THE BACKLOG-
AND THEN CONNECTED IS. WHAT IS
THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THAT TO RESTORE COURT
OPERATIONS TO WHERE THEY SHOULD
BE. AND I I'M SO I'LL SEND IT-
ALL. ENDED BY JUST SAYING IN LA
I UNDERSTAND BETWEEN MARCH AND
AUGUST OF THE PREVIOUS YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN THEY WERE
HUNDRED. FIFTY CIVIL CASES WERE
RESOLVED IN TWENTY TWENTY WAS
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND CASES AND
YOU KNOW HOW HOW IS LOS ANGELES
EVEN WITH FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY.
EIGHTY TWO JUDGES HOW ARE WE
ARE WE GET ADDRESS THAT BACKLOG.
THE DRESS THAT FOR YOU AND THE
MONEY WAS ALLOCATED TO EACH ONE
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COURTS
DEPENDING ON THEIR BACKLOG THE
INITIAL TWENTY FIVE MILLION WAS
PRO RATA AND THE SECOND WAS
BASED ON DATA THAT WAS PROVIDED
BASED ON THE COURT'S BACKLOG IN
EACH OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COURTS
HAVE A PRESIDING JUDGE
ASSISTANT PRESIDING JUDGE. AND
THEIR OWN EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE
AND SO EACH OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COURTS MAKE DECISIONS BASED ON
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES AND BASED
ON THE DATA THAT THEY HAVE SO
WE CANNOT ANSWER UNIVERSALLY IN
TERMS OF WHAT EACH COURT IS
GOING TO DO FOR EXAMPLE I CAN
GIVE YOU- JUST WHAT'S HAPPENING
AND MONTEREY SUPERIOR COURT WE
MAY NOT HAVE THE SAME
CHALLENGES THAT LOS ANGELES MAY
HAVE. I'LL GIVE YOU A PICTURE
IF YOU HAVE A HUGE- CRUISE SHIP
YEAH WITH THOUSANDS OF
PASSENGERS THEN YOU HAVE A
SPEED BOAT OR KAYAK OLD ARM YOU
KNOW MANEUVER DIFFERENTLY
DEPENDING ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF THE OCEAN TE WHIMS AND
EVERYTHING THAT IS GOING ON OUT
THERE AND SO THAT IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN EACH ONE OF THE
COURTS IS THAT THEIR LEADERSHIP
IS DECIDING BASED ON DATA AND
HAVING DATA AND FORM THEM. IN
TERMS OF HOW BEST TO DEAL WITH
THE BACKLOG HOW TO ASSIGN NOT
ONLY JUDICIAL RESOURCES BUT
STAFF RESOURCES- IN ORDER TO
ASSIST IN MAKING SURE THAT THAT
MATTERS. ARE HEARD AND CASES
ARE PROCESSED. AND WHAT YOU
THINK AMOUNT IS TO. COURT UP
LEVELS. AT THIS TIME WE'RE
STILL GATHERING DATA- TO ASSESS
THE BACKLOGS I BELIEVE THIS
YEAR THAT CAN SPEAK WITH
RESPECT TO THE PERCENTAGE OF
BACKLOGS THAT EACH COURT HAS
BASED ON OUR SURVEY BUT AS WE
GATHER MORE DATA AS WE SEE WHAT
COURTS ARE DOING IN ORDER TO
WORK THROUGH- THE BACKLOG. HOW
TECHNOLOGY IS ASSISTING AND
HELPING WHETHER WE BALANCE
PHYSICAL ACCESS REMOTE ACCESS
AND MAKING SURE WE DO HAVE
EQUAL ACCESS. THEN DATA WILL
INFORM US IN TERMS OF WHAT OUR
NEEDS WILL BE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO HIS REYES AND
THEN WILL SEE MS CHANG'S VIDEO.
I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE. BOB
ONE THANK YOU- PERCENT GABRIEL-
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S NEEDED FOR
THE REMOTE TO ACCESS TO
JUSTICE- ENDED FOLLOWING UP
WITH WITH MY COLLEAGUE MYSELF
HER- ON THE COST. OF THAT TALK
ABOUT THE CONSPECIFIC LEAP FOR
UPDATED TECHNOLOGY THERE ARE
SOME COUNTIES THAT CAN ACCEPT
THE REMOTE OR THAT TO BE THE
ELECTRONIC FILINGS SOME CANNOT.
SOME CAN PROVIDE THE REMOTE TO
TURN HEARING SOME CANNOT SO
EVEN IF WE LOOK AT THE MINIMUM
THAT CAN BE PROVIDED TO EACH OF
THESE COUNTIES. HAS THERE
ALREADY BEEN ASKED ABOUT ON THE
COST JUST TO BRING THEM TO A
MINIMUM. SO I CAN ADDRESS THAT
PAIN IS ROBERT A YOUNG- IN
TERMS OF LOOKING AT THE TOTAL
COSTS- FOR BRINGING PEOPLE UP
TO WHAT WOULD CONSIDERED EIGHT
MINIMUM LEVEL HOW WE HAVE NOT
LOOKED AT THAT AS A WHOLE. I
AND THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
COMPLICATED SITUATION WHERE
EACH OF THE COURTS HAVE- QUITE
A FEW DIFFERENT DEPENDENCIES
ARE REGARDING THEIR LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE- THEIR LOCAL
ABILITY TO UTILIZE
TECHNOLOGIES. AND SO THROUGH-
FUNDING REQUEST BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS HOW WE AND THROUGH
THE MODERNIZATION FUNDING THAT
WE RECEIVE. I'LL WE HAVE
ALLOCATED THAT OUT TO THE COURT
SO THAT THEY CAN PRIORITIZE AND
THEY CAN IMPLEMENT BASED ON
THEIR LOCAL CONSTRAINTS- WE DO
HAVE A STRATEGIC PLAN THAT
BASICALLY OUTLINES. THE BASIC
CAPABILITIES OF ELECTRONIC
FILING- DIGITAL- DOCUMENTS-
REMOTE HEARINGS AND AGAIN IT'S
EACH OUR COURT HAS THEIR OWN.
LIMITATIONS AND THEIR OWN-
AREAS OF FOCUS BASED ON THEIR
LOCAL POPULATION AND THEIR
LOCAL PARK OPERATIONS. SO WE
DON'T HAVE AN OVERALL COST FOR
THAT HOWEVER EACH COURT IS.
MOVING TOWARDS THAT AND STOP.
THANK YOU. I THANK LET'S SEE
CAN WE GET MISTRANSLATED- ON
JURY SERVICE TO CONDUCTING
COURT BUSINESS REMOTELY OPEN
NINETEEN IS TURN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM HERE UPSIDE DOWN. JURY
TRIALS ARE CANCELED IN PERSON
HEARINGS ARE POSTPONED. TRIALS
BEING SLOW THANKS TO
CORONAVIRUS. ALSO JUST WHY IT
RIGHT NOW ROTAVIRUS HAS FORCED
THE POSTPONEMENT OF. HEARINGS
RILES.
TO BEGIN WITH MY DAD
FELL.
SO MR- YOUNG IF YOU EVER
FIGURE OUT THE TECHNOLOGY MAYBE
YOU CAN SHARE IT WITH US. WELL
THIS IS. YEAH BOB. YEAH WE CAN
MAKE IT AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE
THRILLING- AND THEN EMAIL AND-
AGAIN IF SOMEONE ENABLE MY
SHARE BUT NINETY CHAIRED BY
LIKE THAT I THINK THEY DISABLED
IT FOR THIS TYPE OF
PRESENTATION MODE WERE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THE LINK FOR IT AND I'M
SORRY YOU COULDN'T SEE IT NOW I
CAN ACTED OUT BUT THEY DO IT SO
MUCH BETTER THAN I WOULD THANK
YOU AND IF YOU YEAH WE AND THEN
WE CAN ALSO PUT UP ON OUR
WEBSITE TO MAKE IT SURE THAT
IT'S PART OF OUR PACKAGE WOULD
BE HAPPY OKAY. SO DID DID YOU
HAVE MORE TO PRESENT TO US. NO
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT I THINK
NOW MORE THAN EVER IT TAKES
CREATIVE OUT OF THE BOX
THINKING. AND WITH US WORKING
TOGETHER WITH- EVEN REACHING
OUT TO OUR- BROTHERS AND
SISTERS ACROSS THE AISLE. I
BELIEVE IN THIS PHASE OF THE
PANDEMIC WE CAN WORK. TO
ADDRESS THIS BACKLOG OF CASES
IN VERY CREATIVE WAYS. AND
VOLUNTEER FOR A LOT OF.
DISCOVERY REFEREE MEDIATING AND
DOING A LOT OF THINGS AND WE'RE
EAGER AND WILLING TO DO THAT
AND WE'RE GOING TO SHARE SOME
OF OUR IDEAS WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL BUT WE'LL GET THROUGH
THIS BECAUSE- WE HAVE THE WILL
AND THE ABILITY. GREAT THANK
YOU. CENTURY TRIALS ARE
CANCELED IN PERSON HEARINGS ARE
POSTPONED CAN YOU. WE'LL DEAL
WITH THIS VIDEO LATER. THANK
YOU WE'LL WE'LL PUT UP WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MEMBERS
HAVE ACCESS SURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU SO I'M
I HAVE A KIND OF FOLLOWING UP
FOR A QUESTION FOR MR YOUNG AND
JUDGE ANDERSON. AND THIS SORT
OF A TOP LEVEL OVER ARCHING
QUESTION THAT I THINK WE NEED
TO ALTERNATELY GET TO AND BASED
ON WHAT YOU EXPLAINED IT AND I
HATE THE CHIEF JUSTICE'S
COMMENTS. TO POINT BECAUSE WE
STRUGGLE WITH. SETTING
STATEWIDE STANDARDS IMPOSING
THAT LOCALLY AND I AND I KNOW
THAT THOSE ARE SOME CHALLENGES
HERE. BUT HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
THAT YOU CAN KEEP THAT THE
CULTURE THE NATURE OF YOUR
FIFTY EIGHT INDIVIDUAL.
COUNTIES THE COURTS FUNCTIONING
BUT STILL BE ABLE TO SET
STANDARDS SO THAT WE DON'T SEE
DIFFERENCES IN ACCESS TO
JUSTICE COUNTY TO COUNTY TO
COUNTY. AND I THINK SOME OF THE
DATA THAT WE'VE SEEN SHOWS THAT
THAT DIFFERENT COUNTIES HAVE
DIFFERENT. CONSTRAINTS TO
DIFFERENT RESOURCES AND- WHICH
LEADS TO A REALLY DIFFERENT
ABILITY TO ACCESS JUSTICE AND
SO WE TALKED ABOUT IS
TECHNOLOGY SOME OF THIS IS
PHYSICAL SPACES. BUT I THINK WE
ULTIMATELY NEED TO HAVE A PLAN
AND ADD AN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
WE CAN GET TO SORT OF WHAT
BASIC LEVELS OF ACCESS OR
ACCEPTABLE OR WE SHOULD BE
SHOOTING FOR. AND THEN HOW WE
ENSURE THAT EVERY SINGLE COURT
CAN MEET THAT STANDARD AND I
THINK IF WE CAN HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION COLLECT THAT DATA
I THINK THE LEGISLATURE IS VERY
WILLING. TO LOOK AT THAT AND
ENSURE THAT WE BUILD. PROOF
AGAINST. A CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE
THIS WILL HOPEFULLY WE'RE NOT
GONNA CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE THIS IN
THE FUTURE BUT BUILD SOME.
BUILD A BETTER SENSE OF ACCESS
AND CONTINUITY AMONG ALL OF THE
COURTS AT A CERTAIN LEVEL. SO
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE DO THAT.
WELL I CAN GO AHEAD AND- START
WITH THAT ANYTHING- THE WAY THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH IS STRUCTURED
IN THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS
STRUCTURED REALLY LENDS ITSELF.
TO OF THE JUDICIAL BRANCH YOU
KNOW AS WELL AS REACHING OUT
PARTNERING OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
ASK THOSE QUESTIONS AND ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS AND LET ME.
GIVE AN EXAMPLE WE ARE
GRASSROOTS TO THE TOP AND
GRASSROOTS TO THE TOP MEANS WE
HAVE ADVISORY COMMITTEES AND
ONCE WE HAVE ADVISORY
COMMITTEES THAT TO THE BATTLE
IN THE INFORMATION GATHERING
THE DATA GATHERING AND THEY
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION ON UP
THE CHAIN- TO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OR POLICIES THAT. WE
HAVE THE TRIAL COURT PRESIDING
JUDGES ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND
WE HAVE THE COURT EXECUTIVE
OFFICERS ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE IS
BEGINNING TO STUDY AND COLLECT
DATA AS MISTER- YOUNG HAD I
TALKED ABOUT THE SURVEY THAT WE
DID WITH RESPECT TO THE COURTS.
THEY PUT OUT THE PANDEMIC
CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS
RESOURCE GUIDES THAT IS THE
PRESIDING JUDGE IS GETTING
TOGETHER OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COURTS AND SHARING INFORMATION
AND SHARING BEST PRACTICES- SO
THAT'S HOW IT IS DONE I CAN
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE FOR. US IN
TERMS OF OUR EVOLUTION HERE IN
MONTEREY COUNTY WE FIRST
STARTED OUT WITH MICROSOFT
TEAMS AND THEN. GRADUATED TO A
DIFFERENT PLATFORM AND FINALLY
WE HAVE RESOLVED UNIFORMITY OUT
WITH THE SUIT AND. THAT WAS AN
EVOLUTION BY. WHEN THEY'RE AT
THE BEACH. OF THE PAN. WHEN ALL
YOU HAD TO DO DO SOME. AND THEN
AS WE- TECHNOLOGY. PLATFORMS
OUT REACHED OUT TO OUR JUSTICE
PARTNERS REACHED OUT TO THE BAR
ASSOCIATIONS TO FIND OUT WHAT.
I WORK FOR THEM AS WELL AS HOW
THAT INFORMED OUR DECISIONS AND
WE BEGAN TO CHANGE OUR
DECISIONS. SAME WORK BRANCH
WIDE BY UTILIZING THE TRIAL
COURT PRESIDING JUDGE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THE COURT EXECUTIVE
OFFICERS ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
AND GATHERING DATA AND
INFORMATION AND SHARING THAT
DATA AND INFORMATION THEN YOU
CAN COME UP WITH A GOOD POLICY.
AND PRODUCE AND PROVIDE MANUALS
FOR FOLKS TO HAVE SOMETHING IN
WRITING THAT SAYS WHAT ARE THE
BEST PRACTICES. WE ALSO HAVE
THE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. THAT DOES A
DATA COLLECTION AND ASSESSING
ON TECHNOLOGY THAT INFORMS THAT
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TECHNOLOGY
COMMITTEE. SO WE HAVE ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT ADVISORY BODIES
COMMITTEES WORK GROUPS THAT
REALLY DO THE VETTING AND
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION. SO
THAT DECISION MAKING AND BEST
PRACTICES. CAN BE PROVIDED.
ROSS THE BRANCH BUT ALSO FROM
COURT TO MAKE OWN IN. DECISIONS
BASED ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES THEY
FIND THEMSELVES WITHIN THEIR
PARTICULAR COUNTY AND I DON'T
KNOW IF THE MISTER YOUNG- YOUNG
HAS ANYTHING ELSE TO PROVIDE.
YEAH I THINK THAT- IS IT IS A
GOOD SUMMARY THINKING THE OTHER
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE REALLY
IS AND TERMS OF WHAT THE- CHIEF
JUSTICE WAS SAYING IN TERMS OF
THE DIFFICULTY OF. ACTUALLY
HAVING JURORS COME IN BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID TO COME IN THE
TO THE COURT- AND THAT'S ALSO A
YOU KNOW A BARRIER- IN TERMS
OF. YES SLOWING DOWN THE
PROCESSES BUT I THINK THE
THINGS THAT YOU HAD MENTIONED
ARE ARE VERY IMPORTANT- AND
AGAIN THAT THE TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS THAT WE'RE PUTTING IN
PLACE- I THINK SHOULD. SHOULD
BE HELPFUL WELL WE DO ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO. SEEING BEYOND THE-
FROM- IS- CHIANG- YOU KNOW IN
WORKING WITH TECHNOLOGY EVERY
DAY NOW WE SEE THOSE TYPES OF
PROBLEMS AS WELL SO HOPEFULLY-
THOSE CAN GET RESOLVED SO THAT
WE CAN SEE THAT THAT VIDEO.
OKAY AND YOU'RE DESCRIBING. AS
WITH INJURED COUNTS AND COURT.
HOW ARE YOU TAKING INFORMATION
FROM THE USERS OF THE COURTS.
TO INFORM THOSE DECISIONS. YES
SO- IN MANY CASES- FOR EXAMPLE
AND SELF HELP- WE DO COLLECT
THAT DATA ON A REGULAR BASIS-
TO DETERMINE. WHICH AREAS ARE
OF HIGHEST DEMAND SO THAT WE
CAN FOCUS RESOURCES IN THOSE
AREAS- WE HAVE MEANT AS WELL-
WITH MANY OF THE GROUPS SOME OF
THE GROUPS THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
HEARING FROM TODAY AS WELL- TO
GET THEIR INPUT AND INCORPORATE
THAT. INTO OUR PLANS FOR
RECOVERY AND IN FACT- IN THE
PANDEMIC CONTINUITY OF
OPERATIONS RESOURCE GUIDE- THAT
JUDGE ANDERSON MENTIONED HOW WE
HAVE INCORPORATED- FEEDBACK
FAST WE HAVE RECEIVED. IN THOSE
BEST PRACTICES. THANK YOU
CHERUB. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'M JUST COUPLE QUESTIONS I'M
GONNA ASK THEM COLLECTIVELY AND
THEN YOU CAN RESPOND- TO ALL OF
THEM FIRST IN TERMS OF THE
INTERSECTION OF CRIMINAL TRIALS
WITH RESPECT TO END CIVIL
TRIALS. WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
CRIMINAL TRIALS AND HOW IS IT
IMPACTING CIVIL TRIALS THAT'S
NUMBER ONE AND THEN NUMBER TWO.
IS THAT. FOR FUTURE EMERGENCIES
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH WE HAVE
FIFTY EIGHT THERE'S BOUNDARIES
THAT ARE SOMEWHAT ARTIFICIAL
THINK IF YOU'RE IN A COUNTY.
THAT COULD BRING SOME OF THE
TRIAL IN TWO YEARS AND YOUR
FIVE MILES FROM OTHER COUNTY
THEY CAN'T BRING ANYTHING A
TRIAL IN FIVE YEARS. THAT SEEMS
LIKE A DISPARITY THERE WITHOUT
WITHOUT A REAL RATIONALE AND SO
WHAT WHAT WHAT THE COURTS
PROPOSED WITH RESPECT TO FOR
EXAMPLE UP MAKING SURE THAT
THAT WE IS A LEGISLATURE ENACT.
A STATUTES SO THAT IN THE EVENT
OF EMERGENCY YOU CAN HAVE
TRIALS THAT ARE IN DIFFERENT
COUNTIES NUMBER ONE AND THEN
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO. TO SURGE
CAPACITY RIGHT NOW- THE FIVE
YEAR OLD THE DREADED FIVE YEAR
RULE IT IS COMING BACK IT WAS
THIRTY YEARS AGO IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THAT EVERY CASE GOING
OUT TO TRIAL WAS A FOUGHT
WHAT'S CALLED A FIVE YEAR CASE.
NOW IT'S BACK. SO WHAT WHAT DO
YOU RECOMMEND IN THE U. S.
COLLECTIVE WHAT DO YOU
RECOMMEND THAT WE DO HERE IN
THE NEXT TWO YEARS. TO MEET THE
CHALLENGE OF ALL THESE CASES
HITTING A FIVE YEAR PERIOD I
GET THAT THERE'S AN EXTRA SIX
MONTHS AS PART OF THE EMERGENCY
ORDER. BUT WE ARE GOING TO BE
IN A SITUATION ESPECIALLY. WHEN
THE ISSUE. IT'S NOT RESOLVED
BUT WHEN THE- EVICTION-
CHALLENGE BECOMES EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED SO. GO AHEAD SOLVE
ALL THOSE QUESTIONS SOLVE ALL
THOSE ISSUES THANK YOU. I THINK
IT'S CONTINUING TO THE DIALOGUE
AND DATA COLLECTION AND
ASSESSING WHAT THE NEEDS ARE UP
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT YOU KNOW FROM JURISDICTION
TO JURISDICTION OFTENTIMES. IT
MAY BE DEPENDENT AGAIN LIKE I
SAID ON ON PHYSICAL ABILITIES
OF THE COURTS TO REALLY PROCESS
ALL THOSE CASES ARE YOU ABLE TO
BRING PEOPLE INTO THE BUILDING
DO YOU HAVE THE REQUISITE
AMOUNT OF STAFF TO BE ABLE TO
DO THE JURY TRIAL DO YOU HAVE
THE REQUISITE AMOUNT OF STAFF
TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE THE JURORS
AND COMPLEMENT. BY YOU KNOW
HAVING HALL IN SAFETY MONITORS
WHEN HAVE WE EVER HAD TO HAVE
SAFETY MONITORS OF THE WHOLE
WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND THERE'S
NOT THAT MANY PEOPLE INSIDE THE
COURTROOM SO I THINK B. R.
FIFTY EIGHT COURTS THROUGH THE
TRIAL COURT PRESIDING JUDGES
ADVISORY COMMITTEE ACCORD
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS COMMITTEE. I
CAN CONTINUE TO COLLECT DATA
AND CONTINUE TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS I BELIEVE THE-
THERE'S ALREADY THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITY OPTS FOR THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH THE CHIEF JUSTICE. TO BE
ABLE TO ASSIGN CERTAIN CASES TO
TWO DIFFERENT CONTIGUOUS
COUNTIES AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE BUT I THINK THERE ARE
ANSWERS ANSWERS OUT THERE WHICH
REQUIRE STUDY AND DATA ANALYSIS
AND FURTHER CONVERSATION SO
THAT WE CAN SEE WHAT ARE THE
BEST PRACTICES BECAUSE- AGAIN.
I CAN TELL JUST TELL YOU I'M
JUST SO FORTUNATE TO BE IN A
COUNTY WITH WE WRE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO BE ALL ELECTRONIC AND
YOU COURT BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
WELL MY NEIGHBOR IN SANTA CRUZ
IS NOT A COMPLETE IN COURT- AND
THAT WAS YOU KNOW FOR VARIETY
OF REASONS COULD BE BUDGET AT.
IN ABILITY TO HIRE THAT
REQUISITE TECHNOLOGY EXPERTS TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT AND SO THERE'S
A WIDE VARIETY OF THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. WITH IN
EACH COURT TO DETERMINE WHAT IS
IT THAT YOU PARTICULARLY NEED
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH YOUR CASES
DEAL WITH YOUR BACK LOADS AT A
CASE ABOUT CLOTHES AND THEN
ONCE WE'VE GATHER DATA AND DO
THE ANALYSIS THEN WE. CAN COME
UP WITH A SOLUTION BUT SOME
TIMES WHEN YOU PUT THE CAR IN
FRONT OF HORSE. AND THE COURT
IS PUSHED THE CART OUT WE DON'T
GET VERY FAR BUT I. IF WE'RE
ABLE TO GET. TO ON CONTINUE TO
SHARE INFORMATION THEN WE CAN
COME UP WITH ANSWERS. JUDGE
LANCE WHAT'S THE TIMELINE FOR
THAT. BECAUSE WE KNOW. THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
CIVIL CASES IN PARTICULAR. SO
WHAT WHAT'S THE TIMELINE. FOR
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH TO MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION TO US TO HELP
RESOLVE THAT ISSUE. WE ARE
STILL COLLECTING DATA I BELIEVE
WE JUST COLLECTED ADDITIONAL
DATA THAT I BELIEVE MISTER
YOUNG INCLUDED IN HIS COMMENTS
WITH RESPECT TO-
QUESTIONNAIRES. THAT WERE SENT
OUT TO THE FIFTY EIGHT COURTS-
SO WE WOULD NEED TO COLLECT
BECAUSE I CAN AGAIN TELL YOU
DIFFERENT COURTS HAVE DIFFERENT
TIMELINES FOR HEARING MONTEREY
IF YOU WANT A TRIAL DATE YOU
GET ONE. FOR CIVIL- AND THERE
ARE AT BUT IN OTHER COUNTIES
AND I THINK I THINK IT'S
BECAUSE WE WERE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO BE EQUAL BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC FORTUNATE ENOUGH IN
TERMS OF FACILITIES. TO BE ABLE
TO SEPARATE OUT CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL WAR OTHER PORTS DON'T
HAVE THAT SO YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE LOCAL CONDITIONS IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
AND ASSESS. WHAT IS IT THAT YOU
NEED IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH YOUR BACK LOADS. ARE
THE RESOURCES JUDICIAL BECAUSE
THEY MAY OR MAY NOT BE OTHER
RESOURCE THE STATS BECAUSE IT
MAY NOT BE. ARE THE RESOURCES
FACILITIES BECAUSE IT MAY MAY
NOT BE ARE THE RESOURCES NEEDED
TECHNOLOGY WHAT IS ACTUALLY
NEEDED IN ORDER UNDER YOUR
CIRCUMSTANCES AND CONDITIONS IN
ORDER TO GET THE CASE OUT. YES
THE BRANCH HAS IT ON THEIR MIND
AT THAT TROUBLE JUST BY YOUR
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS FOR
EXECUTIVES. ARE THINKING ABOUT
THAT AND THINKING DOWN THE ROAD
JUST SAY HEY YOU. SEE THAT.
SOMEONE AT SOME POINT IN TIME
THE ACT YOU KNOW UNLAWFUL
DETAINERS WILL COME TO THE
COURTS WHAT IS OUR PLAN- WHAT
RESOURCES ARE WE GONNA HAVE
WHAT JUDICIAL OFFICERS ARE YOU
GOING TO SIGN TO THAT EACH
COURT WILL HAVE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
CONTINUALLY LOOK DOWN THE ROAD
TO SAY HOW ARE WE GOING TO DEAL
WITH THIS AND HOW DO WE SLOWLY
BUT SURELY. WITHIN STATE HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND THE CURRENT
RESTRICTIONS THAT WE DO HAVE
BEGIN TO WIDEN THE PIPELINE
BEGIN TO OPEN UP AND BEGIN TO
HEAR MORE AND MORE CASES. WE
YEAH THERE ARE JURISDICTIONS
WHO ARE TRYING NOT ONLY
CRIMINAL CASES BUT SEVERAL
CASES- THERE ARE SOME
JURISDICTIONS YOU KNOW THAT
DON'T HAVE THE FACILITIES AND
THEN OUR I BELIEVE YOU'LL BE
HEARING FROM ALAMEDA. A LITTLE
BIT LATER AND HAVE DONE A VERY
GOOD I- REMOTE. JURY TRIALS SO
AS COLLECT THE BEST. I THINK WE
WILL BE ALSO. SALUTE SO MISTER.
YOUNG WHAT WHAT IS THE TIME OF.
FOR THE COLLECTION OF DATA AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP DEAL WITH
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THAT ON
CLOUT NINE. AND ON. THAT WILL-
AFFECT ALL OF US. THREE WELL
WE'RE HOPING THAT IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE AN ONSLAUGHT AND
WHAT AS JUDGE ANDERSON HAD
MENTIONED- WE ARE CONTINUALLY
COLLECTING DATA- WHAT WE ARE
DOING AT THIS POINT IN HIS EACH
STEP TOWARDS RESTORATION FOR
EXAMPLE OF THE BUDGET THE
PROPOSED RESTORATION OUR BUDGET
I THINK IS ONE STEP TOWARDS
MOVING FORWARD- FOR US AND I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL HOW WE'RE IDENTIFYING
THOSE AREAS WHERE WE
ANTICIPATE- EIGHT- JOHN IN OUR
CASE LOAD AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
BE FOCUSING IN ON SOME OF
THOSE- THE CHEESE HAS PUT
TOGETHER PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE-
EARLY DISPOSITION CALENDARS AND
SO. WE'RE LOOKING AT A SET OF
MULTIPLE SOLUTIONS- AND AS WE
DETERMINE- WHAT WE CAN AND DEAL
WITH INTERNALLY- WE WILL WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH ALL OF YOU
TO DEFINITELY REACH OUT AT THIS
POINT IN TERMS OF RESTORATION
OF THE- BUDGET I THINK IS A
VERY STRONG MOVEMENT- TOWARDS-
BEING- NORMALCY- BUT TO BE
FRANK WELL ONE OF THE BIG
CONSTRAINTS FOR US AGAIN IS
NEED PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS- DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC AND SO- YOU KNOW THOSE
ARE SOME THINGS THAT ARE YOU
KNOW ARE ARE PROBABLY GOING TO
BE DEPENDENT UPON THINGS LIKE
VACCINES AND OTHER- OTHER
SOLUTIONS BUT- AS WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK THROUGH THE DATA AS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COURTS. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE AN ONGOING DIALOGUE WITH
YOU AS WELL SO IT IS THE RIGHT
TIME LINE FOR THE COLLECTION OF
DATA AND THEN PROVIDING US.
WITH YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS. HOW
WE DO NOT HAVE A TIMELINE A
IT'S GO TO BE AN ONGOING BASIS
ONCE WE COLLECT- APPROPRIATE
DATA AND WERE I'M READY TO HAVE
THE CONVERSATION- I THINK THAT
WHEN WE'VE GOT SOME GOOD
CONCLUSIONS WE WILL INITIATE
THAT- BUT AT THIS POINT WE
DON'T HAVE A SET TIME. FOR
WHICH WE BELIEVE ARE WE WILL
HAVE THAT ANALYSIS DONE OR COME
TO CONCLUSIONS BUT IT IS AN
ONGOING PROCESS DO YOU THINK
YOU'LL HAVE IT BY THE TIME WE
ENACT THE BUDGET. IT'S HARD TO
SAY I AGAIN IT'S A ONGOING
PROCESS. OKAY. OKAY JUST JUST
DON'T YES I CENTER ALSO THE
DOING THING I DO WANT TO GET ON
TO OUROTHER PANELS I'M SORRY I
JUST I IT'S HARD FOR ME WHEN
YOU SAY. YOU DON'T SEE AN-
WHEN. WE WILL FOR MORE
RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS SEE IT.
COMING AND WHETHER IT'S ON THE
BIG XIN LEVEL. WHETHER IT'S IN
THE DEPENDENCY COURTS I MEAN
THERE ARE NUMEROUS WAYS ALL THE
OTHER CIVIL CASES. THIS IS
REALLY BUILDING UP AND THAT'S
WHAT WE HEAR BACK THAT'S WHAT I
HEAR BACK IN MY DISTRICT. SO I
AM NOT I DON'T THINK I'M ASKING
FOR YOU TO GIVE US A- DETAILED
WHAT IS EVERY SINGLE COURT
GOING TO DO IS. BUT RATHER. HOW
AS A SYSTEM. AS A SYSTEM ARE WE
GOING TO ADDRESS. BOTH THE
BACKLOG CREATED BY THE PANDEMIC
WHICH WAS NOT ARE OF OUR
MAKING. AS WELL AS- WHAT WAS
ALREADY A BACKLOG IN THESE
VARIOUS AREAS SO. YOU MAY NOT
HAVE AN ANSWER NOW BUT- I DON'T
SEE HOW WELLS. WE MOVE FORWARD
AND WE'RE OFFERING YOU ARE
ASKING YOU WHAT IS THE FUNDING
THAT YOU WOULD NEED TO SOLVE
ALL THIS. AND I'M JUST HERE I'M
NOT QUITE HEARING THAT. THAT
PROCESS IS I'M NOT SAYING I'M
GOING TO PROCESS BUT THAT
PROCESS IS GOING TO LEAD US TO
A PLAN SOMEWHERE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO. MOVE ONTO OUR NEXT
PANEL BUT THAT THAT POINT IS
WELL TAKEN AND SO TO JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. I KNOW YOU WANT FULL
RESTORATION THAT'S BEEN BEEN
ONGOING SUBJECT HOWEVER. THERE
ARE A LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED SO THAT WE
CAN ENSURE THAT THE LEVELS OF
ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN EVERY
SINGLE COUNTY. IS AVAILABLE AND
IT IS AVAILABLE AT. LEAST THE
MINIMUM STANDARDS AND I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE
ESTABLISHED ALREADY FROM THIS
IS THERE ARE DISPARATE. LEVELS
OF ACCESS COUNTY BY COUNTY
BASED ON A NUMBER OF FACTORS
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT WE
WANT TO HELP BUT WE NEED
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THAT HELP SO HELP US
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS HELP
US THROUGH. INFORMATION
GATHERING PROCESSES IN THE MORE
THAT WE CAN FEEL INFORMED
THAT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO HELP
BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE YOUR
PARTNERS. IN COURT FUNDING AND
GET YOU WHAT YOU NEED. BUT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
MEASURES UP TO OUR PROCESSES
AND THAT THAT WE UNDERSTAND HOW
THAT IS AFFECTING THE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE QUESTION. ALL RIGHT SO
LET'S NOW MOVES TO THE PANEL
TWO AND WE'RE- A LITTLE BIT
BEHIND BUT THAT'S OKAY. SO WE
HAVE FIRST OF ALL IT'S ENERGY
RICHARDSON EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF BAY AREA LEGAL AID. AND WE
HAVE A SHELL BROWN CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION THE FAMILY
LAW SECTION. AND CATHERINE
STEPHAN- SEVEN OR SO STATES WHO
IS A PRACTICING ELDER ABUSE
ATTORNEY. AND THE SUBJECT OF
THIS PANEL IS THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC OWN SOME COURT USERS
SO THESE ARE FOLKS TALKING
ABOUT VERY SPECIFIC AREAS.
WHERE THE PANDEMIC HAS AFFECTED
THEIR PRACTICE AND THEIR
CLIENTS SO MS RICHARDSON. I'M
GENEVIEVE PROJECT SETTINGS
EXTRACTOR VERY LEGAL LANA-
BENEGAL IS A REGIONAL CIVIL
LEGAL SERVICES NONPROFIT THAT
CERTAIN PRACTICES IN THE SEVEN
BAY AREA COUNTY. WE SERVE AND
REPRESENT VERY LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES AND A
VARIETY OF FUNDAMENTAL LEGAL
RIGHTS ISSUES HOUSING MYSTIC
VIOLENCE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND MORE. I'VE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO BE IN LEGAL AID
FOR THE LAST TWENTY YEARS AND I
THINK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING- AND FOCUSING ON WHAT
CAN BE DONE TO SUPPORT THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM TO BE SAFE. AND
TO ENSURE FULL AND EQUAL ACCESS
THE TWO CANNOT BE SEPARATED. WE
CANNOT BE HAVE LITIGANTS AND
ATTORNEYS CHOOSING BETWEEN
THEIR HEALTH AND THE EXERCISE
IN PROTECTION OF LEGAL RIGHTS
TO TAKE EARLY LEAD AGAINST WITH
LIMITED MEANS AND OFTEN THOSE
WHO ARE THE GREATEST HEALTH
THREATS. AND YET THIS CONTINUES
TO BE A REALLY SIGNIFICANT AS
CHAIR. I LEGAL AID WE ARE. TO
ADDRESSING POVERTY SOCIAL
INJUSTICE AND ACCESS TO THE
COURTS IN ON PANDEMIC HAPPENS
WE DO THIS BY OUR OPEN DOORS.
AND OUR ATTORNEYS ADVOCATES ARE
YOU MEETING WITH OUR CLIENTS
THE COMMUNITY BUT IN MARCH
FOLLOWING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVISORIES EVEN APPARENT
ESSENTIAL SERVICE. WE MADE THE
DIFFICULT DECISION TO CLOSE OUR
DOORS AND- TO PROTECT OUR
CLIENTS STAFF AND COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE BEEN FOCUSING FOCUSED
ON SAFETY AND THEN WE CONTINUED
OUR SERVICES REMOTELY. WITH
VERY LIMITED IN PERSON
ACTIVITIES AND REALLY STRICT-
SAFETY PROTOCOLS IT HASN'T BEEN
PERFECT OR IDEAL BUT IT HAS
BEEN NECESSARY. AND SINCE THE
BEGINNING WE'VE ALSO BEEN
RAISING SAFETY AND ACCESS
ISSUES AND THE COURTS ARE LOCAL
COURTS AND JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
HONEST STATEWIDE LEVEL AS ONE
OF ELEVEN LSC FUNDED LEGAL
SERVICE SAYS TOGETHER WE SERVE
THE COMMUNITIES IN EVERY COUNTY
ACROSS THE STATE. AND IN OUR
FREQUENT MEETINGS THROUGHOUT
KOBE WE START IDENTIFYING THESE
SYSTEMIC PATTERNS OF
DISPARITIES THAT YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT. IN SEPTEMBER
WITH SUCH A DETAILED LETTER TO
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WITH THE
ISSUES THAT WE IDENTIFIED
RECOMMENDATIONS IN OUR
COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO ADDRESS
THEM. WE'VE LOST WITH THE CHIEF
JUSTICE AND MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. RAISING
ADDITIONAL SPECIFIC EXAMPLES
AND RECOMMENDATIONS AND OUR
FOCUS HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY ON
THE NEED FOR STATEWIDE
GUIDELINES AND MINIMUM
STANDARDS. WE ALL KNOW THAT
HOGAN NINETEEN S. EXPOSE GREAT
DISPARITIES THROUGHOUT OUR
SOCIETY INCLUDING AT THE COURTS
AND UNIQUE HEALTH DANGERS
WITHIN THE COURTS. MY FOCUS
TODAY IS ON WHAT CONTINUES TO
BE CENTRAL TO BE LEGAL AND IT
TOO MANY GREAT COLLEAGUES. RT
AND WORKS AND THAT IS THAT OUR
LOW INCOME LITIGANTS AND OUR
STAFF ARE BEING SUBJECTED TO
UNNECESSARY HEALTH RISKS IN
REQUIRED IN PERSON PROCEEDINGS.
AND THERE IS GREAT DISPARITIES
IN ACCESS WE NEED A MINIMUM
STANDARD. I LINES WHERE THE
COURTS AND SAFETY AND WE NEED
TO LINE THE IS WITH A
CALIFORNIA COMPANY GUIDELINES
AND SAFETY STANDARDS THAT ARE
ESTABLISHED BY PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS. WELL MOST OF
CALIFORNIA IS IN THE STRICTEST
PURPLE TEAR WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
MATTERS THAT REQUIRE PEOPLE TO
BE IN PERSON IN UNSAFE
COURTROOMS. MANY OF THE IN
PERSON REQUIREMENTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS LOW
INCOME. FOR EXAMPLE THERE ARE
IN PERSON HEARINGS ON THE WAY
FOR. A TRAFFIC CITATION AND
AFFECTION. EVICTION MATTERS ARE
CONTINUALLY BEING SEPARATE JURY
TRIALS AND SETTLEMENT
CONFERENCE AS THESE REQUIRE-
MORE LONG HOURS INDOORS WITH
MULTIPLE PEOPLE AT ALL OF IT
CONTRADICTS YOUR BASICS CDC
GUIDELINES AND- CREATES EXTREME
DANGERS ARE CODED TRANSMISSION
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN EXAMPLES OF
TRIALS A SUPER SPREADERS. AS
THE CHIEF JUSTICE RARE
REFERENCE WE'VE SEEN EXPOSURE
AFTER EXPOSURE IN THIS CONTEXT.
WE ALSO ROUTINELY HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ALREADY HEALTH
COMPROMSE NEEDING REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION. AND OFTEN THEY
ARE WAITING FOR RULINGS ON
THEIR REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS
UP UNTIL JUST BEFORE HEARINGS
OR IF THEY'RE NOT ANSWERED THEY
HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION BETWEEN
THEIR HEALTH AND EXERCISE OF
THE RIGHTS WERE THE ATTORNEYS
ETHICAL DUTIES. WELL THERE'S
NOTHING PERFECT IT IN NO
PERFECT SOLUTIONS INCORPORATED
WE ARE REALLY FORTUNATE THAT WE
HAVE REMOTE SOLUTIONS THAT
ENABLE US TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND PROVIDE ACCESS TO ARTS. THE
QUESTIONS YOU'VE BEEN ASKING
ABOUT MINIMUM STANDARDS AND HOW
WE GET ALL COURTS CONSISTENT I
THINK ARE EXACTLY ON POINT IN
ORDER TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ACCESS THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM
WE NEED THE LEGISLATURE TO HELP
TO ESTABLISH STATEWIDE SAFETY
GUIDELINES FOR REPORTS. OUR
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN WHEN WE
MEET WITH LOCAL COURTS THE
LOCAL COURTS ARE OFTEN LOOKING
TO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WELL
IT'S NOT THAT'S JUST A COUNCIL
THEY ARE OFTEN DEFERRING TO
LOCAL COURTS OR THEY DON'T WANT
TO OVERSTEP THE LEGISLATURE.
THUS THIS IS LEFT LEAD AGAINST
AN ADVOCATES A CORPORATE HOT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NEXT MATCH OF
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES. I COME
OUT I ALSO COMMEND THE
BACKGROUND PAPER AND ALL THAT
WAS IN IT AS IT JUST CRIED THE
RULES ESTABLISHED BY LOCAL
PORTS ARE NOT. OUR SYSTEM. IN
OUR EXPERIENCE THE IS LOCKED
BIG WHITE STANDARDS HASN'T MET.
MENTION CREATE INCONSISTENCIES
AND DISPARITIES INCREASED
HEALTH RISKS AND INCREASED CORE
ACCESS. WE RECOGNIZE LOCAL
COURTS AND DIGITAL I ALSO HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD- AND WE
UNDERSTAND THERE UNDER RESOURCE
AND THAT THERE ARE LOCAL
CONSTRAINTS INDIANS BUT OUR
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN THAT LOCAL
COURTS AND JUDGES SEEM TO BE
STARTING FROM SCRATCH
RECREATING AND REACTING RATHER
THAN STARTING FROM MINIMUM
SAFETY STANDARDS AND PROCEDURES
AND I'M STANDARDS FOR. REMOTE
TECHNOLOGIES AND BASIC
TEMPLATES FOR COMMUNICATIONS
AND NOTICES AND INSTRUCTIONS.
THE RESULT OF WHAT WE SEE IS
THAT ONE'S ABILITY TO SAFELY
EXERCISE THEIR LEGAL RIGHTS IS
NOT JUST BY COUNTY BUT LIKE
COURT DEPARTMENT AND BY
JUDICIAL OFFICER. EXAMPLE WE
CONTINUE TO SEE A LOT OF
COUNTIES THAT HAVE NOT ADOPTED
CONSISTENT POLICIES FOR ACCESS
REMOTE APPEARANCES AS YOU OF
DISCUSSED. THERE IT MAY BE THAT
WHETHER SOMEBODY HAS TO APPEAR
IN PERSON MIGHT BE ABLE TO CALL
IN OR USE VIDEO PARENTS MAY
DEPEND JUST ON A JUDICIAL
OFFICERS PREFERENCE AN INTEREST
IN LEARNING THE TECHNOLOGY.
RATHER THAN WHITE RIGHT
TRAINING AND FACILITATION OF
REMOTE ACCESS. WE DO NOT SEE
CONSISTENT TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS
EVEN ACROSS LOCAL COURTS. I'M
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
MINIMUM STANDARDS AND BEST
PRACTICES FOR THINGS LIKE
LANGUAGE ACCESS. WE HAVE WE ARE
NOT SEEING SIMPLE CLEAR NOTICES
AND INSTRUCTIONS SO IT IS
CONFUSING TO KNOW HOW- WHAT
OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE AND HOW
YOU ACCESS THEM. AND THEY ARE
OFTEN NOT THAT TRANSLATED INTO
LANGUAGES OUT OTHER THAN
ENGLISH MAKING IT EITHER. FOR
MORE COMPLICATED. FOR LEAD
AGAINST YOU DO NOT SPEAK
ENGLISH AS FIRST LANGUAGE. OUR
CLIENTS ALSO THOSE ARE FACING
FEES RELATED RELATED TO RURAL
REMOTE ACCESS AND FEE WAIVERS
ARE NOT BEING CONSISTENTLY
APPLIED. FOR EXAMPLE FOR A
TELEPHONIC APPEARANCE WITH
COURT CALL IT CAN BE A HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER CALL OR PER CALL
THERE ARE OFTEN MANY STEPS THAT
NEED TO BE TAKEN TO GET THOSE
FEES WAIVED. FOR THOSE WERE
JUST ABOVE A FEE WAIVER WHICH
RAISED A FAMILY OF FOUR I JUST
UNDER THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
THIS COULD BE HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS OR FOR JUST A FEW
HEARINGS WHICH INCLUDE
CONTINUANCE. WHILE OTHER
COMPANIES AND JUST ACROSS THAT
ARTIFICIAL BOUNDARY. YET THERE
ARE NO FEES FOR REMOTE ACCESS.
FURTHER THIS INCONSISTENCY AND
REMOTE APPEARANCE THIS HAS
MEANT THAT THERE ARE LESS
RESOURCES FOR LEGAL AID IN PRO
BONO AS OFTEN WE ARE ETHICALLY
WE HAVE ATTORNEYS THAT ARE
ETHICALLY I HAVE TO LIMIT THEIR
SCOPE OF REPRESENTATION AND
ASSISTANCE BECAUSE HER HEALTH
CONCERNS THEY CANNOT GO INTO
COURT. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
THIS CAN CHANGE AND CHANGE
QUICKLY WE CAN WE SEE AND HOW
MANY IS AND WE WILL HEAR FROM
LATER TODAY ALAMEDA COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT. THAT HAS
SUCCESSFULLY ADOPTED CONSISTENT
UNIVERSAL VIDEO PARENTS
TECHNOLOGIES STARTING IN APRIL.
AND THEY ARE A MODEL FOR BEST
PRACTICES. AS IN THE- ALSO AS
WELL AS DETAILED IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER. ALL MAJORITY
OF COUNTIES HAVE DONE SOME A
REMOTE APPEARANCES FIFTY
COUNTIES HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
REMOTE ACCESS AND THIRTY EIGHT
HAVE SOME WITHIN EACH. CASE
TYPE SO THERE IS ALREADY
GROUNDWORK THAT HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED FOR THE
AVAILABILITY STATEWIDE AND THAT
IS CRITICAL WE NEED THAT
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE STATE.
IN CONCLUSION I JUST I WANT TO
AGAIN RECOGNIZE THE HARD WORK
THAT HAS BEEN DONE BUT WE ARE
STILL VERY MUCH IN THE MIDST OF
THIS. MATCH AND THERE IS GREAT
URGENCY AND NEED TO ACT NOW. I
UNDERSTAND WE THE WE HAVE YEARS
TO COME BUT AGAIN WE NEED THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP ESTABLISH
STATEWIDE COURTS SAFETY
GUIDELINES THAT A LONG.
ESTABLISHED CALIFORNIA CODE
GUIDELINES SUCH OF OUR HOLDERS
TIERED SYSTEM THAT IS WELL
KNOWN AND UNDERSTOOD IT. AND TO
HELP SET SAFETY GUIDELINES THAT
ARE LED BY PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS. WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE EXPANSION OF REMOTE
ACCESS AND HAVE A COMMITMENT TO
CONSISTENCY AND FULL EQUAL. AND
ACCESS. FOR ALL LITIGANTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THIS WILL
RICK. A COMMITMENT FOR ADEQUATE
FUNDING WHICH I'M HEARING LOUD
AND CLEAR FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
I THINK THIS TIMELINE IS URGENT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
FINANCIAL BARRIERS ARE NOT IN
THE WAY OF SAFETY AND ACCESS.
IT WHAT HAS BEEN SPENT IN
DISASTER RELIEF DOES NOT DIVERT
FROM OTHER VITAL SERVICES. AND
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
THE LESSONS WE HAVE LEARNED
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC TO ADDRESS
LONGSTANDING STRUCTURAL
INEQUALITIES. LEGAL AID REMAINS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
COURTS AND THE LEGISLATURE IN
DRESS ACCESS TO JUSTICE. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH OUR-
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE TO
MICHELLE BROWN. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS MICHELLE
BROWN AND I'M THE FAMILY LAW
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
I'M A CERTIFIED FAMILY LAW
SPECIALIST AND HAVE BEEN AND
PRACTICED BOOTS ON THE GROUND
TO START CHIEF JUSTICE SAID FOR
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS. AND I
PRACTICED PRIMARILY IN SAN
DIEGO MY TESTIMONY TODAY IS
REGARDING FAMILY LAW AND THE
EFFECT OF THE PANDEMIC HAS HAD
ON THE LITIGANTS AND THE COURT
AND THE INFORMATION THAT I'M
PROVIDING TO YOU YOU IS BASED
ON INFORMATION FROM MY FAMILY
LAW COLLEGE ACROSS THE STATE L.
AS WELL AS THE FAMILY LAW
LITIGANTS THEMSELVES. INTO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS ESTIMATED
THAT APPROXIMATELY 90% OF
FAMILY LAW LITIGANTS ARE SELF
REPRESENTED WE MUST CONSIDER
THE EFFECT THAT THE PANDEMIC
HAS HAD ON THE SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS. WHEN THE PANDEMIC
INITIALLY HIT IT RESULTED IN
ABSOLUTE CHAOS FOR FAMILY
ALREADY GETS PARTICULARLY THOSE
IN CHILD CUSTODY SITUATIONS.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO YOU
HANDLE A TWO PARENT HOME WHICH
ULTRA HOME ORDERS WHAT DO I DO
IF I'VE LOST MY JOB AND I CAN'T
PAY SUPPORT. HOW DO I GET A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER WITH THE ESCALATION OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE. BUT THROUGH THE
COURTS STAKEHOLDERS JUDICIAL
COUNCILS WE'VE WORKED THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC WE ARE ABLE TO
HELP ALLEVIATE THE CHAOS
PROVIDE DIRECTIONS TO FAMILIES
WHO ARE CONCERNED. ABOUT THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE OF
THEIR CHILDREN. WE'VE ACTUALLY
RESULTED IN SOME POSITIVE THE
FACT THAT WE BELIEVE CAN BE
TAKEN INTO FAMILY COURT ARE NOW
INTO THE FUTURE. I'D LIKE TO
BRIEFLY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT KAMALA
LITIGANTS HAVE. HAD THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC SOME OF THE
POSITIVE EFFECTS AND A WAY
FORWARD. ONE OF THE IMPORT
CONSEQUENCES OF THE PANDEMIC
HAS AN ESCALATION IN THE AMOUNT
OF DISSOLUTION OF MARRIAGE
FILINGS AND IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FILINGS. THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AS STATED IN ITS REPORT
IN JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THAT JUST BETWEEN MARCH
AND JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY THERE
WAS A 59% INCREASE IN
ASSISTANCE FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN A 57% INCREASE IN
ASSISTANCE FOR CHILD CUSTODY
ISSUES. SO WITH THE MESSAGE
VIOLENCE AND DOMESTIC ABUSE ON
THE RISE. THE REQUEST FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TEMPORARY AND
PERMANENT RESTRAINING ORDERS
ESCALATED. HOWEVER MOST OF THE
COURTS TO GRAB THE STATE EVEN
WHEN THE COURTS WERE COMPLETELY
CLOSED PROVIDED A MECHANISM
PROTECTED THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
TO OBTAIN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDERS
AND GUN VIOLENCE TO BRING
RESTRAINING ORDERS. IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY EACH COURT HAD AN
EX PARTE INFORMATION BOOTH
WHERE YOU'RE ABLE TO DROP OFF
YOUR APPLICATION FOR A
RESTRAINING ORDER AND THERE IS
ONE JUDICIAL OFFICERS WHO WOULD
REVIEW THE REQUEST AND EITHER
GRANTS IT OR DENY IT IN CAMERA
WITHOUT THE HEARING. ALTHOUGH
THE COURTS ACROSS THE STATE
REALLY DID A GOOD JOB OF
PUTTING ON THEIR WEBSITES
INFORMATION AS TO HOW TO SEEK A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER DURING THE PANDEMIC. WAS
UP THE DIFFICULT FOR ATTORNEYS
LET ALONE SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WAS GOING ON. YES OUR ROLES HAD
TO KNOW TO GO ON TO THE COURT
WEBSITE TO FIND HOW TO GO TO
CODE RELIEF AND HOW TO SEEK A
RESTRAINING ORDER. MANY OF THE
SELF HELP CENTERS WERE CLOSED
INITIALLY AND THEN ONLY REMOTE
SO THOSE SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS HAD A DIFFICULT TIME
FIGURING OUT HOW TO GET THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDERS EVEN THOUGH
THE COURTS DID A GOOD JOB OF
ENSURING. THAT THAT OPPORTUNITY
WAS AVAILABLE FOR VICTIMS OF
ABUSE. A DV EIGHT ZERO. MUST BE
HEARD OR DISSOLVED WITHIN
TWENTY FIVE DAYS AS THE STATUTE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ENACTED
EMERGENCY ROLE EIGHT WHICH
ALLOW THE EXTENSION OF THE
EMERGENCY PROTECTIVE ORDERS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDERS. IS GREATLY
ASSISTED THE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE UNFORTUNATELY
MANY VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT RULE
EIGHT WAS LOOKING KNOW WHETHER.
THE RESTRAINING ORDER HAD BEEN
TERMINATED OR WERE STILL IN
EFFECT. AND ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE COIN AT PARENT MAY ALSO
INCLUDE AN APPLICATION FOR A G.
D. G. RO. I REQUEST FOR
TEMPORARY CUSTODY OR VISITATION
OF THE CHILD. NO CONTACT OR
SUPERVISED VISITATION. WELL
WHAT THE SHOP AT HOME ORDERS.
COURTS CLOSED MANY SUPERVISED
VISITATION MONITORS WERE NO
LONGER DOING SUPERVISION
SUPERVISED VISITATION AND-
LOCATIONS WERE CLOSED THIS
ENDED UP RESULTING IN NO
CONTACT ORDERS AND NO
VISITATION ORDERS. ARE PERSONS
WHO WERE RESTRAINED OR FOR
PERSONS WHO ACTUALLY CURRENTLY
HAD A SUPERVISED VISITATION
ORDER. AND OFTEN TOOK FOUR TO
FIVE MONTHS FOR THESE PERMANENT
RESTRAINING ORDERS TO BE HEARD
AND DURING THAT TIME THE
RESTRAINT QUALITIES OFTEN HAD
NO ACCESS WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
SO ONE OF THE LARGEST
CHALLENGES DURING THE PANDEMIC
FOR FAMILY LAW LITIGANTS. WAS
HOW TO SHARE YOUR CHILDREN AND
IT TO HOME FAMILY WITH A
SHELTER HOME ORDER. THE
REMAINDER FOR YET A QUESTIONS
THAT SUB REPRESENT AGAINST THAT
WERE ATTORNEYS WERE DISCUSSING
AMONG THEMSELVES WE HAD NO
ABILITY TO SEEK COURT GUIDANCE.
SINCE MOST OF THE SCHOOLS WERE
INITIALLY CLOSED DO YOU FOLLOW
YOUR COURT ORDERED CUSTODY PLAN
WHILE THE CHILDREN ARE IN
SCHOOL DO YOU FELT COURT ORDER
CUSTODY PLAN. FOR SUMMER
VACATION. WHAT DO YOU DO IF ONE
PARENT HAS VISITATION WITH THE
CHILD AND THE CHILD IS OUT OF
STATE DO YOU ALLOW THAT CHILD
TO FLY. FOR THE SHELTER AT HOME
ORDERED. WHAT DO YOU DO IF ONE
PARENT TEST POSITIVE FOR COBIT
DO YOU ALLOW THE CHILD TO GO TO
THE OTHER PARENT'S HOME WELL
THESE ARE QUESTIONS. THAT NO
ONE HAD DEALT WITH LAWYERS WERE
ARGUING ABOUT HOW TO ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS SOUTHWEST
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS WERE
COMPLETELY IN THE DARK. WHAT
DID THIS DO THIS RESULTED IN AN
ESCALATION OF PHONE CALLS TO
POLICE AN ESCALATION OF
RESTRAINING ORDERS. GAME
PLAYING. FORTUNATELY THE MANY
OF THE COURTS DID ISSUE FAQS
WHICH STATED THAT CUSTODY ORDER
SHOULD BE ADHERED TO DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND IF THE PARENT WAS
BOUND TO HAVE WRONGLY ABUSED
THE SYSTEM DURING THE PANDEMIC
THEN THAT CAN BE HELD AGAINST
THEM AND A FUTURE MODIFICATION
HEARING. BUT WITH THE BACKLOG
OF CASES AND THE COURTS
TRIAGING TO ENSURE THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS AND
CASES WHERE THERE ARE NO COURT
ORDERS THAT ALL WANT CUSTODY
WERE HEARD. A MODIFICATION
PROCEEDING WAS SIX TO NINE
MONTHS DOWN THE ROAD. THAT ALSO
RESULTED IN ISSUES LIKE I SAID
WERE YOU HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
ORDERS MAYBE THE PARENTS
SEPARATED DURING THE PANDEMIC
BUT THERE WEREN'T DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS HOW
DO YOU SHARE THE CHILDREN WHAT
IF ONE CHILD. STRUCK THAT WHAT
OF ONE PARENT REFUSES TO TURN
THE CHILD OVER TO ANOTHER
PARENT SEEKING SAFETY ISSUES
THESE WERE ALL CONCERNS THAT
WERE IMPACTING FAMILY LAW
LITIGANTS WHICH WERE NOVEL
ISSUES THAT FAMILY LAW
ATTORNEYS HAD TO DEAL WITH. THE
MASSIVE LOSS OF JOBS ACROSS THE
STATE IMPACTED BOTH PLAYERS A
SUPPORT AND RECIPIENTS OF
SUPPORT. I HAD A PLETHORA WHICH
CLIENTS CALLING ME WITH LOTS
THEIR JOBS WHO DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO THERE IS NO WAY TO GET
INTO COURT TO FILE A
MODIFICATION FOR SUPPORT. DID
THEY CONTINUE PAYING SUPPORT
WHICH WOULD MEAN THEM HAVING TO
CASH IN THEIR RETIREMENT
ACCOUNTS OR DID THEY STOP
PAYING SUPPORT ALTOGETHER. HOW
DID THAT AFFECT THE RECIPIENT
OF THE SUPPORT WHO ALL OF A
SUDDEN IT WENT FROM RECEIVING
MONEY TO SUPPORT THE CHILDREN
TWO ZERO. FORTUNATELY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ENACTED
EMERGENCY ROLE THIRTEEN WHICH
ALLOWED THE PARTIES TO SERVE
MOTIONS FOR MODIFICATION ON
SUPPORT EVEN WHEN THE COURTS
WERE CLOSED. AND ALLOW THE
COURTS TO GRANT RETROACTIVE
MODIFICATION OF CHILD OR
SPOUSAL SUPPORT HOWEVER IT WAS
STILL TAKING MONTHS TO GET INTO
THE COURT. WHEN THE COURTS BY
THE RE OPEN FOR HEARINGS THERE
WAS A SIGNIFICANT BACKLOG BUT
THE COURTS REALLY DID AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF PREJUDGING AND
HEARING ISSUES. LIKE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OR INITIAL CUSTODY
ORDERS FIRST. IT DISCUSSING
CUSTODY ISSUES ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT ALSO CAME ABOUT
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND IS A
CONCERN AS WE SIT HERE TODAY IS
THE CHILD CUSTODY RECOMMENDING
COUNCILLORS OR THE FCS FAMILY
COURT SERVICES MEDIATORS.
PREVIOUSLY. THE FAMILY COURT
SERVICES MEDIATOR WOULD SET
WITH BOTH PARENTS EITHER
COLLECTIVELY OR INDEPENDENTLY
FIND OUT WHAT THE SITUATION WAS
OBTAINED THE FACTS AND BE ABLE
TO WRITE A RECOMMENDATION TO
THE JUDICIAL OFFICER ON A
PARENTING PLAN. HOWEVER SINCE
THE PANDEMIC STARTED MOST OF
THESE FAMILY COURT SERVICES
MEDIATIONS HAVE OCCURRED BY
FALL. NOT ONE SES'S REPORTED
BEING IN PERSON THIS IS
RESULTING TO AN FCS COUNSELOR
MAYBE HAVING A ONE HOUR PHONE
CONVERSATION WITH FAMILY LAW
LITIGANTS. AND NOT BEING ABLE
TO ASSESS BODY LANGUAGE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO ACCEPT THOSE
COERCIVE CONTROL ISSUES AND
PERHAPS AS IS UNFORTUNATELY
COMMON IN FAMILY LAWSUIT
SITUATIONS. TO PARENTS STILL
RESIDING IN THE SAME HOME MAYBE
IN DIFFERENT ROOMS ON THE PHONE
WITH THE FAMILY COURT SERVICES
COUNSELOR TRYING TO DECIDE. HOW
TO PLAN THEIR PARENTING. ONE
THING THAT WE WANT THE COURTS
MAY WANT TO CONSIDER IT'S TWO
PENDING A RETURN TO IN PERSON
FAMILY COURT SERVICES SESSIONS
ENSURING THAT ALL FAMILY COURT
SERVICES SESSIONS ARE DONE VIA
VIRTUAL VIDEO PLATFORM. THIS
WAY THE COUNSELORS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SEE PARENTS AND HOW
THEY INTERACT. WITH EACH OTHER
AND- LASTLY WHAT I WANTED TO A-
WAS THE RIVER HEARINGS FAMILY
LAW HAS ACTUALLY DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF ENSURING THAT
ALL FAMILY LAW LITIGANTS ARE
HAVING ACCESS TO THE COURTS.
THEY ARE ABLE TO HAVE THEIR
SUBSTANTIVE HEARINGS HEARD NOT
ONLY ARE WE HAVING REQUEST FOR
ORDER HEARINGS FOR CUSTODY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD SUPPORT
SPOUSAL SUPPORT. THERE ARE ALSO
TRIALS THAT ARE OCCURRING ON
PROPERTY DIVISION I WAS JUST IN
AN ALMOST TWO WEEK TRIAL JUST
LAST MONTH ON PROMOTE. AND
THERE ARE SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH REMOTE ISSUES BUT
THERE ARE ALSO SOME BENEFITS
THAT WE'VE SEEN. SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE ARE THAT
LOW INCOME LITIGANTS MAY NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO COMPUTERS
LAPTOPS OR SMARTPHONES
THEREFORE THEY HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT DIG UP YOUR BY PHONE. THIS
PUTS THEM AT A DISADVANTAGE THE
JUDGES CAN'T SEE THEM THEY
CAN'T SEE THE JUDGE THEY CAN'T
SEE THE OTHER PARTY. IF THERE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES THE
COURTS OFTEN HAVE TO CONTINUE
HEARINGS THIS IS OFTEN DONE AS
A PLOY OF ONE PARENT OR DOESN'T
WANT A COURT HEARING TO GO
FORWARD HERE SHE MAY FAILING TO
HAVE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES.
PRETEND THAT THEY CAN'T HEAR
THE COURT AND THE MATTER GETS
CONTINUE. SOME OF THE MORE JUST
CONCERNING THINGS THAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THAT YOU'RE IN A CHILD
CUSTODY SITUATION. AND YOU'RE
WITH THE CHILDREN WHO ARE AT
HOME DISTANCE LEARNING. YOU CAN
BE IN THE MIDDLE OF A COURT
HEARING DISCUSSING WHO'S GONNA
HAVE CUSTODY OF A CHILD AND
THAT CHILD WALKS IN IN THE-
PRECEDING. OR YOU COULD HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE YOU'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A CUSTODY PROCEEDING
AND A CHILD MAYBE HAS A TEMPER
TANTRUM AND THE CORPS OFFICER
IS HEARING A CHILD SCREAMING
ARE POUNDING ON THE DOOR TO GET
THEIR MOTHER OR FATHER'S
ATTENTION. HOW IS THAT GOING TO
AFFECT THE- COURT'S RULING ON
PARENTING. AND HONESTLY SOME OF
THE BENEFITS LASTLY SOME OF THE
BENEFITS THAT WE WANT TO SAY R.
DESPITE THESE TECHNICAL
CHALLENGES REMOTE HEARINGS HAVE
PROVIDED MORE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
FOR SOME SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS IT IS EXPENSIVE TO GO
TO COURT YOU HAVE A CAR YOU
GOTTA DRIVE TO COURT IT'S OFTEN
THIRTY DOLLARS TO PAY FOR
PARKING HAS TAKEN ENTIRE DAY
OFF OF WORK SOMEONE WHO MAKES
MINIMUM WAGE THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF THEIR
SALARY. HERE THEY COULD ASK FOR
HALF A DAY OFF THE WORK SIT IN
A ROOM AND MAYBE BE ABLE TO
APPEAR FOR COURT THEY DON'T
HAVE TO PAY FOR PARKING THEY
DON'T HAVE TO TAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION DECREASE CHILD
CARE COSTS THEY DON'T HAVE
GUESTS ALLEGE THEIR CHILD ALL
DAY LONG IF YOU REPRESENTED BY
AN ATTORNEY IS A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN ATTORNEY FEES
YOU'RE NOT PAYING FOR YOUR
LAWYER TO DRIVE TO AND FROM
COURT. AND IF YOU HAVE. THE
ABILITY THAT JUDGES HAVE DONE
TO ENABLE A LADY GETS TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION TO THE
COURTS ON THE SPOT IT'S HELP
DRAMATICALLY FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU'RE IN A CHILD SUPPORT
HEARING. AND YOU DON'T HAVE A
PAY STUB THE COURT CAN'T ISSUE
AN ORDER REGARDING CHILD
SUPPORT. THAT THAT PARENT IS AT
HOME THE JUDGES I'VE SEEN
JUDGES STEAK WELL CAN YOU EMAIL
THE PASTE UP TO MY CLERK WELL
LET'S PUT YOU ON RECALL. THE
JUDGE CAN HEAR THE MATTER RIGHT
THEN AND THERE INSTEAD OF
HAVING THESE PARTIES HAVE TO
COME BACK ON ANOTHER DAY. AND
UNLIKE THE CIVIL TRIALS FAMILY
LAW TRIALS OR BENCH TRIALS SO
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE
TRIALS WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO JUSTICE. SO
AS GOING FORWARD. WE MAY WANT
TO CONSIDER A HYBRID. PERHAPS
IN THE FUTURE LET'S HAVE SOME
OF THESE TRIALS OR CREDIBILITY
IS AN ISSUE OR YOU WANT THE
JUDGE TO BE ABLE TO SEE SOMEONE
ON CROSS EXAMINATION. WHERE YOU
WANT TO BE ABLE TO GET THAT
GOTCHA ON IMPEACHMENT. MAYBE
THOSE ARE IN PERSON REQUEST FOR
ORDER HEARINGS MAYBE THEY CAN
STAY REMOTE LET'S LOOK AT
HIGHBRIDGE. ALLOW ELECTRONIC
FILING. THAT AND KEEP DROP
BOXES FOR THOSE SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS I MAY NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO UPLOAD
DOCUMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY EIGHT I'M CONFIDENT THAT
WITH US ALL WORKING TOGETHER
THANK YOU THIS PANDEMIC THE
FAMILY LAW SYSTEM IS GOING TO
COME OUT STRONGER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LET'S GO TO OUR
FINAL PANELIST ON THIS PANEL TO
CATHERINE STEP. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS CAPTAIN STEPHAN- AND
I AM A VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IT IS WITH
GREAT HUMILITY AND GRATITUDE
THAT I SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. I'M
HERE TO DESCRIBE THE
DEVASTATING WAYS IN WHICH CODE
RELATED JUDICIARY DELAYS THAT
IMPACTED MY ELDERLY CLIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THIS IS A BIT
OF BACKGROUND I'M ALSO ON THE
LEGAL REFERRAL SERVICES BOARD
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
TRIAL LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND
CO AUTHOR IN TWO OF THE
CHAPTERS OF THE CV BOOK ON
ELDER ABUSE LITIGATION. I FILED
MY FIRST ELDER ABUSE IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN NO I
DON'T LOOK THAT OLD. WHAT IT
WAS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
AND I THE PRACTICE TO DO THE
MATH- MY FOR IS IN SERVICES
WHERE FOR LAWYER WORK TIME I
WOULD CASES- ALL THAT'S ALL I
DO ONE OF THE THINGS I'VE
NOTICED SYSTEM AT THE VERY
SHORT- PART OF THIS HEARING IS
THAT NOBODY'S TALKED ABOUT
ELDERS- AND NOT TO SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT YOUR CHILDREN NEED TO BE
PROTECTED BUT OTHERS HAVE NOT
BEEN MENTIONED BUT ELDERS
ESPECIALLY ELDERS LIVING AND-
NURSING HOMES AND YOU KNOW WITH
SERIOUS INJURIES HAVE BEEN-
NEGLECTED. YOU KNOW THEY AREN'T
THEY REQUIRE. PRIORITY LIKE
CHILDREN. AS I JUST KNOW JUST
WANT TO SOME REFERRED ABOUT THE-
TO FOCUS ON THE CHILDREN NOT
THAT THAT'S ONE OF. BUT I THINK
WE NEED. TO NOW AND WE ALL KNOW
THAT RIGHT NOW BEING IN A
NURSING HOME. IS POSSIBLY A
DEATH SENTENCE. FOR A INJURED
ALTER. I TELL PEOPLE THAT MY
CLIENTS ARE EITHER USUALLY
DEMENTED OR DEATH. WE BRING
CASES AGAINST LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES ON BEHALF OF VICTIMS
OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT. IF MY
CLIENT. IS ALIVE THEY'RE OLD.
AND THEIR MEDICAL CONDITIONS
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE IN THESE
FACILITIES AND THE FINANCIAL
ABUSE CASES THEY'VE BEEN
SWINDLED OUT OF THEIR LIFE
SAVINGS AND HAVE NO CHANCE OF
OTHER INCOME AND THEY HAVE
HEALTH CONDITIONS TO ATTEND TO.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO GIVE JUST
SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN BOTH MY CASES AND
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES. IN WAYS
THAT TO SHOW HOW ELDERS HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY HARMED
DUE TO THEIR HEALTH STATUS AND
THE COOK WITH PANDEMIC. MY
CLIENTS DO NOT HAVE THE LUXURY
OF TIME. THEY ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
AND UNIQUELY DISADVANTAGED BY
THE WAY. WHAT I WANTED TO JUST
GO THROUGH VERY SPECIFICALLY
WITH YOU JUST SO YOU CAN SEE
WHAT JUST THE SIMPLE HOLTZ NOT
SIGNING OF AN ORDER DOES TO OUR
CLIENTS AND ONE HAPPENS TO SIT
ON A JUDGE DOES FOR FOUR MONTHS.
SO FIRST CLIENT JAMES NONE.
FILED AN ELDER ABUSE CASE
AGAINST A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
HE WAS NINETY FOUR YEARS OLD AT
THE TIME AND TIME WAS OF THE
ESSENCE. YEAH AMPUTATION IN
JUNE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY AFTER
HAVING A PRESSURE ULCER OR
DECUBITUS ULCER AT THE FACILITY
AND WE WERE GENERALLY CONCERNED
WHETHER HE WOULD EVEN SURVIVE
TO THE END OF THE CASE. WITHOUT
THE CASE RIGHT AWAY RIGHT
BEFORE THE COURT SHUT DOWN ON
MARCH AND WHEN THEY RE OPEN WE
NEED IT WE FILED A MOTION FOR
PREFERENCE WELL IF MY CLIENTS
ARE LIVING THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
A TRIAL WITHIN A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS AFTER- THE MOTION
IS HEARD SO THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT PREFERENTIAL TRIALS
FOR ELDERS ARE NEEDED. BECAUSE
THEY'LL DIE IN ALL GO INTO THAT
LATER. DUE TO THE COURT BACK.
IT WAS SET FOR JUNE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY IT CAN THE
COURT CONTINUED THE MOTION AND
EVEN AFTER GRANTING OUR MOTION
FOR PREFERENCE ON SEPTEMBER
FIRST TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. THE
COURT DIDN'T GIVE US A TRIAL
DATE. FOR THE QUOTE INSTEAD THE
COURT SET A TRIAL SETTING
CONFERENCE ON IN SEPTEMBER
TWENTY NINTH. AT THAT HEARING
THE COURT SAID IT COULD GIVE US
A TRIAL WITHIN THE HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS FOR THE CODE. SO IT
WAS SET FOR. A JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. MR
NONE WAS LITERALLY DYING AND WE
HAVE WE WERE FORCED TO SETTLE
THE CASE. PRIOR TO HIS DAY IN
COURT. IN FEDERAL VERSES CHASE
WE HAVE A FINANCIAL ELDER ABUSE
CASE ARISING FROM A SWEETHEART
SCAM THE DRAIN ALL OF AN EIGHTY
SEVEN YEAR OLD. OF LIFE SAVINGS
FROM HIS BANK ACCOUNT. IT WAS
BROUGHT AGAINST CASE BANK.
CHASE BANK ALLEGING THAT
THROUGH HIS REPRESENTATIVES WE
HAVE NOTICED THAT HE'S
POTENTIALLY BEING SCAMMED AT
THIS DID NOTHING ABOUT IT
IGNORING ALL OF THE GOVERNMENT
ADVISORIES THEY HAD DIDN'T
RESPOND TO THE RED FLAGS AND
THEY TOOK TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS HIS ENTIRE LIFE
SAVINGS. HE MEETS THE CRITERIA
FOR FUNDING FOR A PREFERENTIAL
TRIAL SETTING. AND HE HAS
NOTHING AND HE'S LIVING
PRACTICALLY SWALLOW RIGHT NOW.
THIS CASE WAS INITIALLY FILED
IN SAN FRANCISCO SUPERIOR COURT
FEBRUARY TWENTY SIX TWO
THOUSAND AND- RIGHT BEFORE WE
KNEW THE EXTENT OF CODE. THE
CASE WAS REMOVED TO FEDERAL
COURT BY CHASE IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. SUPERIOR COURT
ALMOST FIVE MONTHS LATER IN
OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. A
HEARING YEAH YES WE GOT OKAY
AND THEN- OKAY GREAT AND THEN
SO IT WAS AND THEN THE COURT
WAS SUPPOSED TO SEND IT SAN
FRANCISCO SEND IT TO- RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND I WAS OVER TWO
MONTHS AGO. WE'VE BEEN MAKING
PHONE CALLS BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY
TRYING TO LEAST EVEN GET A CASE
NUMBER WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
CASES AND MY STAFF AND WE HAVE
BEEN MAKING NUMEROUS PHONE
CALLS EVEN FIND OUT WHERE THIS
CASE IS SO WE CAN'T EVEN ASK
FOR PREFERENTIAL TRIAL SITTING
WITH THIS MAN WAS EIGHTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD WAS LOST ALL HIS
MONEY. MISTER CUNNINGHAM
ANOTHER CLIENT IS EIGHTY FIVE
YEAR OLD HUSBAND OF A WOMAN WHO
DIED AFTER DEVELOPING GANGRENE
FROM ABOUT SORT OF THE
DEVELOPED IN ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITY IN SAN MATEO COUNTY.
WE FILED OUR COMPLAINT THE CASE
DECEMBER NINETEENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. ON JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY WE FILED A MOTION FOR
PREFERENCE HEARING WHICH WAS
SET MARCH SIX TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY WAS RESET FOR APRIL
TENTH. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
HEARING WAS THEN CONTINUED FOUR
TIMES. BECAUSE OF CODE RELATED
DAYS DELAYS AND ON OCTOBER
NINTH THE MOTION WAS GRANTED
AND IT WAS SET FOR A TRIAL ON
FEBRUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. ON DECEMBER
EIGHTEENTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THE COURT SO SPONTANEOUS
VACATED THE TRIAL. VACATED THE
SETTLEMENT CONFERENCE AND JUST
TALK ABOUT COUNTER AND SAID
COME SEE ME ON JANUARY SEVENTH
WHICH WE SHOWED UP FOR AND THAT
AND THAT WAS SET FOR TRIAL ON
MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH MARCH FIRST
TWO THOUSAND. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND THAT WAS ONLY AFTER HE ATE
HIS RIGHT TO A JURY TRIAL AND
WE AGREED TO A BENCH TRIAL. WE
REPRESENT A WOMAN NAMED KERRY
IN A WALL SHOULD DISABLED WOMAN
WHOSE CARE IS SUPERVISED BY THE
REGIONAL CENTER. THIS IS A CASE
AGAINST AN ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY. SHE DEVELOPED A BLOOD
INFECTION AND BRAIN INJURY DUE
TO AN UNTREATED INFECTION. THE
REGIONAL CENTER WE'RE WORKING
WITH WOULD LIKE TO FIND FUNDS
TO PLACE HER IN A MORE
APPROPRIATE SETTING TUTOR
INJURIES. WE FILED THAT
COMPLAINT. AND THE GUARDIAN
ADLAI ITEM APPLICATION WHICH WE
NEED TO HAVE SO WE CAN GET A
SUMMONS TO START THE COMPLY
STARTED GOING. SEPTEMBER FOURTH.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY. THE COURT DID NOTHING
FOR FOUR MONTHS WE TRIED
CALLING EVERYONE WE TRIED
CALLING THE CLERK WE TRIED
EMAILING PEOPLE WE YOU KNOW
PRACTICALLY STOPPED YOU KNOW I
PRACTICALLY STOOD OUTSIDE THE
WINDOW YOU KNOW TRY TRY TO GET
SOMEONE TO FIND OUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON TRYING TO REACH OUT
YOU KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THIS ORDER SIGNED AND THE COURT
GRANTED THE MOTION ON JANUARY
FOURTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
SO THAT WAS FOUR MONTHS. MY
COLLEAGUES THAT REPORTED THE
SAME STORIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ONE TOLD ME THEY
REPRESENTED A WOMAN WHO'S AT A
NURSING HOME OF THE TRACK TO
THAT WAS DISLODGED RESULTING IN
A SEVERE LACK OF OXYGEN TO THE
BRAIN. THEY FILED THEIR
COMPLAINT AND THE GUARD AND
PETITION LIKE WE DID IS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY ON OCTOBER FIFTH
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THAT ORDER
WAS NOT SIGNED UNTIL DECEMBER
EIGHTEENTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
THAT ORDER SAT ON A DESK
SOMEWHERE JUST LIKE OURS. THEN
THE COURT DID NOT ISSUE THE
SUMMONS UNTIL JANUARY. SIXTH
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
ANOTHER TOLD ME THAT SHE- AN
EIGHTY YEAR OLD CLIENT WAS
ACTUALLY THROWN ON THE FLOOR BY
CAREGIVERS. SUSTAINED FRACTURES
OF THE BONES ON HER FACE. WITH
TIME RUNNING SHE QUICKLY FILED
AND STARTING AT A LIGHT AND
WHAT SHE NEEDED. IT TOOK SIX
MONTHS ORANGE COUNTY JUDGE JUST
SIGNED THE ORDER. JUST TO ALLOW
SOMEONE TO BRING THE CASE.
DURING THAT TIME SHE DIED. ON
THE OTHER END OF THE SPECTRUM
WE HAVE A LIVING OUT THERE
WAITING FOR HER DAY IN COURT.
THE FUNDS THAT SHE NEEDS TO
CARE FOR HERSELF WITH THE
INJURIES SHE SUSTAINED. WHILE
WAITING IN THE FACILITY WITH NO
FAMILY TO CHECK ON HER. AND NO
ONE TO GO WITH THE LOVE AND
ENCOURAGEMENT SHE NEEDS. SHEER
DIES OF COVERED. OR LONELINESS.
PEOPLE ARE DYING OF LONELINESS.
IN OUR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES PEOPLE JUST DON'T
WANT TO GO ON WHEN THEIR FAMILY
DOESN'T COME. AND THOSE PEOPLE
DESERVES TO MOVE OUT OF THOSE
FACILITIES AND FIND A BETTER
PLACE AND RECEIVE JUSTICE. IF
SHE DIES. THE DAMAGES TO
COMPENSATE HER FOR HUMAN
SUFFERING DIE WITH HER UNLESS
AN ATTORNEY LIKE ME AN ELDER
ABUSE ATTORNEY CAN PROVE THAT
THERE'S CLEAR CONVINCING
EVIDENCE. BY A MANAGING AGENT
OF RECKLESSNESS. THAT'S VERY
VERY CLOSE TO WHAT YOU NEED FOR
PUNITIVE DAMAGES THIS IS JUST
AND WE WAIT. THIS IS A VERY
EXCEEDINGLY DIFFICULT- LEVEL TO
REACH AND SO WHAT I WANT TO
JUST POINT OUT TO YOU IS THAT
JUST WAITING FOR FOUR MONTHS
FOR A SIGNATURE SITTING ON A
JUDGES STAFF. BUT DOES IT MEAN
THAT TO MY CLIENTS. SO ON
BEHALF OF C. ROC- YOU KNOW WE
FEEL THAT YOU KNOW THERE IS A
PROBLEM. AND THAT WE THINK THAT
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH NEEDS TO
MOVE FORWARD IN THREE AREAS
NUMBER ONE WE ASK THAT PEOPLE
WHO ARE PREFERENCE CASES CAN
HAVE THEIR TRIAL BEFORE THEY
DIED NO MATTER WHAT COUNTY THEY
LIVE IN. THE PREFERENCE CASES
NEED TO GET A TRIAL DATE. AND
THEY SHOULDN'T USE THESE ORDER
SHOULD NOT FOR ELDER SHOULD NOT
BE SITTING ON THE DESK OF
JUDGES. SECONDLY WE THINK THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A CRASH PROGRAM
TO YOU THE RESTORED TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO ATTACK THE
BACKLOG. THERE'S ALREADY A
BACKLOG WE ALL KNOW WHAT'S
GOING TO GET WORSE AND WE NEED
TO HAVE SOME MINIMUM STANDARDS
LIKE OTHER PANELS ARE TALKING
ABOUT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON. IN FACT IT'S NOT JUST
THE COUNTY EACH JUDGE HAS THEIR
OWN RULES WE HAVE NO IDEA. I
CAN'T FIGURE IT OUT I DON'T
KNOW HOW TO IMPROVE PERSPECTIVE
PURPOSES POSTED FIGURED OUT.
LOOK WE HAVE A- DATA RIGHT NOW
TO KNOW THAT THERE'S A SERIOUS
PROBLEMS AND THIS NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED- RIGHT NOW. OKAY I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE NEED THE
DATA WE NEED THOSE THINGS. BUT
WE NEED I THINK THAT THESE
COMMITTEES ARE ASKING. WE WANT
TO GIVE YOU MONEY. TO DO
SOMETHING HERE TO LIKE GET THIS
BACKLOG SO WE'RE ASKING TO HAVE
THIS WE'RE NOT WE DON'T WE
DON'T NEED ALL THE DATA WE KNOW
THERE'S A TSUNAMI. IT'S ALREADY
COMMON THERE'S A BIGGER. ONE
COMING BEHIND IT. SO I OTHER
ANYTHING ANYONE NEEDS I'M AT
YOUR BECK AND CALL AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY- TO
LISTEN ON BEHALF OF WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE ELDERLY THANK
YOU. STE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ALL THREE
AND REALLY. BRINGING AND
RELATING THE STORIES AND MAKING
IT. PERSONAL UNDERSTANDABLE
WHAT'S WHAT'S AT STAKE HOWEVER
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. SO ARE
THERE QUESTIONS OF THIS PANEL.
FOR MANY OF THE MEMBERS. RIGHT
SEEING NONE THANK YOU AND WE
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT PANEL
PANEL THREE SENATOR UMBERG
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE THE LEAD
ON THIS ONE. BOB THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU
THE PREVIOUS PANEL
ILLUMINATING- AS OF YET WITH
PANEL THREE THE IMPACT OF
CLOVER NINETEEN AND PANDEMIC ON
THE COURTS AND COURT PERSONNEL
WE HAVE FOUR WITNESSES NANCY CS
EVER HEARD THE COURT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE SUPERIOR COURT
OF SAMBAR DINO COUNTY. DOUBLE
THOMAS EIGHT THE LANEY'S PEER
COURT OF ORANGE COUNTY PRESENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA JUST
ASSOCIATION- HE IS A HOMETOWN
HERO JANET TUNIC CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF INTERPRETERS- CFI
LOCAL THREE NINE ZERO ZERO AND
JUDY LOUIS SAN FRANCISCO ACCESS
CENTER. SO LET'S LET'S BEGIN
WITH MISS EVER HARDNESS OF ARE
YOU PRESENT. I AM THANK YOU
SENATOR- BURKE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL THIS IS NANCY
EVERHART RECORDED SECOND OF
OFFICER IT'S NUMBER NINETEEN S.
COURT ALSO CHAIR OF THE COURT
EXECUTIVES ADVISORY COMMITTEE
AN ADVISORY MEMBER JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. ON THE SURVEY THAT
MISTER YOUNG SUMMARIZE
PREVIOUSLY IS IMPORTANT AND
THAT IT GATHERS THE EXPERIENCE
OF THE TRIAL COURTS IN A WAY
THAT BEGINS TO SEE COMMON
TRENDS BETWEEN HEALTH AND
SAFETY NEEDS. AND CHALLENGES OF
ACCESS AGAINST KOBE ACCESS AND
THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITIES TO
REIMAGINE THE WORK OF THE COURT.
WHAT EMERGENCY OR AUTHORIZING
OP. AND ITS LOCAL BUT SEVERAL.
THE COURTS TO EXPAND REMOTE
ACCESS TO HEARINGS JURY
SELECTION STRAINING PUBLIC
HEARINGS LIVE CHAT REMOTE SELF
HELP ONCE COMPLETION WHAT KIND
OF VIOLENCE. DIGITAL EVIDENCE
DOCUMENT ROUTING AND SIGNATURES
AND EVEN INVESTIGATION DUTIES
AROUND CONSERVATORSHIP
GUARDIANSHIP CHILD CUSTODY AND
VISITATION. WE ARE COMPLETING
THOUSANDS OF CASES WERE BY
REMOTE HEARING EACH DAY. IN LA
WHERE SIX HUNDRED CARTONS HAVE
REMOTE TECHNOLOGY UPWARDS OF
FIVE THOUSAND CASES ARE HEARD
REMOTELY PER DAY. IN JANUARY
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED NEED FOR LITIGANTS
PARTICIPATED IN UNLIMITED CIVIL
PROCEEDINGS IN LOS ANGELES. AND
SAN DIEGO A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
COURT ROOMS HAVE REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY HEARING AROUND A
THOUSAND CASES PER DAY. IN
SANTA CLARA JUVENILE DEPENDENCY
IS COMPLETELY MORE ABOUT. AN
ORANGE THEY MADE CURRENT SMALL
CLAIMS IN TRAFFIC MATTERS. AND
IN MONTEREY AND SANTA CRUZ THEY
PROVIDE WHAT SERVICES
EXTENSIVELY. IN MY COURT WE
LAUNCHED A NEW DIGITAL ACCESS
SELF HELP PLATFORM. THIS ALLOWS
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS
ACCESS FORMS WORKSHOPS LIVE
CHAT YOU FILES AND DOCUMENTS
REVIEWED. BY DEDICATED STAFF
MEMBERS AND TO COMPLETE. TO DO
LIST. TWO BILLION SIX HUNDRED
AND NINETY SEARCH USERS
REGISTER PERSON. AND JUNE OF
THOUSAND TWENTY HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE ADDITIONAL REGISTER FR AT.
INTEL FROM THROUGH DECEMBER OF
202-400-0800 AND SEVENTY EIGHT
LITIGANTS REACHED OUT CARRILLO
SYSTEMS MANY COURT SHARE
SIMILAR STORIES. COULD YOU
JUSTICE IS CHARGED TO SEARCH
FOR A 310060 DEGREES ACCESS
OPPORTUNITY IS HAPPENING IN OUR
COURTS. IT'S A SAMPLE IT'S
EXPANDABLE IT'S EXCITING AND
WHILE STILL MAINTAINING IN
PERSON ACCESS AS PERMITTED.
HEALTH AND SAFETY AS WE TALKED
ABOUT A LOT TODAY IS A
SIGNIFICANT FACTOR IN THE
COURT'S ABILITY TO MAINTAIN
SERVICES. AND DEPENDENT UPON
THE MANY VERY PUBLIC ORDERS
EACH COUNTING THUS RESULTING IN
DIFFERENT MEASURES AND
EXPERIENCES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THE APPLICATION OF
JUSTICE IS SOCIAL IN NATURE
WHAT IS THE CENTRAL COMPONENT
IS NOW DANGEROUS TO ALL
PARTICIPANTS IN EVEN MORE SO.
GIVEN OUR COURTS HAVE NOT BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS PRIORITY
UNLEASHING THE VACCINES. THE
TRIAL COURTS HAVE AGGRESSIVELY
IMPLEMENTED MASK WEARING
ORDERS. SOCIAL DISTANCING
PROCEDURES SIGNAGE ALTERNATIVE
DELIVERY OPTIONS TRIAGE
ALLIANCE CALENDAR MANAGEMENT
ENHANCED. TEMPERATURE AND
HEALTH SCREENING TEMPORARY
PHYSICAL BARRIERS. REMOTE WORK
STAGGERED SHIFTS MOVEMENT OF
STAFF JUDGES AND JURIES TO
CREATE SPACE AND SPACE LIMITED
FACILITIES. OR EVEN ALTERNATIVE
PLEASE THE SAUDIS FOR RESOURCES
ALLOW. IN SAMBAR TO DINO IS SET
UP TO ALTERNATIVE FACILITIES
ONE FOR JURY SELECTION AT A
COLLEGE. AND ANOTHER. ONE IF
THEY CAN STORAGE AREA. FOR OF
REALITY UPPER. WE ARE OPERATE
STAFF RESOURCE TO ADDRESS KOBE.
BY PROVIDING. OVER APPEARANCE
TECHNOLOGY. PHYSICAL DISTANCE
MONITORS LIVE CHAT MONITORS
EXPANDED CALL CENTERS EXPANDED
CUSTODIAL SERVICES NOTICED IN
RENO TO SING AND MOVING
HEARINGS. IN SANTA CRUZ THEIR
EMPLOYEE NEEDS HAVE DOUBLED TO
MANAGER TO MANAGE. A STABBER
JURY CHECK INS. COURTS HAVE
REALITY STAFF TO PROVIDE
CONTACT TRACING THEIR COURTS L.
A. RECORDS NINE STAFF ORANGE
SIX SAN DIEGO FIVE SAMPOERNA
DINO FOR STAFF DIVERTED TO FULL
TIME CONTACT TRACING. ADDING
HEALTH AND SAFETY MEASURES
COMES AT HUGE MONETARY RESOURCE
REALLOCATION RELOCATION COSTS
TO THE COURTS AND COMMUNITIES
TO DIVERT FUNDS FROM CORE
OPERATIONS AND MY COURT ENHANCE
JANITORIAL CLEANING IN OUR
BUILDINGS IS THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH EXTRA. IN LA
THAT CROSSES OVER FIVE MILLION.
DIMINISHED ACCESS TO THE COURT
AND BACKLOGS ARE THE RESULT OF
MANY FACTORS. SEVEN JUDGES HAVE
NOT BEEN AVAILABLE TO WORK DUE
TO POSITIVE RESULTS QUARANTINE
REQUIREMENTS SCHOOL AND DAYCARE
CLOSURES AND SOME STAFF AND
JUDGES HAVE RETIRED OR QUIT. IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
BEFORE THE BIG HOLIDAY SEARCH
FORTY SEVEN COURTS REPORTED
LOST WORKDAYS IN EIGHTEEN
COURSE REPORTED LOST JUDICIAL
WORKMATES. AT HEART HI POINT IN
DECEMBER MY COURT HAD A HIGH OF
THIRTY NINE POSITIVE STAFF
MEMBERS ON WEDNESDAY AND OVER
ONE HUNDRED QUARANTINE. WITH
TWO TEMPORARY COURTROOM
CLOSURES. IN ORANGE COUNTY ONE
POSITIVE CASE RESULT IN
REPORTED CONTACT TRACING
INVESTIGATIONS. IN SANTA CLARA
AND ENTIRE DEPARTMENT WAS
QUARANTINE BACKING UP WORK FOR
THAT CASE START OVER TWO WEEKS
NOW A REPORT SIMILAR ISSUES.
OUR EMPLOYEES ARE EXHAUSTED
DELAYS CAN BE SEEN IN FILINGS
TIME HEARING TELEPHONE WAIT
TIMES ACCESSING FILES AND A
HOST OF OTHER COURT FUNCTIONS.
RESOURCES ARE STRETCHED FURTHER
BY SEVERE TRIAL COURT BUDGET
REDUCTIONS THIS FISCAL YEAR
THAT HAS RESULTED IN LAYOFFS
FURLOUGHS AND HOPEFULLY THEY
CAN SEIZE. AND ALL OF THE TRIAL
COURT'S. IN PERSON CORPS
CALENDAR EVERY DAY 22225%
CAPACITY DUE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. A STANDARD
COURTROOM IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD
HOLD APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
PEOPLE. WITH SOCIAL DISTANCING
ELEVEN PEOPLE IS THE MAXIMUM
CAPACITY INCLUDING THE JUDGE
AND STAFF. SOME OLDER COURTROOM
SHOULD NOT HOLD MORE THAN FIVE.
MANDATORY IN PERSON HEARINGS
AND JURY TRIALS HAVE SLOWED AND
CALENDARS MUST BE FREQUENTLY.
CONTINUE THE SURVEY SHOWS
SEVERE INCREASES AND CRIMINAL
AND CIVIL CONTINUANCES ARE JURY
CHAU RANKS IN SALMON AND YOU
KNOW HAVE DECLINED FROM 25%
SHOW RATE 211% SHOW RATE.
REMOTE PROCEEDINGS WILL HELP
BRING MATTERS FORWARD WHERE
APPROPRIATE BUT THESE NEW
REMOTE PROCEEDINGS ALSO DELAY
CALAVERAS DUE IN PART TO CALL
AND GET CONNECTION. AND USE OUR
KNOWLEDGE OF THE APPLICATION.
IN MANY COURTS MUST WAIT
OUTSIDE IN VARYING WEATHER
CONDITIONS IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE AT THE
COURTHOUSE. IN MODERATE THE
QUEUE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WAS
CREATED TO ALLOW COURT USERS
CHECK IN THEN WAIT IN THEIR CAR
FOR A TEXT BEFORE ENTERING THE
COURTHOUSE. COURTS HAVE A WHOLE
AS A WHOLE HAVE PERFORMED
HEROICALLY SHIFTING RESHEF
CORPORATIONS TO ADDRESS
MULTIPLE CHALLENGES. IN
MULTIPLE WAYS SINCE THE ONSET
OF THE NINETEEN. IMPACTORS
RESULT OF CODE IS THE WORST
I'VE SEEN IN THIRTY YEARS OF
SERVICE IN THIS BRANCH.
RESTORATION WILL TAKE TIME TO
ACHIEVE ONCE IT'S SAFE TO
RESUME. NORMAL AND FUNDING IS
ONCE AGAIN AVAILABLE TO DO SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SURE THAT PART OF THAT STORY I
WOULD BE HONORED TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISS EVERHART.
DEADLINE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER US USUALLY CENTER ON
BURGER FELLOW HOMETOWN HERO AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE- COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STALLED ON
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION I DO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY ABOUT THE IMPACT THE
PANDEMIC IS OUT ON THE COURTS
AND COURT PERSONNEL. AND HERE
ARE PROVIDED SUBSTANTIAL DETAIL
ON THE NUMBERS THEREFORE I'M
GONNA TAKE A MORE BROADER
APPROACH BY TALKING ABOUT HOW
THE PANDEMIC IS SHED SOME LIGHT
ON OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM. IS
CERTAINLY HAS HIGHLIGHTED
STRENGTHS. PROVEN LEADERSHIP
THROUGHOUT THE G. JUDAS BRANCH
MOST READ THROUGH THE TIRELESS
EFFORTS OF OUR CHIEF JUSTICE.
THE CONSISTENT COLLABORATION
WITH JUSTICE PARTNERS. AND
EXTENSIVE COMMON GROUND THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH SHARES WITH
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT AND
MEMBERS OF THE BAR I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE HEARING TODAY. FROM
MISS CHANG AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE BAR AND THEIR CHALLENGES
AND CHALLENGES THEIR CLIENTS
FACE. OUR JUDICIAL OFFICERS AND
THEIR UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING EQUAL ACCESS TO EQUAL
JUSTICE AT ALL TIMES. AND LET
ME JUST SAY THAT WHO WE ARE AS
JUDICIAL OFFICERS IS BEST
DEMONSTRATED DEMONSTRATED BY
THOSE THAT WE SERVE. THIS PHOTO
COLLAGE PROVIDES. A
DEMONSTRATION OF PEOPLE WHO
WEEK SERVE WHO COULD BE PEOPLE
WE SERVE ON ANY PANEL IN ANY
COURTHOUSE DEPARTMENT IN ANY
COUNTY. OUR JUDICIAL OFFICERS
ARE KEENLY AWARE OF THE PEOPLE
WE SERVE. THE PEOPLE FOR WHOM
WE NEED TO PROVIDE EQUAL ACCESS
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER ALL
CIRCUMSTANCES AND YES THAT
INCLUDES THOSE WHO QUALIFY FOR
CIVIL TRIAL PREFERENCE. AND NOT
MIS STEP WHERE I HEARD ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOUR CLIENT IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO EXCUSE FOR THAT.
I DO ASSURE YOU THAT THAT
THAT'S MORE OF A RESULT OF WHAT
HAPPENED WITH OUR STAFF IS MS
EVER HARD JUST DESCRIBED BUT
THERE IS NO EXCUSE FOR THAT I
MYSELF SIT TWO TRIALS FOR
PREFERENCE BOTH RESOLVED.
BEFORE THEY COULD GO TO TRIAL.
JUDGE WE LOST A LOT. MY STILL
CAN YOU STILL HEAR ME AND SEE
ME WE CAN HAND NOW. CAN YOU SEE
ME NOW WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE COLLAGE. OKAY I'M TRYING TO
GET THAT OFF. WE GO OKAY OKAY
YOU SEEN OUT CENTER WE CAN'T.
ALL RIGHT SO- SO ALONG WITH
THOSE HIGHLIGHTED STRENGTHS BY
THE PANDEMIC EXPOSED THE DEPTH
OF WEAKNESSES IN SOME
LIMITATIONS OF OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM ONE IS OUR RELIANCE ON
LIMITED AN AGING SPACE OR
PHYSICAL PLANT AND I'M BACK IN
A MATTER ABOUT WHICH WE WERE
PREVIOUSLY UNAWARE. OF
BUILDINGS ALWAYS PRESENTED TO
COST BUT WAS FINANCIAL NOW ARE
BUILDINGS THAT ARE SPACED REYES
HEALTH AND SAFETY COSTS TO
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE AT STAKE TRY
AS WE MIGHT JUST SPREAD OUT IN
CERTAIN SOCIAL WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS THE
REALITY IS WE CANNOT CONDUCT
JURY PROCEEDINGS SELECTION OR
TRIALS AT LEAST NOT IN THE SAME
NUMBERS IN THE SAME REASONABLE
TIME SAFELY IN THE LIMITED
SPACE WE HAVE IN OUR COURT
HOUSES. IN OUR PROGRAMS WE ALL
KNOW THE PRIORITY
CONSTITUTIONAL PREFERENCE
AFFORDED CRIMINAL TRIALS AND
THE GOOD REASONS FOR IT
PEOPLE'S LIBERTY IS AT STAKE
STILL NO ONE WILL DENY THAT WE
NEED TO DO ALL WE CAN TO GET TO
JUSTICE CIVIL JUSTICE SYSTEM
MOVING FORWARD MORE EFFICIENTLY
BUT SAFELY WITHIN OUR CURRENT
LIMITATIONS. WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH REMOTE CIVIL LAW
LAWN OTION HEARINGS AND WE
KNOW THAT THOSE WILL HELP MOVE
THOSE CASES FORWARD HOPEFULLY
TOWARD RESOLUTION AND AS WE
PROCEED WE CANNOT FORGET THE
EXISTING ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS
COURT TRIALS EXPEDITED TRIALS.
TRIALS WERE YOU STIPULATE TO
FEWER THAN TWELVE JURORS ALL
OPTIONS UTILIZED DURING THE
BEST OF TIMES IT CAN STILL
APPLY TODAY SIMILAR ETCETERA
BURKE THESE ALTERNATIVES THAT
YOU THAT. WILL HELP ADDRESS
SOME OF THE TOUGH QUESTIONS YOU
ASKED ABOUT THE FIVE YEAR
STATUTE THE BIG THING WE CAN DO
NOW AND THAT WE CAN DO GOING
FORWARD WELL. TO HELP ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THAT BACKLOG. FROM DAY
ONE WE'VE- CREATIVE ALTER.
STAGGERING TRIAL TO. CREATING
TO CALL HOUSES ONE IN THE
MORNING ONE IN THE AFTERNOON.
GOING OFF SITE TO LARGER SPACES
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE. IT IS USE
WITH THOSE ALTERNATIVES
ROSAMILIA IMMEDIATELY. ISSUES
INVOLVING STAFF AND EMPLOYEES
WHO BY THE WAY ARE WORKING
INCREDIBLY HARD UNDER VERY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES CENTER
HERZOG I BELIEVE IT WAS YOU WHO
COMMENTED ON THE VACCINE
PRIORITY. WE APPRECIATE THAT
COMMENT WE MADE THAT REQUEST
ALONG WITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
NOT TO GAIN ANY UNFAIR
ADVANTAGE BY ANY MEANS IN FACT
IT WAS MORE ABOUT OUR EMPLOYEES
AND THE HEALTH RISKS. THAT THEY
ARE UNDER BY SHOWING UP TO
COURT EVERY DAY. ALSO THERE
ISSUES INVOLVED LOGISTICS AND
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
TECHNOLOGY OUR SITE WHICH MADE
IT MORE DIFFICULT AND OF COURSE
THERE WERE ADDITIONAL COST OF
SECURITY AT ON SECURED
LOCATIONS. WHICH EXACERBATED
THE ALREADY MOUNTING CONCERNS
OVER THE INCREASING COST OF
COURTHOUSE SECURITY. THIS
RESULTED OR ROSA REASONS AND
SEVERAL OF OUR COUNTIES.
ANOTHER WEAKNESS IS THE ACCESS
TO TECHNOLOGY NOW THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH HAS MADE GREAT STRIDES
OVER THE YEARS ON TECHNOLOGY.
BUT THE MOVE TO REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS IN A PANDEMIC HOW
TO HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY. SUDDENLY
REMOTE ACCESS WAS NO LONGER FOR
CONVENIENCE IT WAS A NECESSITY.
CHALLENGES AMHERST IMMEDIATELY.
FROM TRAINS ARE JUST OFFICES ON
DIFFERENT MEDIUMS TO UNEVEN
BAND WITH. TO COST. BOTH TO THE
COURT AND TO THE PUBLIC. JUST
ISSUE INVOLVING EQUAL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE TO LITIGANTS CONSISTENT
WITH MR RICHARDSON'S COMMENTS
AND THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO
ACCESS TO OUR PROCEEDINGS WHICH
ARE PUBLIC PROCEEDINGS. FINALLY
UNDER THE HEADING OF THE
NECESSITY THAT NECESSITY IS THE
MOTHER OF INVENTION. DEMOCRATS
ALSO REVEALED POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS WHICH DOUBLE AS REAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE FUTURE.
THE NEED FOR GREATER RESOURCES
AND TECHNOLOGY IS A PARENT WE
NEED TO EXPLORE OPTIONS FOR
BEST PRACTICES BOTH ON THE
TECHNOLOGY ITSELF. HOW TO APPLY
IT IN IN OUR DIFFERENT PRACTICE
AREAS EACH OF WHICH WILL BE
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT. BASED ON
THE DIFFERENT NATURE OF THOSE
PRACTICE AREAS THEMSELVES AND
THE DIFFERENT NEEDS OF EACH
LOCAL COMMUNITY OUR RECORDS
SIR. WE NEED TO EXPLORE WHAT.
MORE WHAT SOME COURTS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO WITH REMOTE JURY
PROCEEDINGS WE WILL HERE IN A
FEW MINUTES FROM JUDGE DO SO
TELLS ABOUT ALAMEDA SUCCESS
WITH REMOTE JURY PROCEEDINGS.
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
HAS FORMED A JOINT TASK FORCE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IT'S NICE TO SEE
MICHELLE BROWN HERE. THAT JOINT
TASK FORCE IS LOOKING AT REMOTE
TRIAL COURT PROCEEDINGS WHICH
WILL COVER BOTH CORRECT BEST
PRACTICES FOR ALL PANELS. AS
WELL AS JURY PROCEEDINGS NOW
AND GOING FORWARD WITH AN EYE
ON WHAT LEGISLATION WE NEED. TO
IMPROVE AND MAINTAIN. THIS IS
AND WILL BE ON. THE CODE
PANDEMIC. THE IDEA REMOTE
COURTROOMS- REMOTE COURT
FACILITIES ALSO IS HAS
POSSIBILITIES WE DISCUSSED THE
POTENTIAL USE OF OFFICE
COURTROOMS COUNTY BUILDING
STADIUMS STADIUM SEATING. OUR
SCHOOLS EVEN THEATERS TO
ACCOMMODATE LARGE CRIMINAL AND
CIVIL CALENDARS THE MORE NON
JURY WORK WE CAN DO OFF SITE
SAFELY. THE MORE SPACE WE MAY
BE ABLE TO CREATE FOR OUR
JURIES BOTH CRIMINAL CRIMINAL
AND CIVIL AND THEY ALL DEMAND
AND ALL THAT THE DEMAND IN
TERMS OF THE STAFF. THE COSTS
AND THE SECURITY WE ARE THE
CHIEF JUSTICE TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SOME OF WHAT ARE COUNTIES
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DO. FINALLY
WE NEED MORE OPPORTUNITIES LIKE
THIS. ECHOING WHAT MS CHANG
SAID WE NEED TO ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES AND ENGAGE MORE
CONSISTENTLY IN DIALOGUE WITH
OUR JUSTICE PARTNERS. ON HOW TO
PROVIDE GREATER ACCESS NOT ONLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC BUT OTHER
POTENTIAL SITUATIONS LIKE
NATURAL DISASTERS. ALL
RECURRING ISSUES WITH OUR AGING
PHYSICAL PLANT LIKE ASBESTOS
THAT CAN AND HAVE CLOSED OUR
COURTHOUSES IN ORANGE COUNTY
AND IN OTHER PLACES. I AM
CONVINCED AND I THINK WE ALL
ARE AFTER WHATEVER TODAY IT WE
WHAT WE DO NOW CAN AND WILL
AFFORD OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GREATER EFFICIENCIES. IN OUR
FUTURE OPERATIONS. THIS IS A
GREAT UP TO START TO START THIS
DISCUSSION THAT NEEDS TO
CONTINUE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. TO
RAISE ISSUES AND DISCUSS ISSUES
THAT ARE UNIQUE TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AND STATE WIDE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN PROCEED
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY AND
ALL OF OUR CASES INCLUDING OUR
CIVIL JURY TRIALS. AND WE NEED
TO DO IT NOW SO WE CAN GET A
PLAN. A REALISTIC PLAN WITH A
REALISTIC PRICE TAG TO YOU SO
WE CAN MAKE IT HAPPEN SOONER
THAN LATER THE TWO HUNDRED THE
MORE THAN TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION. LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
OUR JUSTICE PARTNERS TO
FORMULATE SOLUTIONS THAT WORK.
SO WE CAN PROVIDE. 109 DEGREES
DO YOU CENTER 260 DEGREES
ACCESS TO EQUAL JUSTICE EQUAL
JUSTICE. FOR ALL IN CALIFORNIA
UNDER ANY AND ALL CIRCUMSTANCES
AND AGAIN WE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU JUDGE.
NEXT THE PANDA CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF INTERPRETERS.
THANK THAT NOONE I AM GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COUNTY
FORTY TO TESTIFY TODAY MY
NAME'S JANET SHOULD IT COME
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF INTERPRETERS WE ARE THE
UNION THAT REPRESENTS ALL
INTRUDERS IN CALIFORNIA. OF THE
FOUR EIGHT GIVE ANY SPECIFIC
STATEMENTS LET ME JUST GIVE A
BRIEF FULL. INTERPRETERS HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT TO UNEQUAL HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROTOCOLS D. ONGOING
ELIMINATION CONTRIBUTOR POLICE
HAVE RESULTED IN GREATER
STRAINS IN MAKING INTERPRETERS
AVAILABLE. FORCING MANY TO WORK
UNDER UNDER ADEQUATE SAFETY
PROTOCOLS OFTEN WITHOUT HEALTH
INSURANCE. CFRN IS SOMEONE
UNIQUE AS IT IS A STATE WIDE
UNION WHOLLY COMPRISED OF
INTRAPRENEURS NOT JUST FROM A
SINGLE COUNTY BUT ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTS WE REPRESENTED
GUARDIAN FOR ALL SPOKEN
LANGUAGE IN TRIPURA EMPLOYEES
IN CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO THANK
THE LEGISLATORS AND THE
GOVERNOR FOR ITS ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO LANGUAGE ACCESS
AND SUPPORT FOR INTERPRETERS.
THE COURT INTERPRETERS LINE
ITEM IN THE STATE BUDGET FOR
WHILE YOU NEED FOR COURT
EMPLOYEES REFLECTS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL FEDERAL AND
STATE SUBMIT MANDATES TO
PROVIDE LANGUAGE ACCESS IN ALL
CASES. ARE BUDGET ITEM HAS
NEVER BEEN DECREASE IT HAS
INCREASED EVERY YEAR EVEN
DURING THE TIGHTEST OF YOURS.
INSPIRE COMMITMENT SEVERAL
FACTORS PREPEND THEM IT KEPT
COMPLEMENT COMPLICATED THE
DELIVERY OF A CONTRIBUTOR
SERVICES OVER THE PAST YEAR. I
HAVE CONTRIBUTED AND HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY TRAGEDIES FOR TRIPS.
FIRST DESPITE THE LEGISLATORS
APPROVAL OF OUR OWN OF OUR
INCREASE BUDGET LINE ITEM EVERY
YEAR MANY COURTS HAVE CUT BACK
AND ELIMINATED INTERPRETER
POSITION. SOME COURTS HAVE
EMPLOYEE POSSESS POSTING
IMPROPER POSTINGS IN WHICH
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS HAVE
APPLIED COULD NEVER GET A CALL
BACK. YES TO HIRE THEM ITS
CONTRACTORS. COURTS HAVE
SHIFTED FROM EMPLOYEE
INTERPRETER TO INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR INTEREST. SANTA
CLARA COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE 65%
THE WORKERS OR CONTRACTORS.
THIS RESULTS IN LESS COST
EFFICIENCY AND LESS ABILITY
AVAILABILITY OF INTERPRETERS
AND IS CONTRARY TO THE TWO
THOUSAND TWO IN TRIPURA ACT
PASSED BY LEGISLATORS. WHEN THE
PANDEMIC HIT INTERPRETERS WITH
THE KURDS. GIVEN THAT WE ARE
ESTABLISH IS THE REGIONAL
KOREAN SYSTEM WITH UNIFORM
CONDITIONS INDULGE IN DROUGHT
EACH REGION WE REQUESTED TO
DISCUSS KEEPING INTERPRETERS
HEALTHY AND SAFE- INCUMBENT AT
A REGIONAL LEVEL ONLY TO BE
TURNED AWAY. FROM THE ONSET WE
REQUESTED KEEP E. SPECIFIC
PRINTER PRINTERS EVEN GETTING
THE BASIC P. P. HE WAS A
STRUGGLE SOME COURSEWORK. MORE
WORKABLE THAN OTHERS THE P. P.
GIVEN WAS NOT ADEQUATE FOR
TRUCKERS. PRIOR TO THE SEARCH
MOST COURTS WERE FOCUSED ON
KEEPING STAFF SOMEONE STATE.
BUT AS BACKLOGS PILED UP THE
FOCUS CHANGE AS COLBERT'S SURGE
RAMPED UP COURTS ALSO INCREASED
OPERATIONS. DUE TO THE PRE
EXISTING SHRINKING EMPLOYEE
POOL SURE OF US WERE AVAILABLE
TO COVER THE LANGUAGE YOU NEED
TO THE COURT THAT MEANT THE
AMOUNT OF WORK OF EACH
INTERPRETER INCREASED. AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THE
NEW SEARCH WITH LITTLE
PROTECTIONS. RIGHT NOW COURT
HEARINGS ARE BEING CONDUCTED
MOSTLY BY A MIX OF IN PERSON
EMPLOYEES AND CONTRACTORS AND
IN SOME CASES VIDEO REMOTE
INTERPRETING. HOWEVER
INTERPRETERS NOT ONLY WORK IN
THE COURTROOMS. INTERPRETERS
ALSO WORK IN HALLWAYS AND
WAITING AREAS HELPING ATTORNEYS
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR CLIENTS
AND HELPING WITH FORMS. MANY
COURTS ARE SENDING INTERPRETERS
TO THE JAILS FOR SECOND. THESE
INTERPRETER THESE INTERVIEWS
ARE CONDUCTED IN SMALL NON
VENTILATED ROOMS INSIDE THE
JAIL WITH THE INTERPRETER THE
DOCTOR THE DEFENDANT ARE LESS
THAN SIX FEET DISTANCE. FROM
EACH OTHER FORTY FOUR NINE
EVALUATION THAT LASTED OVER AN
HOUR. UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THIS IS THE NORM.
UNDER KOBE IT'S JUST DANGEROUS.
ON THE ONE HAND IN PERSON IS
THE APPROPRIATE INTERPRETER
MODEL. FOR MANY REASONS
PRIMARILY. TO BENEFIT THE COURT
USER THERE IS GREATER
CONFIDENCE AND PARTICIPATE SHE
IN IN PROCEEDINGS AND SOMEONE
IS ACCOMPANIED BY AN
INTERPRETER. IN PERSON
INTERPRETER IT ENSURES QUALITY
COMMUNICATION AND ALSO MOST
EFFECTIVE AND SPEEDIEST. WE
HAVE HEARD FOR THIS FOR YEARS
AND YEARS HOWEVER WITH YOUR
EMPLOYEE INTERPRETERS EACH
EMPLOYEE IS COVERING MORE AND
MORE COURT ROOMS IN A SINGLE
DAY CREATING GREATER EXPOSURE
TO GLOBAL NINETEEN AND LESS
EFFECTIVE LANGUAGE ACCESS. AND
WE HAVE BEEN FORCED TO RELY ON
VIDEO REMOTE WHICH LARGELY
LARGELY IS INDUCED INEFFECTIVE
AND DETRIMENTAL TO THOSE WHO
NEED WHO NEED OUR SERVICES.
EIGHTY EIGHT DOESN'T GO GO BY
WHEN TECHNOLOGY DOESN'T FAIL.
AFTER THIS PANDEMIC VIDEO
REMOTE SHOULD NOT BE USED AS A
SUBSTITUTION FOR IN PERSON
INTERPRETING. ADDITIONAL
INTERPRETERS ARE RECEIVING LESS
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS
ANOTHER COURT EMPLOYEES FOR
EXAMPLE COURT REPORTERS CLERKS
BENCH OFFICERS INSIDE THE
COURTROOM- CORRECTLY PROTECTED
BY TEXT PLEXI GLASS
INTRAPRENEURS ARE NOT. WE ARE
GIVEN FUTURE ANY PROTECTIONS
UNLIKE OTHER COURTS STAFF THAT
WERE PUT IN A CONFINED SPACE
INTERPRETERS DO NOT. AN
INTERPRETER WORDS SPACE CONSIST
OF WORKING IN CLOSE PROXIMITY
TO COURT USERS INSIDE
COURTROOMS. NEAR IT BECAUSE THE
DEFENDANTS WERE TRANSPORTED TO
COURT. IN HALLWAYS AND WAITING
AREAS WHICH ARE OFTEN TOO MANY
WERE THERE TOO MANY INDIVIDUALS
GROUPS CDC RECOMMENDATIONS AND
NOT ENOUGH TO FIFTEEN SOCIAL.
PROPER SOCIAL DISTANCING. THE
MOST TRAGIC OUTCOME IS REDUCED
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS
WHAT HAPPENING LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. AN INTERPRETER WAS
EXPOSED TO COLD IN THE
COURTROOM WELL OTHER EMPLOYEES
WERE ALLOWED TO QUARANTINE AT
HOME SHE WAS NOT. IN PART
BECAUSE THERE WERE FEWER IN
TRIPURA EMPLOYEES DESPITE
AVAILABLE FUNDING. SHE ASKED
FOR TIME OFF TO QUARANTINE BUT
WAS DENIED. SHE WAS FORCED TO
WORK AND ON HER OWN SOUGHT OUT
A CO THAT TEST SHE DAYS LATER
SHE RECEIVED NOTICE OF A
POSITIVE TEST RESULT. IN THE
DAYS SINCE HER EXPOSURE SHE WAS
FORCED TO GO TO THE COURTHOUSE.
AND BE AROUND HER TRIP THERE
COLLEAGUES. AS A RESULT ALMOST
TWENTY INTERPRETERS IN THAT
COURTHOUSE WERE EXPOSED. SACHEM
CAPITAL BECAME SICK WITH A COLD
IT. AND FROM THAT EXPOSURE SHE
PASSED AWAY JANUARY SEVENTEENTH.
THE SAME THING HAPPENED TO DAN
FELIX. IN A DIFFERENT COURT
BUILDING. WO MORE INTERPRETERS
HAVE PASSED AWAY SINCE THEN.
THESE INTERPRETERS WORK DAILY
IN THE ALLEY COURTS S.
INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE CONTRACTORS.
DAVID BASKET NOT WHAT. WE GOT
PORK CHOP KEYCHAIN. IF GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY THEY WOULD'VE
OPTED TO THE EMPLOYEE. BOTH OF
THESE INTERPRETERS WORKED IN
COURTROOMS AND SMALL HOLDING
CELL STATES PRIOR TO TESTING
POSITIVE. COOLEY CARPAL WAITED
UNTIL THE LAST MINUTE TO GO TO
THE HOSPITAL. KEEP YOUR THE
HIGH COST OF HEALTHCARE. AS A
CONTRACTOR. THEY DON'T HAVE
HELP. SINCE THEY HAVE NO
PROTECTIONS NO BENEFITS. HEALTH
CARE WORKERS. THE HEALTH KERR
I'M SORRY HEALTHCARE WORKERS
COLLUDED NINETEEN DEATH RATE IS
ONE IN SIX THOUSAND WE LOST FOR
ANY COURT WITH THREE HUNDRED IN
A STATE WHERE THERE'S LESS THAN
ONE THOUSAND ENTREPRENEURS
WORKING IN THE COURTS. FOR
YEARS WHICH HAS STRUGGLED WITH
OUR LOCAL COURTS TO BE TREATED
ASK RESPECTED. WORKFORCE THEY
CUT. OUR RANKS DESPITE WHO
FUNDING FROM THE LEGISLATOR
WE'RE TRYING TO REPLACE IS WITH
TECHNOLOGY OR TRIED TO LIMIT
OUR ABILITY TO ACTUALLY
INTERPRET FOR INDIVIDUALS. WE
HAD TO SECURE BUDGET CONTROL
LANGUAGE SIMPLY TO ALLOW US TO
INTERPRET BETWEEN ATTORNEY AND
CLIENT WELL OFF THE RECORDS
WERE TAKING A TEN MINUTE BREAK
BECAUSE PRESIDING JUDGES WERE
TELLING US THAT WE CAN ONLY
PROVIDE LANGUAGE ACCESS WHILE
ON THE RECORD. THIS CONTINUOUS
WAVE UNDERMINING INTERPRETERS
AND THOSE WHO USES ARRIED OVER
TO SLOPPY AND DEADLY DISREGARD
FOR OUR SAFETY. IN KERN COUNTY
SEVENTEEN INTERPRETERS WERE
FORCED TO SIT IN THE SAME NON
VENTILATED ROOM FOR AN HOUR AND
A HALF AS A QUASI FOR A LITTLE
WHILE OTHER EMPLOYEES WERE FREE
TO LEAVE THE BUILDING. IN SHORT.
THE MOST DANGEROUS PRACTICE
DURING THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
KEEPING FEWER PROTECTION TWO
INTERPRETERS AND OTHER
EMPLOYEES AND NOW WE HAVE LOST
THE LIVES OF FOR WORKAHOLICS.
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE.
INTERPRETERS NEED TO BE ANY
NEED TO BE PROVIDED WITH HEALTH
AND SAFETY TOOLS THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR OUR JOBS THIS
INCLUDES FACE SHIELD FOR
INTERPRETERS. AS CHILLS FOR
WITNESSES ARE TESTIFYING THAT
USE INSTRUCTORS TWO WAY RADIO
INCORPORATE QUICKENING ATTORNEY
CLIENT IN JAIL INTERVIEW SHOULD
BE CONDUCTED SAFELY WITH CDC
GUIDELINES IN MIND.
HEALTHSPRING THAT THE DOOR
INFORCE MASK WEARING LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF COURT USERS STABBER
SCHEDULED COURT TIMES TO REDUCE
QUARTERS OUR FOOTPRINT CREATE
SAY FAIRNESS FOR INTERPRETERS.
SO INTERPRETERS CAN DO THEIR
OWN COURTROOM AND CELERY DUTIES
SAFELY AND IMPROVE CONTACT
TRACY. WE NEED STRONG UNIFORM
SAFETY PROTOCOLS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE NOT JUST IN ONE COURTROOM
OR IN SOME. COURTS NEED TO HIRE
MORE EMPLOYEES INCENTIVIZE
COURSE WERE PRIORITIZING THE
HIRING WILL PLEASE GIVE
CONTRACTORS- ALREADY WORKING
PRIMARILY AND MOST OF THE TIME
FOR THE COURSE AND EMPLOYMENT
AT. JOE WAITED WITH THE
RECENTLY ADOPTED DISTRIBUTION
OF THE LINE ITEM FUND THAT
LIMITS AND PUNISHES COURTS
WOULD PRIORITIZE EMPLOYMENT. WE
NEED MORE IN PERSON IN TRIPURA
POLICE TO REDUCE DELAYS AND WE
TACKLE BACKLOG. AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOUR
ATTENTION AND THE DOCTOR
CHANGED I'M- FORTY ONE AND JUST
SAY A FEW WORDS. THANK YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MISS YOU TAKE A VERY
VERY POWERFUL TESTIMONY AND
YOUR PASSION CLEARLY FOR THOSE
THAT YOU REPRESENT THANK YOU.
THE NEXT OF NECESSITY LOUISE
SAN FRANCISCO ACCESS CENTER.
BUT AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE THE CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
TODAY AT THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT I'M PROCEEDING- CAN
EVERYONE SEE MY SHIRT SCREEN.
AND WE SEE YOUR SCREEN. WE
DON'T OKAY GREAT WE SEE ONE.
OKAY THANK YOU SO LAST YEAR I
GAVE TESTIMONY REGARDING THE
SAN FRANCISCO SUPERIOR COURT IN
PERSON DIRECT SERVICES SELF
HELP SERVICE DELIVERY MODEL
WHICH INCLUDED IT. WALK IN
CLINICS WORKSHOPS ONE ON ONE
APPOINTMENTS US MAIL
CORRESPONDENCE AND COURT ROOM
ASSISTANCE. WE KNOW THAT SELF
HELP CENTERS ARE A CORE
FUNCTION OF THE COURTS AND THAT
THE IMPACT OF SELF HELP CENTERS
GOES FAR BEYOND JUST DIRECT
SERVICES FOR THE SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS. SELF
HELP CENTERS STATEWIDE SEE A
CHAIN OF INTACT PRE FILING AN
ON DAY OF COURT FOR EXAMPLE BY
ASSISTING A SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANT WITH THE EXPLANATION
OF THE LAW LEGAL PROCEDURES AND
FORMS COMPLETION THE SELF HELP
SERVICES ENSURE THAT ALL
PAPERWORK IS PREPARED AND
PACKAGED CORRECTLY STREAMLINING
THE PROCESS FOR THE FILING
WINDOWS IN CIVIL OPERATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY IN TAKE AN
INTERVIEW AT SELF HELP CENTERS
PROVIDE A VENUE FOR THE SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS TO TELL
THEIR SIDE OF THE STORY AND
OFTEN SIMPLY THAT THIS PROCESS
INCREASES EFFICIENCIES DURING
COURT PROCEEDINGS BECAUSE SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS CAN THEN
FOCUS ON THE ISSUES THAT AND
CAN BE BETTER PREPARED WHEN
THEY- APPEAR BEFORE THE JUDGE.
THE CHANGE IMPACT BECAME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR ONCE IT WAS
DISRUPTED BY THE FIRST ROUND OF
SHELTER IN PLACE CLOSURES YES
THE CENTER HAD TO CANCEL ALL
APPOINTMENTS AND COMPLETELY
SUSPEND ONSITE SERVICES THE
SHELTER IN PLACE OF LAW
LIBRARIES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND LEGAL
SERVICES FURTHER REDUCED
AVAILABLE RESOURCES FOR SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS. AT THE
SUPERIOR COURT PERSONNEL AND
DIVISIONS WERE IMPACTED BY THE
CLOSURE OF ACCESS SHERIFF
DEPUTIES AT THE COURTHOUSE
LOBBY METAL DETECTORS COULD NO
LONGER REFERRED SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS DIRECTLY
TO ONSITE. HEALTH HELP
ASSISTANCE FILING WINDOWS
RECEIVED FORMS FROM SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS THAT WERE
INCOMPLETE OR HAD NUMEROUS
ERRORS AND MISSING PAGES.
RECORDS DEPARTMENT AND OTHER
CIVIL DIVISIONS WERE INUNDATED
WITH TELEPHONE INCREASED FROM
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS WHO
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE SOUGHT
ASSISTANCE ON SITE AT THE SELF
HELP CENTER. AND FINALLY COURT
ROOMS COULD NOT SEND SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS TO ACCESS
FOR EXPLANATION OF COURT ORDERS
OR HELP. WITH SERVICE OF
PROCESS ISSUES. IN RESPONSE TO
THE SHELTER IN PLACE CLOSURES
THE ACCESS CENTER BEGAN TO
TRANSITION TO REMOTE SERVICES
IMMEDIATELY THE DAY AFTER PLACE
WAS IN PLACE. AND THROUGHOUT
THE THREE MONTHS OF ACCESS
CLOSURE ACTUAL STAFF WORK FROM
HOME TO CAR TAX SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS WITH
THEIR PENDING MATTERS PROVIDE
LEGAL INFORMATION AND TO
RESCHEDULE APPOINTMENTS. A
PRIMARY CHALLENGE THAT AXLE
STAFF FACED WAS A LACK OF
NECESSARY EQUIPMENT REQUIRING
STAFF TO USE THEIR OWN. DEVICES
THEIR OWN PERSONAL LAPTOPS AND
PHONES TO CONTACT. SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS MY WEEK
TO ACCESS RESEARCH ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES WEBSITES
SPECIFICALLY TO IDENTIFY AND
ADOPT VIRTUAL SELF HELP BEST
PRACTICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AFTER AFTER IT DEVELOPED
WRITTEN MATERIALS TO BE
PUBLISHED ON THE ACCESS WEBPAGE.
THE COURTS CLOSURE ACCESS WORK
IN STAGES TO DELIVER SERVICES
TO A BROAD SERVICE DELIVERY
MODEL PUBLISHING AN ONLINE
INFORMATIONAL LIBRARY CREATING
AN EMAIL ADDRESS FOR EMAIL
INCREASED SETTING UP TO
TELEPHONE VOICE MAILS ONLINE
CHATS THROUGH LIVE CHAT VIRTUAL
APPOINTMENTS USING TEAMS AND
ZERO CRACK. ONLINE CALENDAR AND
SCHEDULING AND WITHIN THREE
MONTHS OF SHELTER IN PLACE
ACCESS RETURNED TO THE
COURTHOUSE FOR LIMITED ONSITE
SERVICES. DURING FACE TO ACCESS
BUILT A NEXT REMOTE MODEL AND
EXPANDED INNOVATION INNOVATIONS
TO INCLUDE TRANSLATION OF ITS
INFORMATIONAL LIBRARY INTO THE
SPANISH CHINESE VIETNAMESE
RUSSIAN AND TO GAWLER LANGUAGES.
EMAILS HAVE BEEN STREAMLINED TO
ONLINE SURVEY MONKEY AND
CURRY'S VOICEMAILS ARE
SUPPORTED WITH THE ADDITION OF
THE IBR LIVE LINE DURING THE
STRIKE AND SHELTER IN PLACE.
AXEL'S IDENTIFIED ONSITE
SOLUTIONS TO INCORPORATE A
KIOSK CHIU MATIC APER TICKETING
SYSTEM FOR SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS WHO MAY NOT HAVE A
COMPUTER OR A SMARTPHONE. BUT
OUR FIRST TRANSITION OF
CREATING ONLINE RESOURCES STUFF
REPRESENT THAT WOULD AGAINST
COULD FIND INFORMATION ONLINE
TO OBTAIN PRELIMINARY
INFORMATION AND TO START CASES
ON THEIR OWN. WE SAW A MASSIVE
IMPACT HERE WITH EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINETY EIGHT HITS ON THE
ACCESS SELF HELP WEB PAGE AFTER
POSTING ONLINE MATERIALS THE
NUMBER OF DAILY WEBPAGE
VISITORS NEARLY TRIPLED. TO
TRANSITIONING TO OUR VIRTUAL
REMOTE MODEL YES THE CENTER HAS
PROVIDED DIRECT SERVICES TO
EIGHT THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE. SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS WHEN WE BREAK DOWN
THE DATA WE CAN SEE THAT
TELEPHONE ASSISTANCE PROVIDES
THE GREATEST ACCESS. IT IS
SIGNIFICANT TO NOTE THAT A
LARGE PORTION OF SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS VISIT THE
COURTHOUSE FOR ASSISTANCE EVEN
WHEN ACCESS TRANSITION AND
IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL VIRTUAL AND
REMOTE SERVICE OPTIONS. I WILL
JOIN MISS MICHELLE BROWN AND
SAY THE HYBRID MODEL IS THE
FUTURE OF SELF HELP AS WELL AS
OTHER DIVISIONS. AND ACT AS
ACCESS CONTINUES TO EXPLORE
ENHANCING THE VIRTUAL SELF HELP
MODEL. ACCESS WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE ONSITE
SERVICES FOR SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS WHO DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET NOR
COMPUTERS PRINTERS SMARTPHONES
PHOTOCOPIER STAPLERS TO HOLD
PENSION OTHER BASIC OFFICE
SUPPLIES NEEDED FOR COURT
FILINGS. ANY SELF REPRESENTED
LITIGANTS ALSO REQUIRE IN
PERSON ASSISTANCE FOR COMPLEX
MATTERS AND FOR THOSE FACING
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES DUE TO
LITERACY OR LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY PROFICIENCY. SELF.
WAS MY TEAM LAST YEAR AND IT
CONTINUES TO BE THIRTEEN THIS
YEAR A YBRID MODEL OF. BOTH IN
PERSON AND VIRTUAL REMOTE
SERVICES AND MAXIMIZES THE
SCOPE OF SELF HELP SERVICES AND
REACHES THE POPULATIONS AND THE
MOST ME. I WANT TO ADDRESS
EIGHT EIGHT A QUESTION THAT WAS
POSED EARLIER TODAY HOW TO
DETERMINE BASIC LEVELS OF
ACCESS THAT ARE ACCEPTABLE
HOWEVER COURTS AND- HOW CAN
COURTS MEET THAT STANDARD. SO
SAN FRANCISCO WAS ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION IT
SERVICE DELIVERY MODEL DURING
SHELTER IN PLACE BECAUSE WE
WERE FORTUNATE TO APPLY FOR AND
BE AWARDED GRANT FUNDING FROM
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE BILL
TO BUILD. A VIRTUAL SELF HELP
CENTER. MANY COURTS ESPECIALLY
IN SMALLER COUNTIES ARE STILL
STRUGGLING DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS
SEEKING ASSISTANCE IN SMALLER
COUNTIES SHOULD RECEIVE THE
SAME SELF HELP SERVICES AS SELF
REPRESENT THAT AGAINST. SEEKING
ASSISTANCE FRANCISCO OR
COUNTIES WITH GREATER RESOURCES
SO OUR EATING LOCAL PLAYING
FIELD IS PROBABLY THE BEST
START AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MISS LORI
APPRECIATE THAT TEST WENT UP
JUST A COUPLE OBSERVATIONS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE JUDICIARY IS
A THIRD INDEPENDENT BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT JUST AS WE WOULD NOT
WANT THE COURTS TO TELL US HOW
TO DO OUR BUSINESS. I ASSUME
YOU DON'T WANT THE LEGISLATURE
TO TELL YOU HOW TO DO YOUR
BUSINESS BUT- JUST LOOKING AT
TODAY'S HEARING I CAN SEE THE
LEVEL OF INTEREST. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO DEMONSTRATE ONE
POINT WE HAD OVER 25% OF THE
SENATE WAS HERE FOR THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. WE HAD
TEN OF THE ELEVEN MEMBERS A
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE THREE OF THE FIVE
BUDGET SUB CHAIRS SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIRS WHO ARE PRESENT SO THIS
IS AN AREA OF. TREMENDOUS
INTEREST AND IMPORTANCE TO
CALIFORNIANS. WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT BEST
PRACTICES- AND WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN IN GATHERING
THOSE BEST PRACTICES WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN THE PLAN WERE
VARIANTS THE TIMELINE MORE
VARIANTS OF MAKING SURE THAT
THE DISPARITIES THAT WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT TODAY BETWEEN THE
VARIOUS COUNTIES. OF DOESN'T
CONTINUE TO EXIST THAT ONE
COUNTY YOU MAY BE ABLE TO GET
ACCESS TO JUSTICE NEARLY
IMMEDIATELY ANOTHER COUNTY IT
MAY BE YEARS BEFORE YOU GET
ACCESS TO JUSTICE. SECONDLY IS
THE DISPARITY WITH RESPECT TO
COST WHERE YOU CAN CALL IN SOME
PLACES FOUR ZERO OR YOU CAN
ACCESS THE HEARING VIRTUALLY
FOR NO COST OTHER PLACES IT'S A
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER QUARTER
CALL ANY OF THAT. SO WE ARE
INTERESTED I KNOW THIS SOUNDS
LIKE MY CLOTHES MISTER CHAIR
BUT BUT IT IS NOT QUITE BUT BUT
WE ARE INTERESTED IN THOSE
SOLUTIONS WE'RE INTERESTED IN
THE JUDICIARY AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. WHO PARTICIPATE
IN THE SYSTEM FIDO'S WHATEVER
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES NEED TO BE
MADE IT'S NOT JUST A FUNCTION
OF MONEY THE THERE'S A FUNCTION
THERE'S ALSO SOME EFFICIENCIES
TO BE AFFECTED AND EVENT. SO
THANK YOU- QUESTIONS AS- YEAH.
I'M YOU KNOW WE FOR LEARNED
THAT- BEHAVIORS HAVE CHANGED
YOUR INDEPENDENT MAKE WHAT WE
WERE THINKING LAST APRIL FOR
WHAT THE HOSPITAL SITUATION-
INDUSTRY WAS THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THE SCHOOLS WERE THINKING
ABOUT HAS RADICALLY CHANGE YOU
KNOW THE IDEA THAT THAT FOLKS
DON'T NEED TO HAVE MASKER HAVE
MASK DO WE STAY CLEAN THIS THIS
AREA UP HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
UNBELIEVABLE AMOUNT WE REALIZE
THE BEST PRACTICES DON'T DON'T.
NECESSARILY REQUIRE THAT WE
BECOME SMARTER IT'D I GUESS THE
QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS IN THE
IN THE COURTS. WHERE ARE WE AT
THE VILLAGE WE'VE GOT THIS
REPORT ON THE PERSONNEL AND THE
COURTS FOR OVER THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS RIGHT NOW WE'RE SITTING
ON. FEBRUARY TWENTY THIRD WHAT
ARE THE THING WHAT ARE THE WHAT
ARE THE PRACTICES OTHER THAN
THE HYBRID MODEL I GUESS IS
WHAT I'M HEARING WHAT ARE THE-
WHAT ARE THE- THINGS THAT WE
CAN HAVE WE CAN HELP OUT WITH.
THAT DON'T INCLUDE I GUESS I
WOULD SAY THE ATTITUDES THAT
SOME JUDICIAL OFFICERS WILL
HAVE OR SET IT. UP COURT
ADMINISTRATORS THAT WE CAN WE
CAN HELP OUT BECAUSE IT'S NICE
TO HEAR THE STORY HOW WE GOT
HERE AND ALL THE PAINS AND
SUFFERING BUT WE KNOW NOW. WE
HAVE TO A DOUBLE MASTER'S
THINKING OF THE INTERPRETER
MEAN I KNOW. IT SEEMS IT IS
PRETTY SIMPLE THINGS YOU COULD
DO THAT WE DIDN'T KNOW IN APRIL
MAY AND I GET I GET THAT BUT
NOW. I BE NUTS HAVE A DOUBLE
MASS GOING TO WALK INTO A COURT
ROOM OR- A PLACE THAT WAS AN
AIRPLANE OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
SO. OTHER THINGS THAT. THE
JUDGES IN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND THE- INTERPRETERS
THAT THEY ALL AGREE ON THE DCR-
IRREFUTABLE NOT DEBATABLE
PRACTICES TO REDUCE SPECIALLY.
KING ABOUT DISTANCE HOW CAN YOU
FORCE ELEVEN PEOPLE IN A ROOM
RIGHT NOW THAT JUST SOUNDS LIKE
A AN OUTRAGEOUS ATTEMPTED SO.
I'M ASSUMING THAT THAT HAPPENED
IT'S AN OUT LIAR IT'S NOT PART
OF THE PRACTICES THAT THIRD
THIRD DOING TODAY SO I DON'T
KNOW IF ANY OF THE PANELISTS.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THAT ON
THE PANEL. I CAN GO AHEAD AND
AN ATTEMPT TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION ALTHOUGH I THINK IT
MAY BE DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON
THE COURT EXPERIENCE THIS IS
NANCY EVERHART AGAIN NUMBER
NINETY NOW- YOU KNOW WE'VE
LEARNED A LOT SINCE MARCH WHEN
WE WHEN WE HAVE TO REDUCE
SERVICES AND- WE'VE LEARNED
WHERE TO GET MASS AND HOW TO
WEAR MASKS AND HOW DO. HOW TO
APPLY SIGNAGE AND OTHER SOCIAL
DISTANCE I THINK SOME OF THE
BARRIERS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE OUR AROUND SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THE INADEQUACY
OF OUR FACILITIES- YOU KNOW
WE'VE USE PLEXIGLAS BARRIERS
WHERE WE CAN'T BUT IN GENERAL
COURT ROOMS ARE NOT SUFFICIENT
SO HOW DO WE FIND ALTERNATIVE
FACILITIES FOR THAT. POLICING
COSTS ARE VERY EXPENSIVE IN A
TIME WHERE WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
THE BUDGET AVAILABLE- STAFFING
IS NOT AVAILABLE TO HANDLE
EXPANDED COURTROOM CASES SO
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
IF WE HADN'T NEED BUDGET
AVAILABLE AND WE HAD STAFFING
AVAILABLE WE MAY BE ABLE TO
EXPAND THE SERVICES THAT WE
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT ANSWERS THE
QUESTION OR NOT BUT- I CAN'T
SAY THAT J. C. SEATED AT. A
REMARKABLE JOB OF WORKING WITH
CARILLO WE ASKED TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE PP EQUIPMENT TO THE
COURTS AND WERE ABLE TO ORDER
THAT DIRECTLY NOW WHICH WAS
SOMETHING WE DIDN'T HAVE IN THE
BEGINNING AND WE WERE
SCRAMBLING LIKE EVERYONE ELSE
TO. OBTAIN THAT INFORMATION.
ALREADY FOR THAT EQUIPMENT. BUT
YOU TO SEPARATE AND ELSE CARE
TO. VOLUNTEER NAY. AND THE
QUESTION. THIS IS DELAY JUDGE
LATE OUT ALL RESPOND FROM
CENTER CENTER WHY HOUSE GETS
ITS A GREAT A VERY PRACTICAL
ONE- AND WE HAVE LEARNED A LOT
AS MUSEUM ARTS THAT STATED NAY
DO THINK THAT WHILE EVERY
COUNTY HAS DEFERRED HEALTHCARE
AGENCIES IN DIFFERENT STANDARDS
BECAUSE THE KOBE IT IMPACT IS
DIFFERENT IN MOST COUNTIES I
THINK THERE IT'S SAFE TO SAY
THAT THERE IS A CONSENSUS OF
SOME KIND ON BASIC. HEALTHCARE
PRACTICES IT WORLD FOLLOWING IN
THE COURTS- I DO THINK THAT IT
DOESN'T OF MEDIA AS YOU POINT
OUT THE SPACE ISSUE I COME FROM
A COUNTY WE WE'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN TERMS OF TRYING
JURY TRIALS INCLUDING CIVIL
TRIALS BUT WE'VE HAD ARE LOGS
WE'VE TAKEN OUR LUMPS WHERE
WE'VE HAD TO SHUT DOWN TRIALS
WHERE JURORS WITNESSES OR
ATTORNEYS HAVE BE HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE RIGHT NOW LITTLE TRIAL
RESULTING AS YOU HEARD BEFORE
MISTRIALS OR CONTINUANCES AND
HAVING TO DO OVER SO IT DOESN'T
ALLEVIATE THE CHALLENGES SPACE.
AS YOU PUT IT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT IN THE SPACE WE HAVE
TO GET TWELVE OR FOURTEEN WITH
ALTERNATES. IN ONE ROOM. THANK
YOU- CAREER. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- CHAIR- I GUESS
THAT LET ME JUST SAY THAT I'VE
REALLY BEEN IMPRESSED WITH THE
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY- I THINK
WE EVEN GIVEN US A REALLY GOOD
IDEA OF THE CHALLENGES FROM
YOUR OWN PERSPECTIVES BOND ON.
ON IT YOU KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH
THAT A SITUATION WHERE- THE
COURTS HAVE THE FINITE SPACE TO
WORK IN AND THEY HAVE
RESPONSIBILITIES. THAT OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES- IN MANY WAYS
IN TERMS OF THE TREATMENT OF-
THE LEAD AGAINST I'M I GUESS
WHAT I WOULD LIKE. NOT EVERYONE
TO THINK ABOUT IS. BUT YOU KNOW
I TAKE A LOOK AT AT THAT THE
BACKLOGS- THE DATA SUCH THAT IT
IS IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
CASES THAT HAVE BEEN RESOLVED
BY COUNTY AND- AND IT'S GOING
TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE A REALLY GOOD IDEA OF WHAT
YOUR BUDGET AND YOUR STAFFING
NEEDS ARE GOING TO BE TO BE
ABLE TO. GET BACK TO. I TO
NORMAL AND I PUT THAT IN QUOTES.
BECAUSE IF THERE'S EVER A TIME
OR WE HAVE THE RESOURCES IT'S
RIGHT NOW AND IF WE WAIT TOO
MUCH LONGER- THOSE THE AND WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE BUDGETS
ARE GONNA LOOK IN THE OUT YEARS
AND- THE THIS THESE DELAYS AS
WE HEARD TODAY ARE TREMENDOUSLY
IMPACTING THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS AND- THEIR LIVES
HAVE ALREADY BEEN IMPACTED
BECAUSE OF THIS CORONA VIRUS
AND THEN TO ADD. ADD A LEGAL
SYSTEM THAT THEY DON'T FEEL.
SERVES THEIR NEEDS IS- I THINK
IS IT IS NOT A GOOD THING SO- I
WANT IT I WANT TO SEE SOME
CONSENSUS ON SOME OF THAT AND
THE NEXT PANEL IS BEST
PRACTICES. AND I WANT TO GET TO
IT QUICKLY BUT I WANT TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE THERE ARE
SOME. SOME IDEAS THAT THAT-
THAT CAN COME OUT OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES SOME BEST
PRACTICES THAT THEY ALL AGREE
THAT A SHARE AND START DOING.
TO EXPEDITE SOME OF THE CASES-
AND- AND TELL US WHAT YOUR WHAT
YOUR NEEDS ARE AND IT MAY BE
THAT IT'S BRINGING STAFF AND
JUDGES OUT OF RETIREMENT AND
PUTTING THEM. ON A REAL FOCUSED
BASIS ON THE CASES THAT ARE THE
OLDEST WHERE ARE THE- THEY
RESPONSIBILITY TO GIVE THEM A
TRIAL WITHIN A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS OR WHATEVER THE EXPEDITED.
FRAMEWORK IS THAT THAT DOES GET
PRIORITIZED AND THEY THEY GET
DEALT WITH RIGHT AWAY- BECAUSE
IT'S- I JUST THINK IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL. AND SO I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK OF WHAT
THAT WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE
MAKE A PROPOSAL TO US. SO THAT
WE CAN GET IT IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET AND WE CAN WE CAN BE
SUPPORTIVE IN A WAY THAT I
THINK STARTS MOVING THINGS.
MUCH FASTER. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONIES
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S BEEN VERY.
VERY CLEAR THAT YOU'RE LABORING
UNDER A REALLY A BIG BURDEN AND
THE MORE THAT WE CAN. BE
PARTNERS IN THIS I THINK THE
BETTER IT'LL BE. THANK YOU-
ANYONE RESPOND TO THAT ON THE
PANEL. YOU SHAKING YOUR HEAD
YES OKAY- SENATE SENATOR
RUSSELL. YEAH I HEARD- A LITTLE
BIT OF ALL OF ALL OF THEM MIXTA
RESPONSE WITH REGARDS TO THE
ISSUE OF TACKLING BACKLOGS- OR
IT'S PROBABLY MORE CORRECT TO
SAY THAT. I HAVEN'T HEARD A
CLEAR CUT WAY OF HOW TO RESPOND
TO THE BACKLOG WITHOUT GETTING
INTO THE- THIS COURT IN THIS
AREA RURAL URBAN WHATEVER IT
JUST SEEMS TO ME THERE'S-
THERE'S SOME BASICS THERE AND-
I AM VERY- I FEEL MUCH BETTER
HAVING HEARD FROM THE BEST
PRACTICES THAT THERE ARE WAYS
OF ADDRESSING THESE CASES SO.
HOW COME WE HAVE SUCH DIFFERENT
OPINIONS HERE. AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT WE CAN COME UP WITH A PLAN
TO DEAL WITH THE BACKLOG. YEAH.
JUDGE LEONIE DON'T START WITH
THAT OR ANYONE ELSE ONE OF ALL
I BE HAPPY TO. THANK YOU
SENATOR OF NUMBER IN THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO I MEAN- I DON'T
KNOW THAT THERE IS A TREMENDOUS
DISPARITY IN HOW WE TACKLE THE
BACKLOG I THINK WE'RE STILL-DEALING WITH THE- CURRENT
SITUATION AND TRYING TO GET
THINGS THROUGH AND TRYING TO.
GET TO OUR CURRENT CASES SO
THAT WE CAN GET TO THE BACKLOG
BUT I DO THINK THAT THERE BEEN
A COUPLE OF CONSISTENCIES IN
OUR TESTIMONY. AND ONE OF THEM
WELL IT CAME FROM OUR- MS. WE
TALKED ABOUT THE NEED FOR MORE
EMPLOYEES AND MORE JUDGES. TO
SENATOR- CABALLERO COMMENTS.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE DID APPROVE
RETIRED BRITISH ALL RETIRED
JUDGES TO COME OUT AND HELP US
AND- AND A LOT OF OUR COUNTIES
INCLUDING HERE IN ORANGE WE
HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
SO WE ARE UTILIZING THEM. OR
THAT BACKLOG. WE ALSO HEARD
MORE EMPLOYEES WOULD BE
HELPFUL- OR JUDGES WOULD BE
HELPFUL WE'VE BEEN WORKING A
LOT WITH SO LUIS ESPADAS. OF
THE NEW APPOINTMENT SECRETARY
AND I PROMISED AND WE STOPPED
TALKING TO HIM SO HE COULD GET
BACK TO WORK. PRESENT VERY
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL OF US. AS HE
BEGINS HIS NEW TASK AND IT'S A
BIG ONE. BECAUSE ALL THE
COUNTIES RELEASED A NUMBER OF
US. HAVE BACON CD NEED TO BE
FELT SO THOSE ARE SOME CONCRETE
PLANS FOR A GOOD START. BUT I
DO THINK THAT IT'S REALISTIC
FOR US TO COME BACK TO YOU. AS
A BRANCH TO COME BACK TO YOU
WITH A- WITH A BETTER PLAN. A
MORE CONCRETE PLAN THAT
INCLUDES A REALISTIC- COST.
WHILE WE HAVE THE RESOURCES SO
THAT WE CAN WILL START WORKING
ON THAT BACKLOG AS WE STILL DIG
OUT. OF OUR CURRENT. SITUATION
RIGHT. THANK YOU. BOB THANK YOU
OUR PANEL WERE GONNA NOW TURN
TO FOR STONE RIGHT YOU SO- FOR
IS INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS AND BEST
PRACTICES WE'RE WELCOME MORE
CAN BE DONE TO IMPROVE ACCESS
TO JUSTICE DURING THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC AND FUTURE EMERGENCIES
IN THE PANELISTS FOR THIS OR
THE HONORABLE TERRA DO SOL
TELLS FOR THE PRESIDING JUDGE
OF THE SUPERIOR COURT OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE'VE HEARD
LOTS OF REFERENCE TO GOOD
THINGS GOING ON ALAMEDA COUNTY
SOME INTERESTED IN THAT.
KATAMARI THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF INNER CITY LAW. CENTERS A
DIEGO CARDENAS PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF BET SAID ACT LEGAL
SERVICES DAVID DANIELS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENSE COUNSEL MICHELLE
CALDWELL COURT REPORTER FROM
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. AND THE
HONORABLE MARC YOU HOUSE. L. A.
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT AND THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON ACCESS TO JUSTICE
SO JUDGE DISCOUNT. AFTERNOON I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE BACKGROUND
NOISE IT'S LIFE LIVING AND
WORKING IN DOWNTOWN OAKLAND.
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE INVITED TO
SPEAK WITH YOU ALL HERE THIS
AFTERNOON PARTICULARLY UNDER
THE CATEGORY OF BEST PRACTICES
BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
OVER THE LAST YEAR IS REALLY AS
YOU HEARD FROM EVERYBODY SO FAR
TRY TO THE ABSOLUTE BEST THAT
WE CATCH MY NAME IS STARTING TO
TELL I AM THE PRESIDING JUDGE
OF ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT I AM ALSO THE VICE CHAIR.
OF THE TRIAL COURT PRESIDING
JUDGES ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO COME HERE TODAY TO SPEAK TO
YOU ALL ABOUT HOW WE HAVE
MANAGED OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST YEAR BECAUSE AS WE ALL
REMEMBER IT WAS APPROXIMATELY A
YEAR AGO WHEN THIS BEGAN AT
LEAST IN THE PUBLIC MANNER. IN
WHICH IT IS NOW IT WAS ON MARCH
FOURTEENTH THAT ALAMEDA COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT ISSUED ITS FIRST
PRESS RELEASE DETAILING THE
SAFETY OPERATIONS AND
MODIFICATIONS THAT WE WERE
PUTTING IN PLACE TO ADDRESS THE
THEN NEW CORONAVIRUS SPECTER
AND IT WAS A MERE TWO DAYS
LATER ON MARCH SIXTEENTH. WHERE
ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
ISSUED AN ORDER SHUTTING ITS
COURTHOUSE DOORS AND CEASING
ALL COURTHOUSE OPERATIONS IN
VIEW OF THE BAY AREA SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDER THAT SHORTLY BECAME
THE STATE WIDE SHELTER IN PLACE
ORDER. NOW WE WERE UP AND
RUNNING AGAIN AS SOON AS
REASONABLY POSSIBLE BY THAT
FRIDAY MARCH TWENTIETH WE HAD
REOPENED AND WE HAD RESUMED
CRIMINAL AND JUVENILE
OPERATIONS ON A MUCH REDUCED
PLAQUE FOR. BUTFROM THAT POINT
UNTIL TODAY WE GRADUALLY OPENED
ACROSS. ALL CASE TYPES. AND HOW
DID WE DO THAT. WE DID THAT
THROUGH REMOTE OPERATIONS. THAT
IS THE WAY BY WHICH WE
CONSISTENTLY THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
BALANCE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS NECESSARY TO KEEP
COURT USERS AND POOR DEPLOYS
SAFE THROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC.
AS WELL AS ACCOMMODATE AND
SATISFY THE DIRE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE NEEDS THAT ALL
LITIGANTS AND MEMBERS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEAT. SO
HOW DID WE DO THIS I'M GONNA
BRING EVERYBODY BACK TO THE
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS OF THE
CHIEF JUSTICE AND THE
ADDITIONAL REMARKS OF JUDGE
ANDERSON. AS WE RECALL FROM
THAT IT WAS THE BEGINNING OF
APRIL APRIL SIX WHERE THE CHIEF
JUSTICE OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
OF CALIFORNIA. ISSUED A SERIES
OF EMERGENCY RULES THESE
EMERGENCY RULES GAVE LOCAL
COURTS LIKE OUR OWN. THE
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE OUR OWN WHEN
I MERGING SEAT LOCAL RULES. AND
ONE OF THESE EMERGENCY RULES
WAS ESPECIALLY SIGNIFICANT FOR
THE CONTEXT OF THIS
CONVERSATION. AND THAT WAS
EMERGENCY ROLE THREE. THAT GAVE
THE COURTS THE AUTHORITY TO
ORDER REMOTE FOR STUDENTS. IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
THAT IS WHAT WE DID IT
IMMEDIATELY THAT SAME DAY OUR
COURT ISSUED AN EMERGENCY LOCAL
RULES MANDATING. REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS IN ALL CIVIL CASE
TYPES. THAT MEANS CIVIL LIMITED
CIVIL UNLIMITED INCLUDING
COMPLEX IT INCLUDES PROBATE IT
INCLUDES FAMILY. AND WE
SIMILARLY SET UP REMOTE
OPERATING SERVICE THROUGHOUT
OUR COURTS INCLUDING REMOTE
OPERATIONS INTERVIEWS
COUNSELING SESSIONS AND
WORKSHOPS IN OUR ELF HELP
CENTER AS WELL AS A NEW LIVE
CHAT FORUM. INCLUDING FAMILY
COURT SERVICE MEDIATORS AND
CHILD CUSTODY FACILITATORS. WE
ESTABLISH SETTLEMENT CONFERENCE
DEPARTMENTS WE SET UP INFORMAL
PRE TRIAL HEARING CONFERENCES
WE SET UP CASE MANAGEMENT
CONFERENCES WE MODIFIED
CALENDARS WE CONSOLIDATED
RESOURCES AND WE ADDED
CALENDARS BOTH FORMAL AND
INFORMAL TO MOVE TO THIS NEW
REMOTE CLASS FOR. OUR
OPERATIONS HAVE CHANGED
ENTIRELY ACROSS THE BOARD AND
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT WAS THE
ONLY WAY THAT WE COULD KEEP OUR
COURT DOORS OPEN. YOU HEARD
FROM A NUMBER OF THE OTHER
SPEAKERS ABOUT THE DIFFICULTIES
THAT THE COURT HAVE WITH OUR
DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS PRE
PANDEMIC. MOST OF US ARE IN OLD
FACILITIES. OLD BUILDINGS WITH
LIMITED RESOURCES WITH VERY
LITTLE SPACING OPPORTUNITIES.
USING JUST ONE OF OUR TEN
COURTHOUSES ALAMEDA COUNTY AS
AN EXAMPLE. OUR ADMINISTRATIVE
BUILDING WHERE OUR CIVIL TRIALS
ARE HELD THE MAJORITY OF OUR
CIVIL TRIALS ARE HELD. THERE IS
NOT A SINGLE COURT ROOM. IN
THAT BUILDING. THAT CAN
ACCOMMODATE WITH SIX FOOT
SOCIAL DISTANCING TWELVE JURORS.
THE MOST WE CAN MANAGES NINE.
OBVIOUSLY AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE. WHICH IS
WHY WE MOVED TO THE REMOTE
PLATFORM. THAT WAS THE DAY TO
BRING THE LITIGANTS THE COURT
USERS AND ALL OF OUR COURT
PERSONNEL BACK TO COURT TO KEEP
US RUNNING AND OPERATING
THROUGHOUT. SO WHAT DID WE
LEARN FROM THESE REMOTE
EXPERIENCES WELL I DON'T WANT
TO SUGGEST BY ANY STRETCH THAT
THIS HAS BEEN A SMOOTH RIDE
IT'S BUMPY AND IT CONTINUES TO
BE- WE PIVOTED AT AND-
SHOCKINGLY RAPID RATE THAT WE
WOULD NEVER HAVE DONE UNDER ANY
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCE. WE
RECOGNIZE THERE ARE THERE ARE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE THERE ARE TECHNOLOGICAL
GLITCHES THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WE CAN BUILD UPON.
BUT BY AND LARGE WE HAVE
RECEIVED OVERWHELMING POSITIVE
FEEDBACK FROM ALL WHO INTERACT
WITH OUR COURTS. AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE ATTORNEYS THE
LEAD AGAINST THE SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS. OUR
JUSTICE PARTNERS OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS ALL OF OUR COURT USERS
FOR A WIDE VARIETY OF WAYS AND
SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE POSITIVE LESSONS THAT
WE'VE LEARNED IN THOSE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES STARTING
OF COURSE WITH THE USERS AND
SOME OF THIS MAY SOUND A LITTLE
BIT REPETITIVE BECAUSE SO MANY
OF THE SPEAKERS BEFORE ME. HAVE
SPOKEN ABOUT THE SAME POSITIVE
BENEFITS. IN TERMS OF THE COURT
USERS AND THE POSITIVE FEEDBACK
THAT WE'VE RECEIVED. THEY LIKE
REMOTE APPEARANCES BECAUSE THEY
ARE MORE CONVENIENT. BACK ON
DECEMBER FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY A NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AS STAFF
AND ADDITIONAL JUDICIAL COUNCIL
MEMBERS VISIT IT ALAMEDA COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT FOR ONE DAY.
THROUGH A PRIOD OF
APPROXIMATELY SIX HOURS WE TOOK
THEM THROUGH TEN. DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS ALL
DIFFERENT CASE TYPES. FOR THOSE
OF YOU THAT HAVE PHYSICALLY
VISITED OUR COURTS BEFORE AND
THE WAY WERE SPREAD OUT YOU
KNOW THAT NEVER COULD HAVE
HAPPENED. IF WE HAD NOT BEEN
OPERATING REMOTELY. AND MUCH AS
THOUGH THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WERE ABLE TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS IN OUR COURTS. DO USERS
BENEFIT IN THE SAME WAY THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC BENEFIT
IN THE SAME WAY. ATTORNEYS ARE
ABLE TO APPEAR IN MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS. IN MULTIPLE
COURTHOUSES AND IN MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE IN A SINGLE DAY WITH OUT
BURDENING THEIR CLIENTS WITH
THE ASSOCIATED TRAVEL COSTS. OR
THE COST OF SITTING IN A
COURTROOM WAITING FOR THEIR
CASE TO BE CALLED. THE
LITIGANTS THEMSELVES BENEFIT IN
THAT SAME WAY. THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY NEED TO TAKE A FULL
DAY OFF WORK AND SECURE CHILD
CARE OR DEPENDENT CARE OR MAKE
ADDITIONAL ACCOMMODATIONS.
THERE'S NO NEED TO TRAVEL
THROUGH TRAFFIC OR FIND
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND FIGHT
PERFECT PARKING DIFFICULTIES TO
MAKE IT INTO A COURT ROOM.
INSTEAD WITH VERY SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD ELECTRONIC
PLATFORMS. MEMBERS WHO NEED TO
ACCESS OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM
IMMEDIATELY HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY. AND I WANT TO THROW
IN SOMETHING BECAUSE OF THE
COST PIECE FOLKS HAVE ASKED
ABOUT THE DISPARITY IN COSTS IN
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS THIS IS
GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK INTO. AND
IT IS ABSOLUTELY GOING TO VARY
BY JURISDICTION AND BY RESOURCE
IT'S NECESSARY THAT WAY. IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY BECAUSE WE HAD A
REMOTE MANDATE THAT IS WHAT SET
UP OUR COST STRUCTURE OR LACK
THEREOF. SO AT THIS TIME
BECAUSE OF THAT REMOTE MANDATE
THE COURT IS SHOULDERING THE
COST OF THESE REMOTE OPERATIONS
I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG WE CAN DO
THAT. SO IN ONE OF THOSE ASKED
FOR THE FUTURE THAT SOMETHING
FOR ALL OF US TO KEEP IN MIND
BECAUSE ALL OF THIS OF COURSE
COST MONEY. NOW IN TERMS OF
ADDITIONAL PREFERENCES AS TO
THESE REMOTE OPERATIONS ONE
THING TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
SOMETIMES IS NOT BROUGHT OUT.
IS THE COURT EXPERIENCE IN
PERSON. CAN BE FRIGHTENING. CAN
BE INTIMIDATING. CAN BE
AWKWARD. IT IS MOST CERTAINLY
UNFAMILIAR FOR THE MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE. WHO USE OUR SERVICES.
THE NICE THING ABOUT A REMOTE
PLATFORM IS IT TAKES THAT
UNFAMILIARITY AWAY. THE
INDIVIDUAL USER CAN REACH OUT
TO THE COURT CAN PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROCESS CAN GAIN ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FROM THE COMFORT OF
WHERE EVER THEY ARE. AND WE
HAVE SEEN THAT TAKE PLACE IN A
WIDE VARIETY OF CONTEXTS.
THERE'S BEEN TALK TODAY ABOUT
RESTRAINING ORDER HEARINGS FOR
EXAMPLE AND THE URGENCY OF
THOSE COURT PROCEEDINGS AND WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE. RESTRAINING
ORDER HEARINGS UNDERSTANDABLY
ARE SOME OF THE MOST
CONTENTIOUS COURT APPEARANCES
THERE ARE. S. ARCH FAMILY COURT
HEARINGS. IN THESE TWO AREAS IN
PARTICULAR WE HAVE RECEIVED
TREMENDOUSLY POSITIVE FEEDBACK
TALKING ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF
REMOTE APPEARANCES BECAUSE IT
TAKES DOWN THE TEMPERATURE
LEVEL. YOU ARE NOT ONLY NOT IN
AN UNFAMILIAR AREA BUT YOU'RE
NOT FORCED TO SIT ACROSS THE
TABLE. FROM SOMEBODY THAT YOU
ARE IN A VERY ANTAGONISTIC. AND
POTENTIALLY FRIGHTENING
RELATIONSHIP WITH. YOUR
DISTANCED BY THE REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY IN A POSITIVE WAY
THE NEW NAVELS MANY PEOPLE TO
SPEAK MORE FREELY ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEM TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN A MORE OPEN DIRECT
WAY THAT ULTIMATELY HELPS THE
TRIER OF FACT ASSESS THE
VERACITY. AND DETERMINE WHAT'S
THE BEST COURSE OF ACTION IN
ANY PARTICULAR CASE. I THINK
ALSO FOR EXAMPLE OF OUR
COLLABORATIVE COURTS. WHERE WE
HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DEALING WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ISSUES MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
MAY HAVE PTSD. IN MANY OF THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES COMING TO COURT
CAN BE WHAT'S CONSIDERED A
TRIGGERING EVENT. IT TAKES THE
INDIVIDUAL OUT OF THEIR
TREATMENT FACILITY IT TAKES THE
INDIVIDUAL OUT OF THEIR COMFORT
SETTING AND PUTS THEM BACK
POTENTIALLY IN THE SAME KIND OF
TRIGGERING OR TRAUMATIC
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT MAY SET BACK
THEIR REHABILITATIVE EFFORTS.
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REACH THESE PEOPLE. TO
BRIDGE WHATEVER TECHNOLOGICAL
GAPS THERE MAY BE AND BRING
THEM TOGETHER PROVIDING COURT
SERVICES WHILE STILL ENABLING
THEM TO MAINTAIN THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE THAT'S SO NECESSARY FOR
THEIR ON GOING PROGRESS. SO
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES.
ONE OTHER TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
WE'VE TALKED EARLIER TODAY
ABOUT THE ACCESS PIECE AND HERE
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WE LIVE
STREAM ALL OF OUR PROCEEDINGS
VIA AN AUDIO LAKE. WE ALSO
OFFICE OFFER THE MEDIA THE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY TO
SECURE VIDEO ACCESS. WE HAVE
ALSO BENEFITED FROM THE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY THAT
PRESENTS. FOR EXAMPLE THE COURT
IS ALWAYS INTERESTED IN
OPERATION DURING THE RIGHT WAY
SO WE CAN REACH AS MANY PEOPLE
AS POSSIBLE IN AN APPROPRIATE
EVENHANDED UNBIASED MANNER. AS
THE CHIEF HAS LED WE ENGAGE IN
A NUMBER OF SUBJECTS RELATED
ACTIVITIES IN THE SCHOOLS SEX
IN THE EDUCATION PLATFORM. HOW
GREAT IS IT NOW FOR STUDENTS.
INTERESTED IN LEARNING ABOUT
THE COURT SYSTEM ABOUT THE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT ABOUT
THE JUDICIARY AND COURT
OPERATIONS TO BE ABLE TO LISTEN
A LOT. TO WHAT'S GOING ON IN A
COURTROOM DAY TODAY. WE TALKED
ALREADY TODAY ABOUT JURY
SERVICE. AND HOW CHALLENGING IT
IS FOR JURORS TO COME TO COURT
A MISTER PANDEMIC. IT'S
CHALLENGING FOR JURORS TO COME
TO COURT WITH OUT A PANDEMIC.
IN A COUNTY LIKE ALAMEDA AS BIG
AS OURS. IT TAKES TIME. YOU
HAVE TO DRIVE OR SECURE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. TRY AND FIND
CLOSER PARKING WHEN THERE IS
NONE AND THEN SIT IN A CROWDED
JURY ASSEMBLY ROOM PERHAPS ALL
DAY TO RECEIVE YOUR FIFTEEN
DOLLARS. IT'S DISCOURAGING.
WITH OUR REMOTE OPERATIONS
WHICH HAVE EXTENDED TO JURY
TRIALS THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE IN
THE CIVIL CONTEXT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A BETTER YOUR RESPONSE
RATE. WHICH I THINK OF SOME OF
THE REASONS WHY JURORS CANNOT
SERVE ON JURIES AND IN ADDITION
TO DEALING WITH THAT DO YOU
DISTANCE AND TRANSPORTATION
ASPECT THERE'S THE TIMING
PEAKS. IT GOES BACK TO THE
TAKING TIME OFF WORK. TO
MISSING NECESSARY MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS TO DEALING WITH
CHILD CARE INDEPENDENT CARE
CHECK UP AND DROP OFF ISSUES
ESPECIALLY TODAY IN THE TIME OF
DISTANCE LEARNING. BUT WHEN YOU
HAVE A REMOTE JURY TRIAL. WHEN
THE INDIVIDUAL JUROR CAN
PARTICIPATE FROM THEIR OWN
COMFORTABLE SAFE LOCATION. MANY
OF THESE IMPEDIMENTS ARE
REMOVED AND IT IS IN FACT
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF JURORS
WHO ARE ABLE TO SERVE ON THESE
PANELS. IN ADDITION WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE ACTUAL EVIDENCE
PRESENTATION PIECE LET'S GO
BACK TO THINKING ABOUT A
TRADITIONAL CORPORATE. WELL WE
HAVE TWELVE INDIVIDUALS SITTING
IN THE JURY BOX USUALLY LOOKING
AT A WITNESS TESTIFYING SIDE
WHAT'S- ON ONE SIDE OF THE
COURT. ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
COURTROOM YOU MIGHT HAVE AN OLD
TV MONITOR A PULL DOWN SCREEN
OR SOME OTHER DISPLAY MECHANISM
WHERE THE ATTORNEYS OR SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS ARE
TRYING TO SHOW THEIR RESIDENTS
TO THE JURORS. IN THE BEST
SCENARIO IT'S IMPERFECT. WE DO
OUR BEST TO PRESENT AS WELL AS
WE CAN BUT WE ALL DEAL WITH THE
RESTRICTIONS THAT ARE
INDIVIDUAL COURTHOUSES AND
pNICE THING ABOUT OUR REMOTE
COURT JURY TRIAL OR OTHER COURT
PROCEEDINGS. IS THAT THE TRIER
OF FACT WHETHER IT'S A JUDGE
JURY JUROR. IS LOOKING AT ALL
OF THE WITNESSES THE SAME WAY.
EVERYBODY HAS THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THAT
WITNESS DIRECTLY IN FRONT OF
THEM. TO SEE AND HEAR ASSUMING
THAT YOU HAVE THAT STABLE
INTERNET CONNECTION. TO SEE AND
HEAR THE WITNESSES THE SAME WAY.
TO SEE AND HEAR THE EVIDENCE
PRESENTED THE SAME WAY. WE'VE
HAD INSTANCES WHERE YOU'RE ABLE
TO SEE THE WITNESS TESTIFY AND
WITH THE CONVENIENCE OF THE
SPLIT SHARED SCREEN IMMEDIATELY
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE VIDEO
PLAYING THAT THE WITNESSES
TESTIFYING ABOUT. THERE ARE
FANTASTIC OPPORTUNITIES. THAT
REALLY MEET THE NEEDS OF WHERE
OUR COMMUNITY IS TODAY FROM A
TECHNOLOGICAL PERSPECTIVE. AND
FUNDAMENTALLY. WHEN WE HOW THE
STABLE TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM. IT
HAS A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE COURT ACCESS. IF WE
LOOK AT RECENT EXAMPLES OF WHAT
WE'VE SEEN JUSTIN ALAMEDA
COUNTY ITSELF WHERE AS I SAID
WE ARE OFFERING REMOTE
OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS ALL CASE
TYPES. THAT MEANS WE HAVE
ATTORNEYS APPEARING REMOTELY
LITIGANTS APPEARING REMOTELY
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS
APPEARING REMOTELY. WITNESSES
APPEARING REMOTELY SUPPORT
PEOPLE APPEARING REMOTELY
INTERPRETERS CANNOT APPEAR
REMOTELY. THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
MEASURES ARE CLEAR. IN TERMS OF
ACCESS WE'VE TALKED ALREADY
ABOUT THE ABILITY FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL RATHER THAN HAVING
TO TAKE A DAY OFF WORK. TO COME
TESTIFY OR DEFEND THEMSELVES OR
TAKE A POSITION IN AN IN PERSON
COURT HEARING. NOW GETS TO A
CHEER FROM THEIR HOME LOCATION.
WE'VE HAD EXAMPLES WHERE IN
CRIMINAL SENTENCE SIX. SOMEBODY
RECENTLY RELEASED FROM A
LOCKDOWN FACILITY HAS SECURED A
NEW JOB. RATHER THAN HAVE TO
TRY AND TAKE TIME OFF WORK
DURING THAT PROMOTION. WE HAVE
THE INDIVIDUALS CALL IT. ON OUR
ELECTRONIC PLATFORM YOU CAN USE
IT FROM A MOBILE PHONE OR ANY
KIND OF SMART DEVICE. CALL IN
TO COURT AND YOU CAN WITNESS
THAT INDIVIDUAL IN A
CONSTRUCTION UNIFORM. IN THE
PARKING LOT OF THEIR NEW JOB.
PARTICIPATING IN THEIR COURT
PROCEEDING AND ABLE TO RETURN.
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY TO THE SAME
SETTING THAT THEY CAME FROM.
WE'VE SEEN INSTANCES WHERE WE
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL IN A TRAFFIC
PROCEEDING CHALLENGING THEIR
INFRACTION OR THEIR TICKET. I
RECALL ONE WHERE WE HAD
SOMEBODY WITH A BROKEN ARM. IT
WAS CLEAR THAT PERSON WAS NOT
IN A POSITION TO HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DRIVE TO COURT BUT RATHER
THAN HAVE TO CONTINUE THE
MATTER. THAT PERSON WAS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. WE'VE HAD
INTERPRETER CASES WITH.
LANGUAGES THAT ARE LESS COMMON
OR LESS ACCESSIBLE OR NEED
RELAY INTERPRETERS AND WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO LINK THAT WORKS
THROUGH REMOTE TECHNOLOGY.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
THE ADULT CARE PROVIDERS WHO
ARE REQUIRED TO BE AT HOME OR
AT A WORKPLACE WITH THEIR
DEPENDENT. AND IN TERMS OF THE
TECHNOLOGICAL GAP. THERE
CERTAINLY ARE SOME BUT BY WAY
OF EXAMPLE IN THE SECOND REMOTE
JURY TRIAL THAT ALAMEDA COUNTY
ENGAGED. WE CALLED IT WAS A
PREFERENCE CASE WE CALLED IN
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE JURORS OVER SEVERAL
SESSIONS. THEY WERE ALL GIVEN A
QUESTIONNAIRE. AND BECAUSE WE
KNEW THIS TRIAL WAS GOING TO BE
CONDUCTED REMOTELY. WE MADE
SURE THAT THE INITIAL QUESTIONS
INCLUDING QUESTIONS ABOUT WOULD
YOU BE WILLING TO PARTICIPATE
IN A JURY TRIAL REMOTELY. AND
DO YOU HAVE STABLE SECURE OR
TECHNOLOGICAL ACCESS TO BE ABLE
TO DO SO. ALL OF THAT
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE JURORS THAT WERE
CALLED IN. MY RECOLLECTION IS
THAT THERE WERE ABOUT SIX. WHO
SAID THEY DID NOT WANT TO
PARTICIPATE NO REMOTE JURY
TRIAL OR DID NOT HAVE TO
TECHNOLOGICAL CAPABILITY TO
ENABLE THEM TO DO SO. THAT'S
TREMENDOUS IN TERMS OF THE
SHOWER. I CAN GIVE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE THAT GOES TO THE
QUESTION I ASKED EARLIER ABOUT
A FUTURE ASK. WE'VE HAD
SITUATIONS WHERE ATTORNEYS AND
ALBEIT THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF A
WELL RESOURCE CASE BUT WE'VE
HAD ATTORNEYS IN WELL RESTORES
CASES PROVIDE CLEAN TABLETS. TO
ALL OF THIS WERE JURORS IN
THEIR CASES TO ENSURE THAT ALL
JURORS HAD THE EXACT SAME.
TECHNOLOGICAL PLATFORM IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT SAME
ACCESS TO THE COURT PROCEEDINGS.
SCHNAPF IS THERE ARE NO
GUARANTEES. BUT THESE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES OF THE STEPS THAT CAN
BE TAKEN TO BALLOTS THAT
TREMENDOUS NEEDS TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ALL COURT
USERS ALL COURT MEMBERS. YES
GUARANTEED ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
AND BY WORKING TOGETHER WE CAN
ACHIEVE THAT. SO TO THE
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT WE ENVISION
GOING FORWARD WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE REMOTE ACCESS WELL AS
I SAID THERE HAVE BEEN BUMPS
THERE HAVE BEEN GLITCHES THERE
ARE PLENTY OF THINGS. THAT WE
CAN IMPROVE UPON. THE
OVERWHELMING RESPONSE. HAS BEEN
SO POSITIVE AND THE ONLY WAY TO
REALLY BALANCE THOSE TWO ISSUES
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND ACCESS
APPEARS TO BE THROUGH THESE
REMOTE OPPORTUNITIES WE JUST
NEED TO BRING EVERYBODY UP TO
THE SAME LEVEL TO GUARANTEE ITS
UNIVERSALIST CRAWL ACROSS THE
BOARD TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE. SO TO THE QUESTION AS
TO HOW DO WE DO THAT. ALL BREAK
IT DOWN INTO TWO AREAS. NUMBER
ONE STAFF. WE NEED STAFF I
CAN'T SAY THAT OFTEN UNTOUCHED.
AS MISS AMBER HEARD ALREADY
SAID THE STAFF THAT WE HAVE
THEY ARE WORKING NONSTOP THEY
ARE STRESSED THEY ARE STRAIGHT
NO ONE IN THE COURT HAS TAKEN A
BREAK SINCE MARCH OF. TWENTY
TWENTY. USING L. A. COUNTY AS
AN EXAMPLE. IN TERMS OF OUR
BUDGET. OUR STAFF OVER 80% OF
OUR BUDGET. THIS IS WHAT TIES
DIRECTLY TO OUR BACKLOG. WITH
THE BUDGET CUTS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN EXPERIENCE DURING THIS
FISCAL YEAR THE NINETEEN TWENTY
FISCAL YEAR. WE'VE HAD TO
IMPOSE FOR LOS. WE'VE HAD TO
IMPOSE HIRING FREEZE. WE'VE HAD
VOLUNTARY TIME OFF PROGRAMS WE
HAVE ALL KINDS OF BUDGET
REDUCTIONS TO TRY AND KEEP THE
SHIP MOVING WITH OUT A CLOSURE.
THE LACK OF STAFF LEADS TO AN
INCREASE IN BACKLOG. LAST YEAR
OVER 41% OF OUR EMPLOYEES TOOK
SOME KIND OF FORMAL LEACH. ON
TOP OF THAT WE HAVE BEEN
CARRYING A 10% VACANCY RATE AT
LEAST. THAT TELLS YOU WHERE WE
ARE. THAT'S AS MUCH AS A 50%
REDUCTION AT ANY GIVEN POINT IN
TIME NOW I'M NOT SAYING IT'S
THAT WAY EVERY DAY BUT SUFFICE
TO SAY THE NUMBERS ARE SHOCKING.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE BACKGROUND
HAPPENS. WHEN WE TOOK OUR
VOLUNTARY TIME OFF PROGRAM OVER
THE HOLIDAYS AS A COST SAVING
MEASURE. BECAUSE IT WAS THE
HOLIDAYS AND WE ALREADY KNEW WE
HAD REDUCE COURT OPERATIONS WE
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THAT TIME TO
REDEPLOY THE STAFF THAT WE HAD
WORKING TO FOCUS DIRECTLY ON
THE BACK LOCK. AND WE MADE A
SUBSTANTIAL EFFORT TO REDUCE
OUR FILING DELAYS JUST IN A TWO
WEEK PERIOD. WHEN WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE HIRE STAFF
ON A FULL TIME BASIS WE CAN
DEVELOP THAT STAFF TO THE
BACKLOG WE CAN DEVOTE THAT
STAFF TO CASE PROCESSING WE CAN
DEVOTE THAT STAFF TO REMOTE
JURY SELECTION SO THAT WE CAN
GET MORE TRIALS OUT. BUT WE
CAN'T DO IT WITH THIS HUGE
WITHOUT THIS HUGE STAFF HE'S
SATISFIED. AND THEN OF COURSE
THERE'S THE SECOND PIECE WHICH
WE'VE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT NOT
THE TECHNOLOGY ITSELF. ALL
COURTS AND THIS IS WHERE
THERE'S THE DISPARITY IN THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTS. WE ALL ARE
IN DIFFERENT NETWORKS WE ALL
HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
BANDWIDTH WEALL HAVE DIFFERENT
COURTHOUSE STRUCTURES WITH SIX
FOOT CEMENT WALL SEPARATING OUR
INDIVIDUAL COURTHOUSE CHAMBERS.
WE NEED EXPANDED CONSISTENT
RELIABLE BANDWIDTH AND THE
FUNDING TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN. WE
NEED SOFTWARE LICENSES ACROSS
THE BOARD THAT HAS SECURITY AND
CAN ACCOMMODATE MULTI PARTY
PLATFORMS. WE NEED THINGS LIKE
MULTIPLE MONITORS JUDGES THAT
ARE PRESIDING OVER REMOTE
REMOTE JURY TRIALS AND CLERKS
WORKING IN COURT ROOMS WITH
REMOTE HEARINGS NEED DUAL
MONITORS TO BE ABLE TO MANAGE
EVERYBODY GOING ON. WE NEED
ADDITIONAL VIDEO EQUIPMENT AND
THE COURTS WHICH INCLUDE
MODERNIZE DISPLAY CAPABILITIES
SO THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN
COURT CAN BE SEEN COOLEY FROM
EVERY ANGLE. WE NEED UPGRADED
AND EXPANDED VIDEO AND
PROJECTION EQUIPMENT TO ENABLE
THAT EQUAL VIEWING AND ALL
CORPORATES. WE NEED INTEGRATED
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS THAT
MATCH WITH INTEGRATED JURY
SYSTEMS. WE NEEDEVIDENCE
PRESENTATION SYSTEMS THAT ARE
USER FRIENDLY SO THAT MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CAN USE IT
ESPECIALLY THOSE SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS KEEPING
IN MIND THE RESTRAINING ORDER
CASES AND THE SMALL CLAIMS
CASES THAT ARE ONLY GOING TO
INCREASE WITH THE ADJUSTMENTS
IN THE UNLAWFUL DETAINER
RELATED LOSS. WE NEED THINGS
LIKE ELECTRONIC HEADSETS OR
CONFERENCE CALL CAPABILITIES TO
MANAGE THE INTERPRETER ISSUES
THAT YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD SOME
ABOUT. AND WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE MORE
PROACTIVE LIKE ELECTRONIC
RESOURCE LIBRARIES WIFI HOT
SPOTS THE ABILITY TO OFFER OUT
TABLETS SMARTPHONES MOBILE
DEVICES ELECTRONIC EQUIPMENT.
THAT DOES THAT DON'T HAVE THEIR
OWN CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF TO
USE. SO THESE ARE JUST A FEW
IDEAS TO THROW OUT FOR ALL OF
YOU TO CONSIDER AND WHEAT AS
THE COURT LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO PARTNER WITH ALL
OF YOU. TO MOVE THIS PROGRESS
FORWARD. THESE CHANGES WERE
FORCED UPON US. WHAT WE WANT TO
DO NOW IS KEEP ALL THE GOOD
THAT CAME WITH. REFINE THE
PRACTICES IMPROVE UP HONDA. AND
WILL FORWARD IN A WAY THAT
REALLY IS GUARANTEEING THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING EXPANDED ACCESS
TO THE GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE
FOR ALL WHO WANT TO USE OUR
JUDICIAL SERVICES. SO I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE I KNOW WE'RE LATE AND I
KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF OTHER
PANELISTS I APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WITH ME. AND I WELCOME
ANY QUESTIONS NOW OR LATER THAT
ANY OF THE ATTENDEES HALF.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU JUDGE AND
YES WE ARE RUNNING LATE WE LET
IT. SORT OF OUT OF TIME TO
FOLKS AND WE'RE- RUNNING PRETTY
FAR BEHIND- BUT THE INFORMATION
IS GOOD. AND THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS HEARING WAS DESIGNED
TO TRY AND- RESET IT SO OUR
NEXT. HELLO THIS IS ADAM MURRAY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE INNER
CITY LAWCENTER. THANK YOU. I
DON'T SEE MYSELF ON SCREEN BUT
CAN PEOPLE HEAR ME YES BECAUSE
SEE YOU AND HEAR YOU OKAY
WONDERFUL. SO- THANK THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME TODAY MY NAME IS
ADAM MARIE I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE INNER CITY LAW
CENTER WHICH IS A FIFTEEN YEAR
TERM NEED NONPROFIT POVERTY LAW
FIRM LOCATED IN THE SKIN RUN
NEIGHBORHOOD OF LOS ANGELES. WE
FOCUS ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS- WE WORK WITH
CLIENTS WHO ARE EITHER
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS OR
VERY PRECARIOUSLY HOUSED WERE
STRUGGLING TO GET INTO HOUSING
OR RETAIN THEIR HOUSE- AND IT
IS WONDERFUL TO BE WITH YOU
HERE TODAY AND WONDERFUL TO SEE
YOU BRINGING SUCH ATTENTION TO
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC. I HAVE
SOME THOUGHTS I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU BEFORE I DO THAT I
WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS
ON THE PRESENTATION I JUST
HEARD- BY THE HONORABLE JUDGE
FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY WHICH I
THOUGHT WAS ABSOLUTELY
FABULOUS- AND TO ME IS REALLY
MODEL. FOR WHAT SHOULD BE
HAPPENING ACROSS OUR STATE WHEN
I HEARD HER SAY WAS THAT
IMMEDIATELY THE COURT FOCUSED
ON WHAT I WHAT I THINK ARE THE
TWO PILLARS THAT SHOULD BE
DRIVING. OUR CONVERSATION OUR
DECISIONS IN THIS AREA THE TWO
COLORS IN MY MIND OR SAFETY AND
ACCESS TO JUSTICE I WANT HER
THE JUDGE SAYING IS THAT FIRST
THEY MADE SURE THEY WERE BEING
SAFE. AND FOR THAT WHAT THAT
MEANT IS THEY NEED TO BE REMOTE
AND SO THEY MANDATED REMOTE
ACCESS AND THEN THEY SPENT THE
LAST ELEVEN MONTHS FIGURING OUT
HOW TO DO THAT AS EFFECTIVELY
AS POSSIBLE. AND I WOULD NOTE.
THAT WELL IN SOME INSTANCES.
SAY AN AXE. CAN SIT INCOME
DURING. WITH ONE ANOTHER THERE
ARE LOTS OF INSTANCES WHERE
THEY CAN ACTUALLY REINFORCE.
ONE ANOTHER I THINK YOU HEARD
THAT IN THE PRESENTATION JUST
READ ABOUT ALL MEDIA. IS THERE
ARE THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE
AROUND ACCESS THAT MAKE
EVERYBODY SAFER AND THINGS CAN
BE BLOWN AROUND SAFETY THAT
IMPROVE ACCESS AS WELL. SO
THESE AREN'T ALWAYS CONFLICTING
IDEAS AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL. THAT AT THE END OF
THE DAY OUR COURT ROOMS ARE
SAFE. AND THAT WE MAXIMIZE.
ACCESS FOR THE PUBLIC TO OUR
JUDICIARY SYSTEM- SO I HAVE
THREE POINTS THAT I WANT TO-
AND INTERESTING OF THE FACT
THAT THAT AS YOU JUST
MENTIONED- WE ARE WE ARE
RUNNING A BIT LATE THAT I WILL
QUICKLY RUN THROUGH THAT I WANT
TO SHARE. THE FIRST IS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE UNSAFE
PROCEEDINGS IN MANY OF OUR
COURT ROOMS ACROSS THE STATE- I
THINK THE PROBLEM WITH THE
ALAMEDA MODEL ALAMEDA MODEL YOU
JUST HEARD ABOUT. IS THAT IT.
FOR MOSTLY CANCER MANY
LITIGANTS IN THE STATE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE ACCESS TO THOSE
BENEFITS. IN MANY INSTANCES
ACROSS THE BAY DOWN HERE IN LOS
ANGELES PEOPLE ARE STILL HAVING
TO GO INTO COURT. IN VERY
UNSAFE SITUATIONS I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT IT IS NOT JUST
THOSE SITUATIONS THAT WE HEARD
ABOUT FROM THE CHIEF JUSTICE.
WHICH ARE CERTAINLY SOME OF THE
SITUATIONS WHERE THIS IS
HAPPENING ISSUES WITH IT SHE
RACED AROUND THE PEOPLE'S
LIBERTY IS AT STAKE OR THERE'S
A FUNDAMENTAL HEALTH OR SAFETY
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IN PERSON. BUT WHAT
WE ARE SEEING A LOS ANGELES. WE
ALSO HAVE. ROUTINE I TRAFFIC
MATTERS BEING HEARD IN PERSON
SO WE HAVE A CLIENT WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TO PAY THE FINE RELATED
OR CRACKED WINDSHIELD THEIR
ONLY OPTION. IS TO SHOW UP AT A
CROWDED WAREHOUSE AND GO INTO A
CROWDED COURTROOM. AND DEAL IN
WHAT I BELIEVE IS A VERY UNSAFE
WAY WITHOUT CITATION. CENTRALLY
IN OUR VISION MATTERS- AND
THESE ARE DONE IN LOS ANGELES
ON A JUDGE BY JUDGE
DETERMINATION EACH JUDGE HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO THE SIDE. TO
WHAT DEGREE SOMEONE FACING
EVICTION. FROM THEIR HOME AND
THEIR LAWYER IF THEY'RE
REPRESENTED. SHOULDN'T REQUIRED
TO COME INTO. IN WITH THEIR
ANTICS MATTER IF THEY BELIEVE
THEY HAVE A- AND THE RIGHT TO
STAY IN HOME OR WHAT DEGREE
THEY CAN DO THAT REMOTELY- I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID NOT
KNOW THAT THESE AREAS WHERE WE
SEE THE- RATE. THE GREATEST
CONTINUATION OF IN PERSON
PROCEEDINGS OR WHATEVER WE SEE
LOW INCOME LITIGANTS AND MOSTLY
BLACK AND BROWN THAT AGAINST IN
OUR COURT ROOMS- THAT'S MY
FIRST POINT IS THAT THIS
CONTINUES TO GO ON AND
CONTINUES TO GO ON AREAS. THAT
ARE FUNDAMENTALLY UNSAFE AND
THAT ARE NOT ESSENTIAL URGE.
THE SECOND POINT I WANT TO MAKE
IS THAT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AT
LEAST. BUT STILL HAPPY IS IN
SAY THE IDEA THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO CONDUCT IN PERSON
PROCEEDINGS. IN NONESSENTIAL
MATTERS. WHEN WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF THE WORST. PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS THAT OUR COUNTRY
HAS SEEN IN OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS. MAKES NO SENSE TO ME. I
DON'T BELIEVE WHY WE ARE
CONTINUING TO SEE THAT. AS YOU
CAN TELL FROM THE TESTIMONY
TODAY IS ROOTED IN OUR
DECENTRALIZATION OF HOW WE ARE
MAKING THE DECISIONS ABOUT HOW
OUR COURTS ARE OPERATING. SO WE
HAVE SET UP A SYSTEM WHERE
FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT COUNTY
COURTS ON MAKING THE DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN THEIR
COUNTY. AND WHAT'S OPEN AND
WHAT'S CLOSED AND WHAT THE
REMOTE PROCEDURES ARE I'M NOT
EVEN ALWAYS ON FIFTY EIGHT
LEVELS WE HAVE INDIVIDUAL.
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THOSE COURTS
ARE MAKING DIFFERENT DECISIONS
AND IN MANY INSTANCES FOR
EXAMPLE AS I JUST MENTIONED
INDIVIDUAL COURTS WE ACTUALLY.
INDIVIDUAL JUDGES HUNDREDS OF
DIFFERENT JUDGES ACROSS OUR
STATE MAKING THESE DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT IS SAFE AND WHAT IS
NOT SAFE. I BELIEVE THAT THE
CHAOS THAT WE ARE SEEING AND
EXPERIENCING. I DON'T USE THAT
WORD LIGHTLY I REALLY THINK IN
MANY. CASES IT IS CHAOTIC. WHAT
WE ARE SEEING IS BECAUSE- BY
DECENT. AND THAT D. CENTRAL. IS
JEOPARDIZING BOTH SAFETY AND
ACCESS TO JUSTICE I THINK IT'S
VERY TELLING THAT YOU HAVE NOT
HER. IN THE BACK OF A SECOND
YOU HAVE FOR LOTS OF VERY
CREATIVE. VERY HARDWORKING
REPORTS FROM THE COURTS ABOUT
THINGS THEY HAVE DONE TO TRY TO
DEAL WITH THIS PANDEMIC I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT THESE ARE
TOUGH ISSUES AND EVEN THOUGH I
AM. SO VERY STRONGLY ABOUT
THESE THINGS I RECOGNIZE THEY
ARE COMPLICATED I RECOGNIZE
THERE'S LOTS IN THE WEST. BUT
IN THE END OF THE DAY WHAT YOU
HEARD FROM THE COURTS FOR THE
MOST PART WAS HEY WE'VE DONE A
LOT. YOU DIDN'T HEAR THEM SAY
IN COURT PROCEEDINGS THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY CONDUCTING IN OUR
SMALL COURT ROOMS ARE SAFE. AND
I BELIEVE YOU'VE NOT HEARD THAT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS BACK THAT
UP. I'M NOT A PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERT BUT NEITHER ARE THE
JUDGES THAT WE'RE ASKING.
INDIVIDUALLY COURTROOM BY COURT
ROOM OR ACROSS. DEPARTMENTS YOU
MAY THESE. THEY'RE NOT PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS AND WE SHOULDN'T
EXPECT THEM TO BE- I BELIEVE
WHAT WE NEED IS CLEAR
CONSISTENT GUIDELINES. AND
STANDARDS THAT ARE SET
STATEWIDE WHICH BRINGS ME TO MY
THIRD POINT. WHICH IS BUT I
STRONGLY URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO SET MINIMUM. STATEWIDE
SAFETY AND ACCESS STANDARDS FOR
OUR COURTS. I THINK WE HAVE TOO
MUCH OF A DISJOINTED CHAOTIC
DECENTRALIZED PROCESS I
RECOGNIZE YOUR LOTS OF WAYS IN
WHICH THAT CAN BE ADVANTAGEOUS.
BUT IN THIS INSTANCE IS
JEOPARDIZING OUR SAFETY AND
IT'S IN JEOPARDIZING. THE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE. IF I WERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE I WOULD BE
LOOKING TO THE CHEER COLORED
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE. THAT WE
APPLY FOR MANY THINGS ACROSS
COUNTIES AND I WOULD ASK PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS TO TELL ME WHAT
LEVEL OF SAFETY IS APPROPRIATE
IN TERMS OF IN PERSON
PROCEEDINGS. IN TERMS OF WHAT
OTHER PROTECTION SHOULD BE IN
PLACE AT THE VARIOUS LEVELS
THAT WE HAVE OF THAT COLOR
TIERED SYSTEM. AND I WOULD
MANDATE SOME MINIMUM STANDARDS
FOR THE COURTS IN THAT RESPECT.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THAT
THAT THERE IS OFTEN AND
UNDERSTANDABLY. HESITANCY FROM
A LEGISLATIVE BRANCH TO MANDATE
THANKS TO THE JUDICIARY AND
THAT IS APPROPRIATE TO TRY VERY
CAREFULLY THERE. BUT USUAL
COUNSELORS HAD THE AUTHORITY
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PANDEMIC TO SET THOSE MINIMUM
STANDARDS. INDEED THEY HAVE
THEIR INDIVIDUAL COURTS SOME
HAVE SET STANDARDS SOME OF NOT
INDIVIDUAL JUDGES UPSET SOME
SOME HAVE NOT. IT'S A PATCHWORK
THAT DOES NOT HAVE CONSISTENCY
IT IS NOT KEEPING US SAFE IT IS
NOT KEEPING THE PUBLIC SAFE IS
NOT KEEPING LITIGANTS SAFE. IT
IS NOT KEEPING MY LAWYERS ARE
GOING INTO COURT WITH A STAFF
FOR WORKING IMPORTS WERE JURORS
SAY. IN A IN A CONSISTENT
SYSTEMATIC WAY. SO WE NEED SOME
STANDARDS THAT DO THAT WE DO
NOT NEED THE LEGISLATURE I
DON'T BELIEVE TO DICTATE
EVERYTHING THE COURTS THERE'S
LOTS OF ROOMS. THE ROOM FOR THE
COURTS TO INNOVATE AND BE
FLEXIBLE AND IT JUST IN TERMS
OF THE SPECIFICS OF WHAT
NEEDED. WHAT WE NEED A MINIMUM
FLOOR WHEN WE SAY AT A MINIMUM.
IF YOUR ACCOUNT IS. IN THIS
YEAR YOU SHOULD NOT BE HAVING A
IN PERSON. I'M THEY KNEW THESE.
PUBLICLY HEALTH EXPERTS SAID
GUIDELINES FOR WHAT YOU BE
GOING ON. I BELIEVE THAT IF HAD
THE- WE WOULD NOT BE HAVING ANY
REMOTE. PROCEEDINGS CURRENTLY
ARE ALMOST NO REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I BELIEVE THAT OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS WERE
DRIVING WHAT SHOULD BE
HAPPENING ON COURT ROOMS WE
WILL ALL BE LOOKING AT A
SYSTEM. LIKE THE ONE ALAMEDA
HAS AT LEAST FOR THE IMMEDIATE
FUTURE. AND THE LAST POINT I'LL
MAKE I KNOW I SAID IN MY FINAL
POINT IT'LL MAKE ONE MORE.
WHICH IS THAT I THINK THERE'S A
LOT. OF COLLABORATIVE CREATIVE
STUFF THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
DONE AND THAT CAN BE A MODEL
FOR WHAT WE DO. IN LOTS OF WAYS
THAT CAN INCREASE AT CHRIS
ACCESS YOU'VE HEARD FROM
VARIOUS FOLKS. THAT THEY'RE
HOPEFUL THAT SOME OF THE STUFF
WE'VE ALREADY DONE. CAN CAN CAN
BUILD THE BEST THAT DIFFERENT
WORLD IN A DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
JUDICIAL SYSTEM AS WE MOVE INTO
THE AFTER TIMES. IF WE CAN DEAL
WITH A BACKLOG IF WE CAN DEAL
WITH THE OVERWHELMING. SCALE
ISSUES THERE'S LOTS OF POSITIVE
BEST PRACTICES THAT CAN COME
OUT OF THIS THAT CAN MAKE US
MUCH MORE EFFICIENT TO INCREASE
ACCESS. THAT CAN THAT CAN MAKE
IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO PLUG IN
ACCESS JUSTICE- THERE'S LOTS OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCESSING OUR
COURTS BETTER IN THIS CURRENT
SYSTEM IN MANY INSTANCES. WE
NEED TO STATE KEEP THOSE
ASPECTS OF THINGS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WHAT WE NEED TO
CORRECT. THE FUNDAMENTAL LACK
OF SAFETY THAT IS STILL GOING
ON AND TOO MANY OF OUR COURT
ROOMS. AND SO AGAIN I REALLY
CALL IN THE LEGISLATURE TO STEP
INTO THAT VOID. YOU HEARD FROM
MY COLLEAGUE UP NORTH
GENEVIEVE. EARLY LEADER FROM
THEIR ILLEGAL EIGHT WHERE SHE
SPOKE ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS PUTTING IT
TO THE COURTS. THE COURTS ARE
LOOKING TO THE LEGISLATURE BACK
TO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TOO
MANY PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
SOMEWHERE ELSE WE NEED THE
LEGISLATURE TO STEP STEP UP AND
SAY. AT A MINIMUM HERE ARE SOME
STANDARDS GOING TO INNOVATE ON
THAT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
ATTENTION AND BRINGING-
BRINGING. ATTENTION FOCUSED ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK FOR JOINING US
TO. VERY MUCH FOR. YOUR ALL
RIGHT THOMAS RECORDED. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE AS HAS BEEN
NOTED MY NAME IS DIEGO CAR TO
HANNAH AND I HAVE THE HONOR OF
SERVING AS PRESIDENT CEO GETS
OUT OF LEGAL SERVICES. OUR
AGENCY PROVIDE SERVICES TO LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY IN A WIDE ARRAY
OF LEGAL ISSUES INCLUDING
HOUSING TRAFFIC DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND ELDER ABUSE
MATTERS WE ARE VERY FAMILIAR
THERE FOR WITH THE IMPACT THAT
CODE IS HAVING A WIDE CROSS
SECTION OF WHAT AGAINST. I'D
LIKE TO TELL THE STORY OF TWO
DIFFERENT COURTS ONE IS THE
DEPENDENCY COURT HERE IN LOS
ANGELES. AND MONTEREY PARK TO
BE PRECISE. AND THE OTHER IS
THE STANLEY MOSK COURTHOUSE
JUST UP A LITTLE OVER FIVE
MILES AWAY. WHY THE SPOTLIGHT
ON THE DEPENDENCY COURT. THE
DEPENDENCY COURT ADDRESSES A
VERY HIGH NUMBER OF URGENT. ON
BEHALF OF A LITIGANT POPULATION
SIMILAR TO WHAT IS SEEN IN
OTHER COURTS THEY'RE OFTEN LOW
INCOME LITIGANTS THERE OFTEN
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THAT IS TO SAY
THAT THE CASE IS SEEN IN
DEPENDENCY COURT- NOT UNLIKE
THE MATTERS WE NEED AS A LEGAL
AID ORGANIZATION HANDLES. HIGH
STAKES MATTERS HIGH VOLUMES ON
BEHALF OF LOW INCOME LITIGANTS
OF COLOR. WHEN FACED WITH THE
PANDEMIC AND REALIZING THE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO GRANT ACCESS TO
THE COURTS WHILE PROVIDING A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT. THE
DEPENDENCY COURT DECIDED IT
WOULD MOVE TO WEAR UNIFORMS
REMOTE ACCESS PLATFORM ACROSS
ALL ITS COURTS. NAMELY THE WEB
EXPORT PLATFORM. THIS WAS DONE
BECAUSE THE COURT IMMEDIATELY
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO PRESERVE
HEALTH AND SAFETY. HOWEVER THEY
DID NOT LOSE SIGHT OF ENSURING
COURT ACCESS AS A GOAL. TO MAKE
THE TRANSITION TO WEBEX THEY
PURPOSEFULLY AND INTENTIONALLY
CLOSED ALL BUT FOUR COURTS.
WHAT OTHERS WERE BEING
OUTFITTED WITH WEBEX. THEY
UNDERSTOOD THIS WOULD CAUSE A
BACKLOG BUT THEY ALSO WORK TO
HAVE A PRIORITY LIST OF URGENT
HEARINGS THAT WOULD STILL BE
OUT. AND MANY OF THOSE MATTERS
WERE HANDLED VIA STIPULATION.
IF NOT BY REMOTE ACCESS THEM BY
STIPULATION ULTIMATELY THEY
HANDLED THREE THOUSAND CASES BY
ELECTRONIC STIPULATION. AND
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE ADOPTIONS
HEARINGS I WISH THERE WERE
HUNDREDS THAT WERE HANDLED
REMOTELY DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THOSE THREE THOUSAND MATTERS
HANDLED BY STIPULATION OR
HANDLED COMPLETELY OUTSIDE OF
THE COURT THEY WERE FILED.
JUDGES REVIEWED AND SIGNED THE
STIPULATIONS ALL WITHOUT A
HEARING OR APPEARANCES. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES THESE STIPULATIONS OR
FOR THE PURPOSE OF. ISSUE MERIT
THAT IS TO SAY THEY DID NOT
RESOLVE THE ENTIRE CASE BUT
WERE ABLE TO NARROW DOWN THE
ISSUES IN QUESTION. BY JUNE ALL
DEPENDENCY COURTS WERE
OUTFITTED WITH WEBEX. THEY HAVE
NOW BEEN WORKING FOR MORE THAN
SIX MONTHS ON A COMPLETELY
REMOTE ACCESS STRUCTURE AND AS
A RESULT THEY'RE HANDLING
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF CASES
EVERY WEEK USING WEBEX. AND AS
HAS BEEN NOTED BY OTHERS
SPEAKERS THIS IS CARD IS
BECAUSE SOME UNINTENDED
BENEFITS. THE PERCENTAGE OF
LITIGANTS WHO SHOW UP FOR
HEARINGS HAVE INCREASE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE TO TRAVEL. AND
THEY DO NOT HAVE TO TAKE AS
MUCH TIME OFF OF WORK TO GIVE
JUST TWO EXAMPLES. THIS IS NOT
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN STANLEY
MOSK AND PLEASE KEEP IN MIND.
THIS IS NOT ACROSS THE COUNTY
LINE THIS IS WITHIN THE SAME
COUNTY JUST A LITTLE OVER FIVE
MILES AWAY. WHEN IT COMES TO
THE STANLEY MOSK COURTHOUSE WE
ARE SEEING WHAT AGAINST AND
ATTORNEYS. BEING REQUIRED TO
ATTEND COURT HEARINGS IN
PERSON. REGARDLESS OF THE
NATURE OF THE HEARING. FOR
EXAMPLE THIS IS WHERE ATTORNEYS
FOR MY OFFICE HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO ATTEND VARIOUS
UNLAWFUL DETAINER HEARINGS. IN
PERSON. OR PERHAPS WE CAN GO A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER TO THE OTHER
END OF THE COUNTY TO THE SANTA
MONICA COURTHOUSE. THAT IS
WHERE ATTORNEYS FROM OUR
OFFICE. AND ATTORNEYS FROM
OTHER OFFICES. INCLUDING MY OWN
WIFE. ARE REQUIRED TO ATTEND IN
PERSON HEARINGS TO ADDRESS
MINOR INFRACTIONS ON BEHALF OF
CLIENTS. MINOR MATTERS LIKE A
BROKEN WINDSHIELD. OUR DAUGHTER
HAS LOST SLEEP WONDERING
WHETHER HER MOTHER WILL COME
BACK SICK FROM ATTENDING A
COURT HEARING. SO AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE NOTED IT IS
CRITICAL TO HAVE STANDARDIZED
PROTOCOLS POLICIES AND MEASURES
THAT BALANCE BOTH ACCESS TO
JUSTICE AND HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND WE BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME
SIMPLE STEPS THAT ALL COURTS
CAN TAKE YOUR INSURER ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. AND PRESERVE HEALTH
AND SAFETY FIRST WHEN IT COMES
TO SUBMISSION OF DOCUMENTS TO
COURTS COURTS MUST PROVIDE
OPTIONS INCLUDING E. FILING
EMAIL FAX AND DROP OFF IF
NECESSARY. THESE OPTIONS SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE IN ALL MATTERS AND
TO ALL INDIVIDUALS THIS IS A
BOTH ATTORNEYS AND LITIGANTS.
WE HAVE EXAMPLES OF COURTS
WHERE DEFENSE BUT I APOLOGIZE
PLAINTIFFS ARE ALLOWED TO EFILE
AND DEFENDANTS HAVE BEEN
REQUIRED TO FILE IN PERSON. IN
ADDITION THE COURT MUST
ELIMINATE DELAYS IN RETURN
CONFORM COPIES. WHEN IT COMES
TO FEE WAIVERS ALL FEES FOR
REMOTE ACCESS SHOULD BE WAIVED
WHEN A CLIENT IS ELIGIBLE. AND
THIS WOULD INCLUDE ACCESS TO
REMOTE ACCESS PLATFORMS
ELECTRONIC FILING AND REVIEWING
COURT DOCUMENTS THE WAIVERS
SHOULD COVER THE LITIGANT THE
LEGAL AID COUNSEL AND IF
APPLICABLE PRO BONO COUNSEL.
AND THESE WAIVER SHOULD COVER
THIRD PARTY SEATS. AWEBER
SHOULD BE GRANTED ON THE PAPERS
AND IF THERE IS A QUESTION
REGARDING A FEE WAIVER THE
MATTER SHOULD BE SEPARATE
HEARING NOT SIMPLY BOUNCED AND
IF HEARING IS REQUIRED THE
HEARING SHOULD BE HELD REMOTELY.
WE ALSO NEED UNIFORM RULES
REGARDING THE ACCEPTANCE OF E.
SIGNATURES E. SIGNATURES MUST
BE ACCEPTED BY ALL COURTS ON
ALL MATTERS. AND THIS ROLE
SHOULD NOT DEPEND ON THE WHIMS
OF ANYONE INDEPENDENT
INDIVIDUAL BENCH OFFICER OR
COURT CLERK. IN SO FAR AS
HEARINGS WE WOULD URGE FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF UNIFORMED
CLEAR POLICIES AND PRACTICES TO
IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING KOBE SAFETY. THIS
ARTICLE MASS PHYSICAL
DISTANCING. ADEQUATE AIR
CIRCULATION AND- IN ALL OF THE
COURTHOUSE AND IF THIS CANNOT
BE ACCOMPLISHED IT WOULD MEAN
CLOSING COURTROOMS SOME
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD
INCLUDE PROVIDING A UNIFORM AND
ACCESSIBLE PLATFORM FOR REMOTE
APPEARANCES. SETTING SPECIFIC
HEARING TIMES STAGGERING COURT
CALENDARS ONLY SCHEDULING A
NUMBER OF MATTERS THAT CAN BE
CONDUCTED WALLEN'S FORCING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE REQUIREMENTS
AND LIMITING THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE IN EACH COURTROOM.
ESTABLISHING PROCEDURES SO THAT
PEOPLE WERE WAITING TO ENTER
COURTROOM CAN MAINTAIN PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND NOT GATHER IN
LARGE GROUPS. WE REALIZE THAT
THIS MAY CAUSE A DELAY IN
HEARINGS BEING HELD HOWEVER WE
CAN TRY TO ADDRESS THIS BY FOR
EXAMPLE PRIORITIZING MATTERS.
ADDRESS MATTER SUCH AS CASE
HERE CASE MANAGEMENT HEARINGS
OR TRIAL SETTINGS ON THE PAPERS
OR BY STIPULATION. FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE BROUGHT LOS ANGELES
FAMILY COURT SERVICES OFFICE
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE IS RATHER
THAN REQUIRE IN PERSON OR EVEN
REMOTE MEETINGS TO DISCUSS CáC
AND VISITATION MATTERS THIS
OFFICE SENSE FORMS JIM WOOD
AGAINST. AND BASED ON THE
RESPONSES PROVIDED BY THE LATE
AGAINST IF THE PARTIES ARE ABLE
TO SHOW SOME BASIS FOR AN
AGREEMENT WHEN AN AGREEMENT IS
WRITTEN UP IN ISSUE. THIS
COMPLETELY ABOUT ELIMINATES THE
NEED FOR HEARING AND INDEED
ELIMINATES THE NEED FOR THE
COURT STAFF TO HOLD. A MEETING
BETWEEN THE LITIGANTS. WHATEVER
BEST PRACTICES ARE PROBLEMS. TO
BE EFFECTIVE THE COURTS NEED TO
HAVE REGULAR AND CLEAR
COMMUNICATION AND MESSAGING.
COURTS OFTEN RELY ON THEIR
WEBSITES AND WE WOULD THEREFORE
RECOMMEND FOLLOWING SOME COMMON
BEST PRACTICES WHEN IT COMES TO
THEIR WEBSITES. MINIMIZING TAX.
FOLLOWING THE RULES CHAU NOT
TELLING AND SIMPLE NAVIGATION.
TRANSLATING THE WEBSITE INTO
MOST COMMON LANGUAGES SPOKEN IN
THE AREA AND NOT RELYING ON
GOOGLE TRANSLATE OR OTHER
MACHINE TRANSLATIONS.
OPTIMIZING WEBSITES DESIGNSFOR
USE ON MOBILE. PHONES AND
OPTIMIZING WEBSITES FOR
ACCESSIBILITY. AND NOTICES TO
LITIGANTS MUST BE MODIFIED THEY
MUST INCLUDE LANGUAGE REGARDING
METHODS BY WHICH TO ACCESS THE
COURT IN COURT HEARINGS AND
THEY MUST DRAW ATTENTION TO
LANGUAGE FOR EXAMPLE- USING
DIFFERENT COLORED PAGES OR
IMAGES THIS WAS A TOPIC THAT
WAS DEPLOYED BY THE DEPENDENCY
COURT. WHEN THEY ISSUED NEW
NOTICES THEY PUT THESE NOTICES
ON DIFFERENT COLOR PAPER. WE
ALSO WOULD RECOMMEND FREQUENT
TRAININGS FOR JUDICIAL OFFICERS
STAFF AND ATTORNEY. FOR EXAMPLE
THIS PAST DECEMBER BLACKBUCK
PART IN THE L. A. COUNTY BAR
ASSOCIATION EXCUSE ME PARTNERED
WITH THE FAMILY COURT TO
PROVIDED TRAINING ON HOW TO
CONDUCT AN EVIDENTIARY HEARING
AND OR TRIAL REMOTELY. RECENTLY
THE WEEK OF FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH
THERE WAS A MEETING OF THE
FAMILY LAW COALITION THIS IS A
MONTHLY MEETING OF FAMILY LAW
LEGAL SERVICES ADVOCATES AND
THE COURTS WHERE THERE IS A
BACK AND FORTH DISCUSSION ON
HOW TO RESOLVE ISSUES AND
IMPLEMENT BEST PRACTICES. AND
FINALLY WE WOULD RECOMMEND
ENGAGING IN DIRECT
COMMUNICATION WITH LEGAL AID
AND OTHER PARTNERS TO CREATE
AND MAINTAIN OPEN LINES OF
COMMUNICATION AND FORM
PARTNERSHIPS. FOR EXAMPLE LEGAL
AID OUR OFFICES HAVE BEEN
CONSIDERING CREATING CHAOS
WHERE OUR CLIENTS CAN ACCESS
HEARINGS REMOTELY. AND THERE
ARE THE LAW LIBRARY COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIES ARE PART OF THE
SYSTEM AND THEY PROVIDE SUPPORT
AND ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE WHO
CANNOT AFFORD REPRESENTATION
AND DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
ASSISTANCE FROM LEGAL AID. OR
SELF HELP CENTERS THEY CAN
SERVE AS A KEY RESOURCE BY
PROVIDING CLASSES HELP WITH
RESEARCH AND EVEN FREE
CONSULTATIONS WITH VOLUNTEER
ATTORNEYS. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BRINGING ATTENTION TO THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COURTS AND ALL OUR. PARTNERS
I'M RESOLVING SOME OF THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU AND THANKS
FOR BEING CLEAR WITH VERY GOOD
TO. RIGHT MISTER DANIELS. GOOD
HAVE- THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
I'LL TRY BE BRIEF IN MY
COMMENTS DUE TO THE LOW OF THE-
HEARING SO FAR- I WOULD TO-
COMMENT THAT EVERYTHING THAT MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS PANEL OF
SAID I AGREE WITH. THAT I WILL
NOT WE STATE THAT- AS WELL.
WELL I AM CURRENTLY THE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
PRIOR TO THAT I SAY SERVED AS
PER. OF THE ALSO DEFINES OF
MONICA NEVADA I BEEN PRACTICING
I THINK THIS IS MY TWO YEAR IN
FACT SENATOR WHY KASKI YOU MAY
KNOW MY MAN CARE WHITE HOUSE
THE WHO I WORK FOR BACK IN.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE- BECAUSE
OF THAT LET. I'VE BEEN TO
APPEAR IN THE IF NOT ALL OF THE-
IN THE COUNTY SPUR COURT ALL
FIFTY EIGHT. IN THERE IS WIDE
DISPARITY THERE ALWAYS WILL BE
AWAY SPIRIT. FROM TO. WHEN
YOU'VE GOT IT ALL COME JUDGES A
MODOC COUNTY THE OR- VERSUS TO
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY OUR
STUDENTS FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY.
JUDGES IN L. A. COUNTY IT'S
JUST GONNA BE DEBT. BUT THAT.
MEAN WE SHOULDN'T TRY TO COME
UP WITH SOME WITH SOME UNIFORM
WHEN IT COMES TO. ACCESS TO THE
COURTS IN THE REMOTE. SYSTEM
THAT THE L. A. COUNTY IS. I
THINK THAT THAT IS A SPEECH
GREAT. THAT WE CAN YOU. OUR OWN.
THAT TO FOLLOW TO SET UP IN THE-
OTHER CASE. IN PREPARATION FOR
MY TEST MY TODAY I. SOME JUDGE
THAT ARE COLLEAGUES OF IN
SHASTA. L. A. COUNTY DIEGO
COUNTY SACRAMENTO ON FOSTER-
WHERE I SPEND MOST OF MY TIME.
LITIGATING AND- THEY UNIFORMLY
TOLD ME THEY'RE BUSIER THAN
THEY HAVE EVER BEEN. SO IF
THERE'S ANY NOTION THAT THE
JUDGES AND THE COURTS ARE NOT
WORKING BECAUSE OF COURT
CLOSURES. AT THE THAT'S THE- IT
TO STAY LEGAL TERM AT HOGWARTS.
WELL THEY ALL FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
THE LITTLE DUTCH BOY WHO'S
TRYING SAVE THE DAY BY STICKING
A FINGER IN THE DIKE. IN THERE
WAITING FOR- THAT DAY TO BREAK
AND I THINK GONNA. I THINK THAT
WE NEED TO. MOVE FOR WITH A
PLAN A STRONG PLAN TO GET THESE
CASES MOVED ALONG. I WOULD LIKE
TO SPLIT. MY TESTIMONY TO AIR.
THE PREACHER. LITIGATION OF.
AND THEN THE TRIAL OF MATTERS
SUPER COURTS. JUST AT EIGHT
THIRTY I LONG COUNTY ON A-
RESTRAINING ORDER YEAH I WISH I
THE CAMERA TEMPORARY ORDERS
WERE ISSUED J. IN THIS WAS FOR
THE PERMANENT. WE DID IT WE IN
WAS SEEN EIGHT EIGHT THE ALL
THE PARTIES WERE PRESS WE ALL
SEE EACH OTHER AT WHOLE TIME-
THE JUDGE WILL ON TIME HE SAID
BASICALLY THREE MAIN ON HALF
HOUR. YEAH MANAGE WERE POST ON
THE- ONLINE I THAT THAT EVERY
TIME SHE BE REQUIRED TO HAVE
AND I DOT SO THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS WHAT'S ON IN COURTS OF
DAY. HE HAD THREE MATTER OF THE
THIRD THREE MATTER NINE THREE
MINUTES NINE THREE. IN MY
MATTER WAS ACTUALLY SO AT NINE
WE STARTED AT NINE OO. THAT'S
INCREDIBLE IT WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE ROLE ACCESS I CAN'T SAY HOW
MANY TO WHEN I WOULD BE HOURS.
BECAUSE OF COURSE WE'RE WE'RE
LARA AND WE WERE NOT GETTING
THINGS FOR ON A TINY BASE. SO I
THINK FROM FREE TROUBLE STAND.
ONE HUNDRED REMOTE TO THE
COURTS. IS A THING I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE SOME UNIFORMS
RULES ON THAT. I THINK THAT
THOSE LITIGANTS WHO- CANNOT
ACCESS TO REMOTE HEARINGS THAT
MADE WE SEE SOMETHING UP WITH
HIS AND THAT THE JUDGE MELANIE
COUNTY SAID. GIVEN SO THAT THEY-
HAVE A TO EQUAL I. ALBUM UP TO
COURT ROOM THEM SAY IN IN IN IN
THE G. DELIVER. IN FOR OF A
VIDEO CONFERENCE SINCE THEN IT
ASK APPEAR- SO THERE ARE TO
LOSE TO THE OF APPEARANCE HOMES
THAT WE HAVE. WE THINK THE-
DOES NAMES PRACTICE IN THE
LITIGANT- PRACTICE
PRACTITIONERS. NEED MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER GOING TO A NINE PANEL
JURY INSTEAD OF THE TWELVE- I
WOULD NOT HOWEVER WANT THAT TO
BE FORCED UPON ME AS A TRIAL
ATTORNEY. I THINK THAT THAT
SHOULD BE A LEFT IN WE SHOULD
HAVE SOME LEGISLATION THAT SAYS
THAT. IF THE PARTY STIPULATE TO
NINE- JURIST OR IF THE PARTY
STIPULATE. THAT TO SOME OTHER.
POLKA TRIAL AND CHIP AWAY THAT
WE CARRY THE BILL DON'T CASE
FORWARD. AT THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO A WELL. ON. WE SEE
HERE. WELL I ALSO THAT WE TRY
TO STRIVE TO HAVE A SINGLE TO.
PLATFORM GOING- I DO PRACTICING
LAW ENOUGH WHERE THE WE HAD
EVERYTHING DONE PERSON AND THEN
WE WILL TO COURT CALL. COURT
CALL WAS. WE FANTASTIC I NO
LONGER HAD TO TAKE THAT THAT UP
TO WHAT COUNTY. OR FLY DOWN TO
SAN DIEGO FOR A HOUR. WITH COST
ME MY CLIENT. THE FULL TIME AND
MONEY TO HAVE MY HEARD. ABOUT
NOW. COURT CALL WE'RE WE'RE NOW
DOWN INTERIM ACCESS TO THE- I
THINK THAT A YEAR FROM NOW FOR
YEARS AND TEN FROM NOW. WE AS
THE JUDICIAL NEED TO STAY UP
WITH THE- INCOME WITH A PLAN WE
HAVE A SINGLE PLAY. FOR ALL WHO
TO USE THE SAME. THE INCIDENT
BE TEAMS THAT MARK TEAMS
WHATEVER BE- BUT AFTER WE GOT A
HAVE YOU TO. THERE WELL.
WITHOUT REACH WHAT MIGHT
COLLEAGUES I WILL LET ME LEAVE
BACK TO YOU- NO WORRIES JUST
LITTLE IN OUR HOUSE. RIVALRY'S
ALL RIGHT MISS CALDWELL. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU THIS
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MICHELLE
CALDWELL AND I'M AN OFFICIAL
COURT REPORTER IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT AND A
MEMBER OF SEIU I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING A PART OF
THIS PROFESSION SINCE I WAS A
LICENSED BY THE COURT REPORTERS
PORED OVER THIRTY YEARS AGO. AS
MOST OF YOU KNOW SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WAS AUTHORIZED BY AB TWO
FIFTY THREE TO CONDUCT A REMOTE
COURT REPORTING PILOT PROJECT
THE BILL AUTHORIZES THE PILOT
TO BE CONDUCTED IN LIMITED
COURT ROOMS DURING CALENDAR
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY AND ENDED
THIS PAST DECEMBER. THE POINT
OF THE PILOT WHICH PASSED
PRETTY COVE IT WAS TO TEST THE
FEASIBILITY OF COURT REPORTER
APPEARING THE COURT REPORTER
APPEARING REMOTELY IN A
COURTROOM IN FULL EVERY DAY IN
PERSON THREE KOPET OPERATIONS
OUR FIRST TEST WAS IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY BUT IT HAD
CHALLENGES IT WAS A SINGLE
CAMERA AND THE ANGLE WASN'T
ENOUGH FOR REPORTER TO
DIFFERENTIATE EVEN WHO WAS
SPEAKING. THE SOUND WAS TENNEY
AND IT WAS UNFORGETTABLE BUT
OUR I. T. DIVISION WENT TO WORK
RIGHT AWAY TO RESOLVE THOSE
ISSUES BUT IT WAS JUST A WEEK
LATER WHEN MOST COURTROOMS- IN
OUR COUNTY JUST LIKE STATEWIDE
SHUTDOWN OVER COATED AND THE
TESTING WAS STOPPED SO WHAT WE
DID RESUME TESTING LATER IN THE
FALL IT WAS UNDER REMOTE
APPEARANCES AND KOBE CONDITIONS.
PEOPLE MASSED AND WHATNOT. BUT
WE'RE AB TWO FIVE THREE ONE OFF
THEIR OF THE INTO. SO OF PICKED.
AND I SAY SORT OF BECAUSE THE
TYPE OF REMOTE REPORTING MY
COLLEAGUES AND I DO NOWADAYS.
DOES NOT RESEMBLE WHAT AB TWO
FIFTY THREE ENVISIONED CREE
COVE IT. AB TWO FIFTY THREE
ENVISIONED EVERYONE IN THE
COURTROOM EXCEPT THE REPORTER
AND THAT'S NOT HOW WE CONDUCT
BUSINESS NOWADAYS AS YOU ALL
KNOW. IN FACT TO THAT END AB
TWO FIFTY THREE HAS NEVER BEEN
TRULY TESTED BUT FOR THOSE TWO
DAYS NEARLY A YEAR AGO.
ULTIMATELY IS THE REMOTE SYSTEM
GOOD ENOUGH. PERHAPS IT IS. BUT
EVEN IF WE CAN GET TO GOOD
ENOUGH WE HAVE TO MOVE TO THE
NEXT PART OF THE ANALYSIS WHEN
IT COMES TO KEEPING A RECORD.
AND THAT IS GOOD ENOUGH GOOD
ENOUGH. ORDERS ROLE IN THIS
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT ISN'T JUST
TO BE GOOD ENOUGH GUARDINS OF
THE RECORD. OUR REPORTERS ROLE
IS TO BE THE GUARDIANS OF
HISTORY. IF IT IS SET IN A
COURTROOM AND A REPORTER
DOESN'T HEAR IT OR DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT. AND CAN'T SPEAK
UP TO INTERRUPT AND GET IT
RIGHT.IT'S GONE FOREVER IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN AND IT'S NO
LONGER PART OF HISTORY. IT
CAN'T BE REVIEWED OR ANALYZE OR
BE PROCESSED THROUGH ANY FORM
OF CHECKS AND BALANCES. IT JUST
ISN'T OUR PROFESSION. THE COURT
REPORTERS BOARD LICENSING
AGENCY OF EVERY CALIFORNIA
COURT REPORTER WILL TELL US
THAT MUCH. ONE CAN LISTEN TO AN
ARGUMENT WITH INTERRUPTED
CONNECTIONS ARE OUTSIDE NOISE
AND DISTRACTIONS. AND GET THE
GIST OF WHAT SOMEONE SAYING
EXACTLY LIKE ELECTRONIC
RECORDING DOES. AND A CORD
INJURY CAN EVEN MAKE A DECISION
BASED ON THAT INCOMPLETE
RECORD. BUT AS WE ALL KNOW THAT
END RESULT IS ULTIMATELY
INCONSEQUENTIAL. HOW THE COURT
OR JURY GOT TO THAT END RESULT
IS ULTIMATELY WHAT MATTERS. THE
CONTENT ISWHAT MATTERS AND
THAT'S WHAT THE RECORD FROM
THOSE COURTROOM HISTORIANS THE
COURT REPORTERS. BECOMES
INVALUABLE. THERE IS NO APPEAL
NO JUST JUDICIAL REVIEW WITHOUT
AN ACCURATE RECORD OF HOW CORD
INJURY GOT TO THE END RESULT.
IF WE MERELY WANTED A SYNOPSIS
OF THE DAY'S EVENTS WE HAVE
MINUTE ORDERS FOR THAT. AND
WHERE ARE OUR STANDARDS IN THE
COURT ROOM THREE CODED THERE
WAS ABSOLUTE AND NECESSARY
COURTROOM PROTOCOL. BUT NOW
NOT. YES THEIR GUIDELINES AND
SUGGESTIONS AND BEST PRACTICES
BUT A RECORD IS A RECORD AND
DOESN'T CHANGE FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY. MY COLLEAGUES STATEWIDE
ARE WORKING UNDER EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES EVERY SINGLE DAY.
LITIGANTS LAWYERS AND JUSTICE
PARTNERS ARE CALLING IN AND
PARTICIPATING IN COURT
PROCEEDINGS. ON CELL PHONES
FROM THEIR CARS IN TRAFFIC WITH
OPEN MIKES FROM RESTAURANTS
GROCERY STORES SUMMER LYING IN
BED ORDERING FOOD IN A DRIVE
THROUGH LAUNCHING A BOAT. ARE
BEING SEEN AN EMERGENCY ROOM
THE LIST OF OPEN MIKE SCENARIOS
GOES ON. IT DOES NOT REMOTELY
RESEMBLE THE ORDER OF EVEN THIS
HEARING. NOT EVEN CLOSE IN MANY
MANY COURTROOM STATEWIDE BE
OUTSIDE INTERFERENCES MAKE IT
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO MAKE
AND KEEP A RECORD. AND
SOMETIMES THERE'S JUST NO
ACCESS AT ALL ABOUT FOUR
O'CLOCK EVERY AFTERNOON AND ONE
PARTICULAR COURT THE STATE
ANNOUNCEMENT PLAYS LOUDLY QUOTE
YOUR SESSION HAS ENDED GOODBYE.
LITIGANTS VICTIMS ADVOCATES AND
THE PUBLIC ARE DROPPED FROM THE
CALL COURT JUST CONTINUES AND
NO ONE BATS AN EYE OR WE CAN
ACCESS. AND MANY CALLERS HAVE
NO CAMERAS IF A REPORTER CAN'T
SEE AMOUNTS MOVING HERE SHE
CAN'T ALWAYS DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN SIMILAR WORDS LIKE
FIFTY OR FIFTEEN NON STATION
MATTERS. AND SO IT'S A
REPORTERS RESPONSIBILITY TO
INTERRUPT. BUT TRUTH BE TOLD
THE PATIENCE OF THE SYSTEM IS
WEARING THIN IT'S BEEN ALMOST A
YEAR. TRAINING AND TECHNOLOGY
IS OFTEN NONEXISTENT AND
JUDICIAL FATIGUE IS A REAL
THING BUT THEIR CALENDARS TO
GET THROUGH BACK WELL TO CLEAR
OUT OF AS WE'VE HEARD SO MUCH
ABOUT TODAY. AND SO JUDICIAL
OFFICERS HAVE GONE SO FAR AS TO
DIRECT REPORTERS NOT TO
INTERRUPT. ONE JUDICIAL OFFICER
NOTING THE RECORD DURING JURY
SELECTION THAT IT WOULD BE
QUITE A BIT OF DISRUPTION TO
ALLOW THE REPORTER TO
INTERRUPTING OVER THINGS THAT
ARE QUOTE NOT PARTICULARLY
CONSEQUENTIAL. WHAT IS
CONSEQUENTIAL AND WHAT IS NOT
INCLUDED WHAT IS
INCONSEQUENTIAL ARE NOT
RECORDER BORDERS CALL. HISTORY
AND APPELLATE COURTS GET TO
MAKE THAT CALL NOT A REPORTER.
OUR PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
AND IN FACT STATUTORY AND
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS REQUIRE
THE REPORTERS MAKE EVERY EFFORT
TO MAKE ARRESTS RECORD AS IT'S
HAPPENING. NOT TO CREATE ONE
LATER FROM THE CHEST OF A
PROCEEDING. THE WORDS INAUDIBLE
AND UNINTELLIGIBLE ARE NOT
OPTIONS AS CERTIFIED TRANSCRIPT
THOSE WORDS THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD DOESN'T RECOGNIZE AND
DOES NOT ALLOW US LICENSE YOU
REPORTERS TO USE. THIS IS JUST
ONE EXAMPLE FROM ONE TRIAL
COURT BUT COURT ROOM STATEWIDE
ARE REPLETE WITH EXAMPLES JUST
LIKE THAT. INCLUDING A WAVE OFF
FROM A JUDGE ONE REPORTER SAYS
HERE SHE CAN'T HEAR OR SIMPLY
IGNORING A MUTED MIKE FROM A
TALKING ATTORNEY OR LITIGANT
AND MOVING ON WITH CASES. THESE
THINGS HAPPEN EVERY DAY. LET ME
TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THE CONDITIONS
UNDER WHICH MY COLLEAGUE
STATEWIDE AND I ARE WORKING.
AND HAVE BEEN SINCE THE REST OF
THE STATE WANTED TO SHUT DOWN
IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY.
REPORTERS IN THE COURTROOM ARE
EXPOSED TO LITIGANTS IN CUSTODY
AND OTHERWISE WHO HAVE A RIGHT
TO BE PRESENT IN THE COURTROOM.
THEY'RE OFTEN STICK EXPOSED ON
MASTER IMPROPERLY MASKED. AND
THERE IS LITTLE MASK OR
DISTANCING ENFORCEMENT FROM THE
BENCH COURT SECURITY OFFICER OR
OTHERWISE. SOMETIMES MINUTES
MAYBE HOURS AND PLEXIGLAS IS A
FINANCIAL LUXURY NOT AVAILABLE
IN ALL PROGRAMS. MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE CONTRACTED THE VIRUS FROM
THEIR WORKPLACES MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO TAKE PAID
TIME OFF EVEN AFTER THEY WERE
DIRECTLY EXPOSED TO THE VIRUS
AT WORK. MY COLLEAGUES HAVE NOT
BEEN VACCINATED AND BUT FOR A
FEW SELECT REGIONS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO BE. BUT MANY COURTS
ARE GETTING IT RIGHT SOME
COUNTIES- CONTINUE TO PAY FOR
PAID LEAVE TO EMPLOYEES WHO
NEED TO QUARANTINE. OTHERS DO
NOT. SOME IS HERE TO STRIP
DISTANCING AND SANITIZING AND
HAVE LIMITED CAPACITY AND
OTHERS NOT. SOME I PARTNERED
WITH THEIR EMPLOYEES TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THE COURT FAMILY CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO FIND A
SOLUTION IN THESE DANGEROUS AND
SCARY TIMES. AND OTHERS WOULD
NORTH PLEASE WORKERS. ON BEHALF
OF MY PROFESSION MY COLLEAGUES
WE URGE THE ADOPTION OF SYSTEM
WIDE PROTOCOLS TO HELP ENSURE
THE SAFETY OF COURT WORKERS.
AND TO ENSURE ACCURACY AND
ACCESSIBILITY OF THE RECORD.
BORDERS ALONG WITH THIS YEAH
YOU WELCOME AND REQUEST TO SEE
IF THAT DECISION MAKING TABLE
AND ARE EAGER TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. WE DO AGREE THAT
REMOTE COURTROOMS CAN BE A
VIABLE STANDARD FOR THE FUTURE
BUT WE HAVE LEARNED THROUGH OUR
EXPERIENCES WITHIN OUR
INDIVIDUAL COURTROOMS. IS
SWITCH OUT PROTOCOLS AND
STANDARDS WHEN IT COMES TO
COURT WORKER SAFETY AND THE
PROTECTION OF THE RECORD. GOOD
ENOUGH JUST ISN'T ALWAYS GOOD
ENOUGH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THEN IT IS INTERESTING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT PROJECT FOR
REMOTE REPORT COURT REPORTERS
AND THEN SEE HOW THAT WAS.
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC AT I
THINK IT'S REALLY RAISED A LOT
OF ISSUES. WRITER ARE FEEDING
FINAL SPEAKER FOR THIS PANEL IS
JUDGE YOU HOUSE. AND MUCH OF
SENATOR UMBERG INITIAL NUMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STRONG FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE- I'VE
BEEN WORKING THIS AFTERNOON
CUTTING DOWN MY REMARKS SO I
UNDERSTAND ON THE FINAL HOLD
OUT HERE AND I'M GONNA MAKE
THEM- AS QUICK AS I CAN- I'M
THE CURRENT CHAIR OF THE ACCESS
TO JUSTICE COMMISSION FOR
CALIFORNIA- I'M ALSO A FAMILY
LAW JUDGE ARE HERE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. I'M NOT HERE ON
BEHALF OF EITHER THE BRANCH FOR
ALL OF LOS ANGELES. COUNTY
HOWEVER I DO WANT TO MAKE ONE
COMMENT WE'VE BEEN TALKING A
LOT ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS INSIDE A
COURTROOM WE'VE NOT TALKED A
LOT ABOUT THE FACT IT WELL ALL
OF THIS IS BEEN GOING ON. THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS BEEN
CONTINUING TO WORK ON FORMS AND
RULES- THAT ARE PROVIDE ACCESS
TO THE VARIOUS LITIGANTS SHOP I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT. THAT
THERE'S MORE TO THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH DOWN WHAT OCCURS INSIDE
OF A CORK ON THE CALIFORNIA
ACCESS TO JUSTICE COMMISSION
HAS WORKED FOR THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. TO LOWER OBSTACLES
TO ACCESS TO JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC OFFICIALS
INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
OF THE SENATE AND THE SPEAKER
OF THE ASSEMBLY. THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE WITH A STAKE
IN THESE ISSUES OF OUR
COMMISSIONERS FOR LAWYERS
JUDGES AND COMMUNITY LEADERS
I'M I THINK IN THE FUTURE WE
NEED TO DO TWO THINGS
CONCURRENTLY. ONE WE NEED TO
DETERMINE WHICH OF THE MANY
CHANGES WE'RE GOING TO ADOPT
I'M ON AN ONGOING BASIS AND
WHICH OF THE EMERGENCY CHANGES
THAT HEARD ARE WE'RE GOING TO
REJECT AS WE MOVE FORWARD. AND
SECONDLY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
PREPARE FOR THE INEVITABLE
CRISIS WHETHER IT'S FIVE YEARS
TEN YEARS FIFTEEN YEARS FIFTEEN
YEARS. OR HUNDRED YEARS DOWN
THE ROAD- ACCOMPANYING SECURING
ISN'T. AN EXCELLENT. PAPER IN
THE- SUCH. OF SERVE ACTUALLY
CONSIDER. THE COURTS MUST INTO
CAN. I'M I'M LIKE TO. MAKES
SUGGESTIONS HOW THE COMING.
WORK TO ASSIST CAL. I THINK
EVERYONE TESTIFIED TODAY- NO
THE IMPORT. OF VIRTUAL
APPEARANCES APPEARANCES AND
WITH A HOLD GREAT PROMISE FOR
ACCESS. WEST MAIN ACCESSED
COMMISSION ISSUED A FOR COURTS
ON TO JUSTICE ISSUES ARE THAT
THE REMOTE HEARINGS POST JUDGES
AND COURT STAFF SURGEON
REMARKABLE JOB. INCLUDING SOME
OF THESE CHANGES AND AFTER THE
VICTIM DIMMOCK THERE IS NO
DOUBT THE COURTS WILL NOT AND
FRANKLY CANNOT SIMPLY RETURN TO
THE BUSINESS AS USUAL. RECORDS
NEED SUPPORT TO REDUCE EXPECTS
TECH TONIC TECHNOLOGY SHIFT AND
SINCE THE SHIFT OVER THE PAST
YEAR HAS BEEN BOTH EXPENSIVE.
AND CHALLENGING. THE MOST ACUTE
ACCESSING AFFECT WHO CAN'T THE
MOST OF ACCESS ISSUES OF PEOPLE
WHO CAN AFFORD LAW. I'M THESE
ARE MANY OF THIS PEOPLE WERE MY
LIKELY BEEN UNABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN REMOTE HEARINGS
BECAUSE THEY LACK THE REQUIRED
TECHNOLOGY I THINK WE CAN'T
IGNORE THE FACT THAT- WELL MANY
PEOPLE IN URBAN AREAS ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS TECHNOLOGY. HOW
RELIABLE BANDWIDTH I'M AT THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS I THINK WE HAVE
TO WE HAVE TO REALIZE THAT.
MANY OF OUR PEOPLE IN URBAN
AREAS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
RURAL AND OTHER AREAS SIMPLY
DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE TECHNOLOGY-
BAND WITH THEY DON'T HAVE THE
BASIC TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT'S REQUIRED
ON THE ACCESS CONNECTION IS
WORKING ON A MODEL PROGRAM JUST
SET UP A REMOTE HEARING ACCESS
SITES. THESE WILL BE PLACES
THAT OFFER ONLINE ACCESS A
COMPUTER TERMINAL A CAMERA
MICROPHONE PRINTER. AND A
SCANNER IN A PRIVATE SECURE AND
COVERT NINETEEN SHOULD ASK
ENTER A LOCATION THE SUCH WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO ANYONE IN THE
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO HAS.
NEEDS REMOTE. COURT ACCESS. FOR
TO GET INTO COURT. TO MEET THE
ROLE THE NEW IN RURAL AREAS WE
ARE UNDERTAKING WORK WITH AID
TOURIST FROM HEARING. THE
CRITICAL OF K. LAW LIBRARY
AREN'T DIRECTIONAL LOCATION
LIBRARIES AS HAS ALREADY BEEN
NOTICED- ARE ALREADY
ESTABLISHED ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
AND HAVE PROVIDED SAFE RELIABLE
ACCESS FOR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR MANY YEARS WE
ALSO HOPE TO WORK WITH SUPERIOR
COURTS CITY AND COUNTY
OFFICIALS SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
OTHER LIBRARIES AMONG OTHERS
ABOUT OTHER POTENTIAL
LOCATIONS. WE WILL NEED TO
ESTABLISH A SUFFICIENT NUMBER
OF THESE LOCATIONS ARE WITH
EVERY ADEQUATE ADVERTISING TO
LET THE PUBLIC KNOW THAT THEY
EXIST FOR MAKING SENTIMENTAL
STATEWIDE REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL SUPPORT BUT WE HOPE
TO DEMONSTRATE IN THESE REMOTE
HEARING SUCH HELP NARROW THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND ALLOW ACCESS
TO THOSE CALIFORNIANS DON'T
HAVE. EASY ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY.
ARE WE ALL KNOW THAT IS THE-
ELECTION MONITORING BEGINS THE
COURTS WILL UNDOUBTEDLY FACE
AND US. CASE THE LEGISLATURE
HAS TAKEN CRITICAL STEPS TO PM.
OF THESE CORPORATE BASED
ECONOMIC ABOVE THE CORPORATE
BASED. CRISIS ON BOTH WINTERS
LANDLORDS. HOWEVER MANY COURTS
IN LARGE URBAN AREAS HAVE
STARTED MEDIATION PROGRAMS FROM
LAWFUL DETAINER CASES IT'S
EVERYTHING EVERYBODY'S BEST
INTERESTS TO SETTLE AS MANY
CASES AS WE CAN- MANY COURTS
DON'T HAVE THESE MEDIATION
PROGRAMS. SO WHILE MEDIATION
USING REMOTE TECHNOLOGY CAN BE
EFFECTIVE AGAIN ALSO POSES SOME
OF THE MANY CHALLENGES THAT
REMOTE COURT PROCEEDINGS ARE
THERE ARE DISCUSSED WITH REMOTE
COURT PROCEEDINGS. YEAH THIS
COMMISSION IS WORKING ON THREE
PROJECTS TO HELP COURTS WITH
THESE- MEDIATION REMOTE
MEDIATION POSSIBILITIES. ONE
PROVIDING VIRTUAL TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR MEDIATORS TAUGHT
BY VERY EXPERIENCED VERY
EXPERIENCED MEDIATORS ABOUT HOW
TO RESOLVE IN FICTION DISPUTES
IN THE LANDSCAPE. TO WORKING
WITH ONE OR MORE SUPERIOR
COURTS TO ESTABLISH NEW
MEDIATION PROGRAMS WERE
EXPLORING MEDIAN IN THOSE CASES
PERHAPS A DAY OR TWO IN ADVANCE
OF BEFORE THE COURT DATE WHICH
GIVES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR.
PEOPLE TO NOT HAVE TO PLAN ON
TAKING TIME OFF OF WORK SHORT
AS THAT MAY BE A BIT ALSO CAN
ADDRESSES POTENTIAL CALENDAR-
CROWDING AS THAT WILL HOPEFULLY
GET PEOPLE ARE RESOLVED AND OFF
THE DOCKET BEFORE THE NEEDS TO
COME INTO COURT. EVEN FOR
DIFFERENT. VIRTUALLY REMOTE. WE
DON'T LIKE TO SEE PROVIDE ORGAN.
AND BARS CA. ORGANIZED AND
COACHING FOR LITTLE. BOTH TEN
AND LANDLORDS. WILL HAVE PART
IN SMALL PRESS. ABOUT
BACKGROUND CARDS I'M COOPER
NINETEEN HAS EXPONENTIALLY
WORSENED PROBLEMS WITH
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING CHILD CARE
AND HEALTH CARE. PUBLIC
SOLUTIONS AND SYSTEMS ARE
AVAILABLE BUT OFTEN IT TAKES
KNOWLEDGEABLE RESOURCES AND
ACTIONS AND MANEUVERING TO GET
THAT HELP. FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE IS PROVIDED FOR
RATE REDUCTIONS BUT ONLY FOR
WINTER FILLS OUT THE RIGHT
FORMS AT THE RIGHT TIMES CIVIL
LEGAL AID PROGRAMS PLAN
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY ROLE. IN
ASSISTING LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS SENIORS DISABLED
VETERANS AND OTHERS IN
OBTAINING THE HELP THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PROVIDED. MANY
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR JOBS OR
HAVING HOURS CUT BACK. WORKERS
CAN GET HELP FROM LEGAL AID
PROGRAMS AND OTHER TARGETED
PROGRAMS THAT RECEIVE EQUAL
ACCESS FUND GRANTS A LEGAL
SERVICES TRUST FUND TO
PROCEEDS. FROM INTEREST ON
LAWYERS TRUST FUNDS OR IOTA
FUNDS. FEDERAL AND STATE
COVERED NINETEEN ASSISTANT
ASSISTANCE BUT IS DIRECTLY
AVAILABLE CAN DEPEND ON GETTING
LEGAL HELP AT THE RIGHT TIME
WHEN FOR EXAMPLE THE DEBIT
CARDS WITH UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS GO ASTRAY. THERE ARE
MANY EXAMPLES OF HOW THESE
PROGRAMS ARE GREAT WAYS. TO
VIRTUAL HELP. BUT THE PROBE ARE
UNDERFUNDED YOU BEFORE LIKE.
BEFORE COVERED MY TEAM ALIVE OF
THEIR CALL SO MUCH MORE. WITH
INTEREST RATES FUNDING TAKE A
THE BASIN THAT'S RESERVE FUND
HAS. FROM OVER FORTY SIX
MILLION THOUSAND NINETEEN. WHEN
ESTIMATED TWENTY MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE A 60% DROP
CALIFORNIA SHOULD INCREASE
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR LEGAL
AID PROGRAMS. OFFSET THIS
REDUCTION AND INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF LEGAL AID OF HER
PROGRAMS ARE AVAILABLE TO OUR
CALIFORNIANS THAT SUGGESTED WE
NEED IT. ADDITIONALLY OF THE
COMMISSION IS WORKING ON PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND COMMUNICATION X.
EFFORTS TO HELP MORE PEOPLE
KNOW WHERE AND HOW TO GET
CRITICAL RESOURCE ACCESS
COMMISSION IS AT WORK ON LISTS
OF RESOURCES FOR SOME
HELP CENTERS JUST SURE
CALIFORNIA CORTISOL HELP
CENTERS. CAN DISTRIBUTE THOSE
LISTINGS TO LEGAL HELP AND
OTHER LEGAL SOURCES AREN'T SURE
THEY IT PROVIDES INFORMATION
FOR OUR FOLKS WERE NEEDS FOR
SHELTER FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
HEALTH CARE. ANOTHER PUBLIC
EDUCATION CHALLENGES KNOWN AS
THE KNOWLEDGE. OFFER PEOPLE DO
NOT KNOW HOW THEY ARE. FOR ROCK.
OR A WIFE FROM DIRECT COUNCIL
SALUTE. COVERED BY MAKES OF
THESE. MORE PART TO. SHE THE
ACCESS COMMISSION IS WORK WITH
THE STATE BAR TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE. ARE BEING ADDRESSED. WE
ALL HAVE A DEAL OF WORK AHEAD
OF US. THE JUDICIAL BRANCH AND
LET. ARE WORKING TIRELESSLY
ALMOST WE JUST THESE CONUNDRUM
THE CONUNDRUMS THAT ARE COVERED
PRESENTS. THE COMMISSION IS
IMPORTANT PARTNER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE COURTS LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES
AND THE BAR SHOULD NOT ALWAYS
SKILLFULLY ADDRESS OUR CURRENT
CHALLENGES. BUT YOU DO SO IN A
WAY THAT WILL ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS AND
THEY NEED. TO ADDRESS OUR LEGAL
PROBLEMS FOR SEVERAL YEARS TO
COME. SO ON BEHALF OF THE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE COMMISSION I
THANK YO FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE THESE REMARKS. ARE IF
ANYONE HAS ANY QUESTIONS I'M.
MORE THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH
THAT THE ACT INCLUDES THAT
PANEL OTHER QUESTIONS. ALL IN
ALL ALL HOLD. I'LL HOLD OFF
MISTER CHAIRS BECAUSE WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK HERE I AM IT DID
CROSS MY MIND WE'RE LISTENING
TO LAST PANEL THAT- OVER THE
YEARS WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET WE TOOK ONE
POINT FOUR ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
BILLION FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
FROM FROM THE COURTS. AND WE'VE
NEVER PAID THAT BACK IN SOME OF
THESE ACCESS. IT IS COURTS. OF
THE PHYSICAL CONFINES THAT THEY
HAVE MAY OFFER AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO LOOK AT THAT AS WE
TRYING TO SOLVE THE TCHNOLOGY
GAP TO LOOK AT IT. WITH THE A
DIFFERENT LEADS FROM THE
PANELISTS THAT CAME IN SO. I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU GUYS PUT IN
LONG HOURS HERE. APPRECIATE HI
PRAYER WILL NOT OPEN NOW WE SET
THE PUBLIC HEARING. GOOD FOR
YOU GOOD. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT I
WANT TO THANK THIS PANEL.
PROVIDE SOME VERY GOOD
INFORMATION AND THINGS THAT
THAT CLEARLY THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK TO DO. ALL RIGHT I'M GOING
TO OPEN THIS UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE
ANYONE WHO HAS BEEN WAITING I
KNOW WE HAVE A- ROOM SET ASIDE
AND ONE TWENTY FOUR I DON'T SEE
ANYONE DOWN THERE IS THERE
ANYONE. IN THE PUBLIC ROOM WHO
WANTED TO. SPEAK IN PUBLIC
COMMENTS. IMAGE THING IS BEFORE
WE GO TO PUBLIC OFFICES. OKAY I
DON'T SEE ONE SO HEY LORI-
TERRIBLE SO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I WANT TO THANK
THE PANELISTS THIS IS BEEN.
VERY VERY HELPFUL TO ME AND I
THINK TO OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL- IT IT HAS
ILLUSTRATED SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE USUALLY FACE
I THINK WE BOTH BOTH THE
JUDICIARY AND LEGISLATURE HAS
WE HAVE THE SAME OBJECTIVES-
AGAIN IT'S NOT OUR- JOB. NOR
NOR IT IS NOT OUR JOB TO TELL
THE JUDICIARY HOW TO RUN THE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT BUT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT CERTAIN ISSUES
CERTAIN DISPARITIES- CERTAIN
LIMITATIONS ON ACCESS TO
JUSTICE AND I THINK IT WOULD BE
USEFUL ONE HAVE A PLAN. TO HAVE
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS AND
METRICS THAT ESTABLISHED SORT
OF THE BARE MINIMUM OF ACCESS
TO JUSTICE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WITH THAT I'LL THANK YOU
AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
WHO PARTICIPATED AND IN
PARTICULAR THE PANELISTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT SO PUBLIC
COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE SO I DON'T I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE TO
WOULD LIKE TO. OFFER PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS TOPIC. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THERE TO ON HOLD ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU COULD WE HAVE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE AND
I'D LIKE MEMBERS OF PUBLIC TO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR- SINCE HER
ONLY TO PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
DISCUSSION TO THREE MINUTES
EACH. I HAVE A QUESTION A
COMMENT FROM ONE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CARE MEMBERS LED THE PHANTASM
BEHALF OF THAT CHAU CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING COURT EMPLOYEES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING AS WE DISCUSSED I PUT
DISCUSS TODAY THERE'S BEEN WILD
DISPARITY IN EXPERIENCE NOT
ONLY BETWEEN COUNTIES BUT
BETWEEN CORPORATE. RESULTING IN
VARYING EXPERIENCES WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTOCOL
ADHERENCE PROVISION AFFECT
PLEASE CONTACT TRACING AND
OUTBREAK RESPONSE WELL THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT LOCAL
DISCRETION AS APPROPRIATE FOR
CERTAIN COURT FUNCTIONS PUBLIC
HEALTH PROTOCOLS IN THE MIDST
OF A- MAC CAN NEVER BE ONE OF
THEM. ADDITIONALLY DEFICIENCIES
CAN NEVER BE IMPLEMENTED AT THE
EXPENSE OF OUR WORKERS OR IN A
WAY THAT EXACERBATES EXISTING
ISSUES SURROUNDING EQUAL ACCESS
TO JUSTICE. IT SEEMS THAT WORK
INSTEAD WIDEN THE CHASM BETWEEN
THOSE. OF MEANS AND THOSE
WITHOUT. THE IMPLEMENTED
EFFICIENCY IS THAT. TO ENSURE
THE FRANK TO OF OFFICIAL RECORD
OR EVEN CAUSE ACCESS PROBLEMS
TO THAT OFFICIAL RECORDS ARE
INHERENTLY PROBLEMATIC LAY OFF
THE FURLOUGH DAYS FAILURE TO
HIGHER COURT REPORTER
SUFFICIENT TO COMPLY WITH
JAMISON VIDAK STOCK. AND
FAILURE TO INCREASE STATUTORY
TAX THAT STATUTORY TRANSCRIPT
RATE ALL SERVE ONLY TO INCREASE
THE BURDEN OF OUR OVER EXTENDED
WORKFORCE AND DO NOTHING TO
INCREASE EQUAL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE HOBBIT SOMEONE NUMBER
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON-
TERRORISTIC NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ
ON ACTUALLY SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF TO OUR CLIENTS THAT WILL
KEEP IT BRIEF- MY FIRST
COMMENT. IS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION I JUST WANT TO ECHO
THE SENTIMENT THAT WAS RAISED
BY THE EARLIER WITNESS ON THIS
CALL AS WELL AS WELL AT THE
PUMP THAT WOULD JUST MAKE THEM
SANCHEZ- ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF ENSURING. THAT COURT
REPORTERS AND PUT IN THE BEST
POSITION TO CAPTURE AN ACTOR
INCOMPLETE RECORD OF COURT
PROCEEDINGS. WE HAVE BEEN
COLLECTING ON INFORMATION AND
STORIES FROM COURT REPORTERS
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE
HAVE FOUND THAT THEIR ABILITY
TO CAPTURE A COMPLETE AND
ACCURATE RECORDS BETWEEN THE
THIRD WITH CONSISTENTLY.
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTIES- TO DO
OUR OF THROUGH REMOTE HEARING
AFTER THEIR A LOT OF PROBLEMS
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED- AND
AS WELL AS DESCRIBED EARLIER IS
JUST NOT ANY INTERFERENCE WITH
THE COMPLETE AND ACCURATE
RECORD THEY ALSO CAN HAVE
PROFESSIONAL IMPLICATIONS. OF
COURT REPORTERS HAVE A
STATUTORY MEDICAL OBLIGATION.
TO CAPTURE FULL AND COMPLETE
RECORD AND WIN IT INTERFERED
WITH THEIR LICENSE CAN BE
SUBJECT TO DISCIPLINE NOW WE
HAVE AT LEAST ONE- COURT
ORDERS- IS NOW BEING THREATENED
BY A LITIGANT- WITH A COMPLAINT
TO THE C. R. B. BECAUSE THE
LITIGATE CLAIMS THAT THE- THAT
THE REPORTER DID NOT CAPTURE
ALL OF HS STATEMENTS. DURING
THE HEARING AND IT AND YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES- JUDGES NOT ALLOWING
THE COURT REPORTER. TO STOP.
THE HEARING TO- TO WORK WITH TO
MAKE. THEMSELVES OF WE GET A
COMPLETE LACK RECORD. ON THAT
IS BEEN A REPEAT IN- THAT WE'VE
BEEN HEARING THE STATE AND
THEIR NUMBER PROBLEMS SO WE DO
FOR. DISCUSSION ON THAT EACH
GOING- IN REGARDS TO MY CLIENTS
THE CALIFORNIA. FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE WE ARE STATEWIDE
ASSOCIATION OF CRIMINAL DEFENSE
LAWYERS IN PRIVATE PRACTICE. AS
WELL AS THE TERMS OF WHAT THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER OFFICES. EITHER
A LOT OF DISCUSSION TODAY ABOUT
A VARIETY OF COURT. HEARING
CASE TYPES I INCLUDING
CRIMINAL- AND WHILE WE WERE NOT
PART THE CHANNELS TODAY. WE DO
WANT TO PARTICIPATE AND BE
FULLY AT THE TABLE IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT ANYTHING SHOULD GO FORWARD-
WITH. OUR INPUT AND WITHOUT OUR
FEEDBACK IN CONTRARY TO SOME OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
EARLIER- WHAT WE'VE BEEN
HEARING FROM OUR MEMBERSHIP.
IT'S NOT BAD NOT OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT. FOR THE CURRENT REMOTE
HEARING PROCESS. CONTACT WE
HAVE BEENHEARING A NUMBER OF
PROBLEMS WITH THAT- AND SO- WE
WILL NOT. HAPPY DISCUSS THAT
WITH THE CHAIRS MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WITH JUDICIAL
COUNCIL- WE KNOW THE LINE TO
COMMUNICATION WILL BE OPEN. AND
WE- INTEND TO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT COMMUNICATION. LET ME JUST
ADD REAL QUICKLY THAT I THINK
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS. ONE IS WHAT DO
WE DO DURING THE PANDEMIC. TO
INSURE. AS MUCH ACCESS AS
POSSIBLE. WHILE PROTECTING
HEALTH AND SAFETY. BUT I THE
SEPARATE. IT REALLY SHOULD BE.
AND MAYBE EVEN DEFERRED IS WHAT
DO WE DO AFTERWARDS IF AS ONE
WITNESS STATED WE SHOULD TAKE
SOME OF THE BEST OF WHAT'S
GOING ON NOW. AND GO FORWARD
WITH IT. NOW MAY NOT BE THE
BEST TIME TO DO THAT BECAUSE WE
ARE STILL IN THE MIDST OF THE
TENT AND- WE STILL HAVE NOT
GOTTEN IT RIGHT. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND WE STILL WILL BE
DEALING WITH PANDEMICS FOR A
BIT LONGER. EMERGENCY ORDERS
THAT ARE IN PLACE RIGHT NOW FOR
COURTS TO EXPAND. SIX MONTHS
BEYOND. THE STATEWIDE.
DECLARATION SO THERE'S PLENTY
OF TIME TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
COMES AFTER. AND I. AND OUR
VIEWPOINT IS THE ANSWERS FOR
PANDEMIC ARE GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THE ANSWERS
ARE GOING TO BE. AFTERWARDS SO
COMPLETED TWO IS A CONCERN.
MARINE YOU KNOW FAST TRACKING
SOME CHANGES THAT WILL- THE
ADOPTED POST ENDEMIC YOU THINK-
IS PROBLEMATIC. AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO SHARE WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH OUR CLIENTS IN THEIR
PURSUIT OF DUE PROCESS AND
THEIR PURSUIT OF ENSURING. A
FAIR HEARING- BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE A LOT OF PROBLEMS
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THERE MAY NOT
BE OPENINGS TO DO SOME REMOTE-
BUT WE ARE FAR FROM HAVING
RESOLVE THAT ISSUE. NOW WE
CAN'T IMAGINE THAT WE CAN GET
TO THAT POINT IN SIX MONTHS
FROM NOW WHEN WE ARE STILL
DEALING WITH THE IMMEDIACY OF
THE PANDEMIC SO WE URGE. YOU TO
INCLUDE US IN THE DISCUSSIONS
THANK YOU AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING. THAT DISCUSSION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
THOMAS FROM LINE NUMBER TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CARE AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA ROSE ALICE
FOR WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. WESTERN CENTER WE
BELIEVE THAT TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC
IT IS ESSENTIAL TO LIMIT OR
REDUCE. INCRETIN PROCEEDINGS
FOR NONESSENTIAL MATTERS SUCH
AS MOTIONS THE HEARING AND
AFFECTION BY STRENGTHENING
EVICTION PROTECTIONS PEOPLE
SHOULD NOT BE FORCED INTO AN
OVERCROWDED COURT HOUSE BUT THE
THREAT OF TRANSMISSION OF THE
VIRUS. WITHOUT A COMPELLING
REASON ANOTHER PREVIOUS
ADDICTION DEFENSE ATTORNEY
DURING THE PANDEMIC I CAN MAKE
THE TYPICALLY ATTACKED HOW
OVERCROWDED AND UNSAFE. THE
COURT THE MATH ANGELES ARE. WE
ARE THE DEEPLY CAN THAT THE-
PROPOSED ELEVEN SEVEN. DOLLARS
ALLOCATED BY THE GOVERNOR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE INCOMING
ONSLAUGHT OF ADDICTIONS BEING
RETRACTED. WE MUST IMMEDIATELY
RESTORE THE POTENTIAL FUNDING
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR COURTS TO CORRECT BASIC
HEALTH SAFETY AND ACCESS TO
TRUSTED BY LESIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY OCCURRING. AND LASTLYWE NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
COURT TO ENSURE THAT IT GETS
DUE PROCESS RIGHTS ARE BEING.
ARE PROTECTED BY COMPLYING WITH
THIS SUPREME COURT JANUS
INDICATION THANK YOU AND HAVE A
GOOD EVENING. THANK YOU.
OPERATORS ANY ANYONE ELSE ON
THE LINE. YES SHARE WE HAVE ONE
MORE IN Q. HOW MUCH MY NUMBER
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- HONORABLE CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT TODAY MY NAME IS
SANDY LEVIN I MEAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY LAW LIBRARY AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIANS SHRINE HERE
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
SYSTEM OF PUBLIC LAW LIBRARY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AS WE TRY
TO HELP OUR PATRONS NAVIGATE
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ADVOCATE
FOR THEIR RIGHTS. AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES YOUR CAN YOU ALL
LIBRARIES ARE THE STATING THAT
FOR SELF REPRESENTED INDIVIDUAL
WHEN NO ONE ELSE CAN HELP ME
HELP ANYONE WITH ANY LEGAL
ISSUE REGARDLESS OF INCOME
BACKGROUND OR SUBJECT AREA. WE
HELP PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
VIOLENCE AT HOME PEOPLE WHO
LOST THEIR JOBS AND WANT TO
START NEW BUSINESSES PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO MAKE GUT WRENCHING
DECISION ABOUT A LOVED ONE'S
CARE. TENANTS TRYING TO GET A
GREAT RELIEF OR DEFEND AGAINST
EVICTION THREAT LANDLORDS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE NEW
RULES. AND PEOPLE WHOSE COMMON
CHALLENGES HAVE LED TO DIVORCE
AND CUSTODY ISSUES AND SO MANY
MORE ISSUES. WHEN SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS COM CHOI
COUNTY LAW LIBRARY THEY USE
FEWER JUDICIAL RESOURCES. GET
THEIR MATTERS HEARD MORE
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY AND
EXPERIENCE LESS FRUSTRATION AND
STRESS NAVIGATING THE PROCESS.
SADLY THOUGH OUR ABILITY TO
HELP HAS BEEN LIMITED SH COUNTY
LAW LIBRARIES ARE FUNDED ALMOST
ENTIRELY BY TROUBLE FILING
FEES. IF CURRENT NUMBERS
CONTINUE COUNTY LAW LIBRARY
REVENUE THIS YEAR WILL BE DOWN
50% AS COMPARED TO TWO THOUSAND
NINE. HER OF THIS TO YOU ARE
FOR TODAY. IS TO OUR- FUND
COUNTY LONG. WE CAN DO TO HELP
AND WE TO DO MORE TO HELP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. SURE WE HAVE NO OTHER
SECURE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU I AM GOING TO. CLOSE
PUBLIC COMMENT SENATOR UMBERG
BENEFITS. GIVEN THE- ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THAT THIS IS A VERY
INTERESTING INFORMATIVE HEARING
I'D- I WAS WORRIED WE WERE
GOING TO TRY TO BITE OFF TOO
MUCH BUT GIVEN THE TIMELINESS
OF THIS AND THE NECESSITY TO
GET THINGS DONE WE REALLY
NEEDED TO GET THIS INFORMATION.
AND THEN FIGURE OUT WHAT NEXT
STEPS THAT I THINK COMMON
THREADS ARE. SAFETY AND ACCESS
AND ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
FURTHER THAT. IS WHAT WE REALLY
NEED TO TAKE SERIOUSLY AND I DO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE LOTS OF
BUDGET QUESTIONS HERE. AND THAT
WILL COME UP THROUGH OUR BUDGET
PROCESS AND AT LEAST I HOPE BUT
I ALSO HOPE THAT FOLKS HAVE
HEARD SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
FROM LEGISLATORS AND THE
INTEREST. DECIDERS IN TRYING TO
SOLVE THE ACCESS PROBLEMS WHILE
KEEPING THINGS SAFE SO WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO AND- WE
HAVE A LOT OF GREAT PEOPLE IN
THE RIGHT PLACES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S DONE. THANK YOU ALL
FOR THE HEARING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO ALL OF THE SPEAKERS.
WHO TOLD US THEIR STORIES GIVE
US THEIR PERSPECTIVE AND GIVE
US A LOT OF GOOD INFORMATION TO
WORK WITH. AND I THINK LATER.
AT LEAST A PATH FOR. WORKING
TOWARDS SOME RESOLUTION AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR SENATE
COUNTERPARTS. ON THIS ISSUE AND
MANY ISSUES TO COME. THANK YOU
WITH THAT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.